[Music]
la
he
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
n
d
sorry about that but we are here we are
live at NDC Sydney here from the
beautiful Hilton Hotel well not really
I'm sorry um but we are live and we are
on the YouTubes and welcome everybody uh
this is really exciting we got a whole
day full jam-packed of all sorts of
technical content and um before we get
into all that though there are a few
things that I just need to mention now
first of all obviously we are sort of in
Sydney we're actually everywhere but
it's Sydney that comes together for this
event now please go as a first step to
go to expo. NDC sydney.com because we
could not do this with all the without
all the sponsors that we uh have this
year as well so go and check out all the
uh different booths the virtual booths
um you might even win some stuff right
yep so go there NDC sydney.com
um and then also we need to make sure
that um you stay around for the quizzes
because you can win stuff I know you can
win more stuff so in between all the
talks we're going to have a few
different things that kind of keeps you
engaged entertained make sure that we
have a great day with not just all talk
right but we're Canna also mingle Etc
but there are some quizzes um they're
going to be happening right here on the
stream all you need to do is just access
slider that's it um at lunchtime we're
going to try something new
if you have a ticket to NDC Sydney so
not just on the live YouTube stream
which is free if you have a ticket for
NDC Sydney you can join gather toown um
I'm going to be there and we can hang
out during the lunch break and and it's
sort of like a virtual environment for
conferences and you'll get little Avatar
and everything you should have a link um
if you don't just check out the slack
channels as well there should be all the
information there and then of course
slack I just mentioned slack everything
happens on slack behind the scenes as in
the rooms everything all the
communication is on uh slack and there's
an agenda of course there's an agenda if
you are wondering what is going to come
up on the different tracks so we have
four tracks this year you can go to NDC
sydney.com aggenda and check that out
there as well and you can see everything
that's coming up throughout the day now
the YouTube stream if you're watching
that that is track one so you can see
what talks are going to come up there uh
room
234 are going to be uh for ticket
holders and that's going to happen uh
through slack you can see how you join
all the different talks there on slack
um and then of course um I am not the
only one hosting this year no I know
there are other co-hosts that you will
meet throughout the day we have William
lenberg we have Aaron Powell and we have
David wer uh they're all gonna help out
as well so you're not just GNA be stuck
with my ugly face right um but I think
that's enough I'm just going to make
sure I've done all the housekeeping I've
got little people telling me what to do
here um I think we're good so I'm gonna
go straight into introducing our keynote
now um it's Melissa Howton and Melissa
is a lead software engineer at aenx aenx
however you want to say it she's also
Microsoft MVP in developer Technologies
um and she's focused mainly on the
angular net Azure stuff but she actually
does all the things um so um what else
should I say well Melissa is an advocate
for women in Tech that's something I'm a
big proponent of as well to be honest um
I think we need more diverse crowds in
text that's one of the ways we can do
that um she does a ton of community
things um all over Azure reactor NDC
sitney like this meetups um yeah um I'm
sure she can tell you all about it as
well and of course she travels all over
the world when we can talking at Tech
conferences as well now she is original
from California but she's pretty much an
Aussie now we're not going to give her
back so um I'm hoping Melissa will join
me on the on the stream here oh there
she is good morning H good morning how
you doing yeah pretty good I'm excited
to to be here today even if it is a in a
virtual context I know I know but next
year we're gonna be there live in Sydney
right so yes yes definitely I'm excited
to go up and visit oh man it's um so it
is what it is we're here we're doing
everything that we can online um now
you're going to be talking about
leadership through selfawareness
this morning and is there anything you
want to mention beforehand or should we
just jump straight into your talk what
do you reckon we can jump straight into
it sweet all right so I'm gonna be back
with Melissa with some Q&A if you do
have questions for Melissa throughout
the talk put them in the YouTube chat um
and I will get to him after Melissa has
done her talk take it away awesome thank
you
guys cool so my talk today as large
mentioned is leadership through
self-awareness and you can become a
great leader by understanding yourself a
leader is not determined by a title but
by influence over others and anyone can
become a leader but first you need the
right skills you can build your
leadership skills and become a great
leader through self-awareness in this
talk I will dive into self-awareness
what it is how to develop it how
self-awareness can not only make you a
better leader but how it can help your
followers become leaders too building up
our skills to understand ourselves
creates a positive impact on those
around us and helps us to navigate the
difficult World we're living in and
enables us to become great
leaders but first a little bit more
about me so as lar me mentioned my name
is Melissa hton and I'm a lead software
engineer at a zenic and a Microsoft MVP
in developer Technologies I'm very
active online especially on Twitter so
please do connect with me on there and
share your thoughts as I'm going in my
talk today you may also recognize me as
one of your hosts from NDC Melbourne if
you're able to catch NDC Melbourne and I
am coming to you live from Melbourne so
unfortunately I'm not in Sydney either
but I do hope to go and visit there for
next year's conference we have people
tuning in from all over the world and
people who have helped organize and are
behind the scenes from all over the
world as well so thank you to everyone
for listening today and those who helps
make this event happened I was actually
lucky enough to help with organizing NDC
Sydney this year and helped a little bit
on the agenda committee if you're
thinking I chose myself to be the
keynote you are very much mistaken oh
and my cat is here to say hello of
course hopefully uh he gets his cuddles
out at the beginning but anyways I
didn't choose myself for this talk if
you're able to catch myself um catch my
talk last year it was all about imposter
syndrome which suffer very heavily from
and definitely battled against it in the
leadup for today imposter syndrome is
commonly felt by leaders and my tax
takes for dealing with imposter syndrome
are very related to self-awareness and
my understanding of that and my battle
against it have helped me to build my
self awareness and all these experiences
have fed into my talk that I have for
you
today and my idea for this talk is not a
unique one when writing this talk I
pulled from many different leadership
training courses I've done throughout my
career and I did tons of research found
hundreds and hundreds of Articles and it
scientific studies on this very topic
but the idea for me originated from a
leadership training camp that I attended
and helped to run through Rotary Club
the camp was for young adults aged 18 to
28 called the rotary youth leadership
awards or we called it Riya for short
and it was all focused on leadership
through self awareness the camp was over
a week long in the woods with no phones
no computers completely off the grid I
was lucky enough to attend the camp in
2016 and then become a counselor for a
few few years after that to help teach
others those same skills so this photo
here is of me as the counselor at the
camp with the group of young adults that
I helped to teach I'm not trying to
retrofit this Camp into a conference
talk but that idea of becoming a better
leader by understanding in yourself is
one that has always stuck with me and
many other leadership training courses
that I've done have focused on very
similar Concepts if I could see everyone
there in the audience I would ask you to
raise your hand if you've ever done a
personality test as part of some sort of
corporate training and I'm going to
guess that many of you have and this is
because self-awareness and understanding
ourselves our personalities and our
different traits is one of the key
skills to becoming a great leader to
working well with others and
successfully being in a team knowing how
to improve our leadership skills boils
down to understanding
oneself but first what is leadership
leadership has many definitions in the
dictionary it says that leadership is
the action of leading a group of people
or an
organization I didn't find this too
helpful so I looked up the definition of
lead and it told me that lead is the
initiative in an action an example for
others to follow so if we put this
together we can say that leadership is
the action of taking the initiative and
setting an example for others to
follow now I like this definition
because to me a leader is a someone with
followers you can't force people to
follow you other people will decide
whether you are truly a leader or not
because leadership is not actually about
you it's about those around you and it's
not always the person who may have lead
in their title or manager or executive
or whatever it may be it's the person
who is truly influencing the one who is
motivating supporting and enabling those
around them and the leader could be
anyone at any level with any type of
Personality background or
experience they could be you a manager
on the other hand controls to get a goal
there's that common depiction of manager
versus leader showing the the whole push
and pull where the manager is pushing
the employees from the back giving them
commands and generally not actually
helping out too much where the leader is
out at the front pulling the team
forward and get driving them to their
goal with the right skills attitude in
approach people will follow so what
makes a good leader I would like to hear
from everyone uh watching on the stream
if I can I would love to see comments in
the chat coming from you of what you
think makes a good
leader there are many different
leadership attributes that people have
and anyone can have it at any levels not
just the ones at the front so to you
what makes a good
leader people can be leaders in many
different
contexts we have here a comment saying a
good leader manages the people not the
tasks and everyone works differently yes
that's definitely true it's about
looking at everyone's different skill
sets PE leaders are the ones that are
helping others out and they're even the
ones that are supporting the leader we
have to manage each other's strengths
and weaknesses and work together to
become good great leaders I see
integrity and
empathy leaders are the ones who are
doing the little tasks that other people
may have forgotten they're checking in
with the team members who may be quiet
L there doesn't always have to just be
one leader think about in a a game of
basketball you have the coach the person
making the plays someone who did the
assist and someone who actually shot the
poop who is the leader in that situation
all of them could be leaders is about
taking this step initiative and working
together to make that goal happen I see
more things in the chat accountability
helping you to achieve your full
potential democracy
a leader sets a direction work and works
to clear those walkers for the team and
avoiding those mindf Falls mindfields
someone who
inspires any of us can be good leaders
it's all about taking that step and
initiative and working towards the goal
to make that
happen in the in the game of basketball
they all play that small role to get to
the end and they were leaders in their
own
way so in the words of of Bill Gates as
we look ahead to The Next Century
leaders will be those who Empower others
but how do we Empower others how do we
become that person that others want to
follow how do we separate ourselves from
the
managers and become the leader it all
comes down to understanding ourselves
before we look at taking care of others
we have to F first look at taking care
of oursel and our actions and how they
are deceived by the other people so
self-awareness does not equal leadership
but it is a key
foundation and all those traits that
people mentioned that being
inspirational being accountable having
integrity and empathy delegating those
tasks and managing everything
effectively having active listening and
good communication the ability to really
Empower others that all first starts
with
yourself so selfawareness awareness is
really when you are aware of yourself
it's it's in the name right it's about
being aware of your values your
personality your strengths your
weaknesses your habits and emotions and
how they affect your actions and the
actions of those around you people are
not born completely self-aware yet
research has found that from infancy we
do develop that rudimentary sense of
self-awareness and as we go through life
we continue to build our self- awareness
and you can continue to work on it no
matter what age you are but true
self-awareness is actually quite rare
research estimates that only 10 to 15%
of people are truly self-aware and the
concept of selfawareness has appeared in
text for centuries in the concept of
self pondered by many for even longer
however the official study of self-a
awareness as we know it now began with
shelle Deval and Robert ber Wickland in
1972 Deval and Wickland proposed that at
a given moment people can focus
attention on the external self or your
internal self and your environment
around you this Theory and further
research actually separate
self-awareness into two parts the first
is your internal or your private
self-awareness this is how you look at
yourself looking at your inner self your
emotions and your
actions generally we don't actually
really focus on ourselves but in certain
certain situations it can cause our
attention to be drawn inward take a
moment now to think about how you are
breathing take a deep breath
in and
out generally we don't actually focus on
our breathing but because I mentioned it
to you now and Drew your attention to it
that caused you to become self-aware in
that moment of your breathing so this is
an internal type of self-awareness it
happens when you become aware of an
aspect of yourself in some private way
an awareness of your internal state so
seeing your face in a mirror or suddenly
thinking about the way you're breathing
in and out that is internal
self-awareness and the other part of
this is external self-awareness which is
our awareness how it's
perceived by others of how weef appear
to others so it's an imagined
perspective of our external self and
awareness of your appearance on how
others see you so it's not it's called
imagined or perceived because we are
coming to conclusions on what this
external self looks like to people it's
about our understanding of how our
actions are impacting others so for
example right now I'm giving this
presentation and I'm aware of my body
movements and maybe little things that I
might be doing and I'm coming to
conclusion iions on how you are viewing
me based on them I don't actually know
exactly what you're thinking but I am
having a bit of external self-awareness
because you're watching me and we when
we are aware that we're being watched
and evaluated we often try to behave in
ways that are socially acceptable or
desirable it's like when we tell a joke
that might be a little bit contentious
and we look at our friends to see how
they might react because we know
initially our reaction it might not
actually fit into social norms and we go
off that external self-awareness and the
reactions of others to understand our
external self so the internal
self-awareness tends to result in
behavior that reflects our personal
values and our external self-awareness
can cause Behavior to become more
consistent with that of social
expectations and societal
Norms so from these two types of
self-awareness Dr TOA urch re has
developed four self-awareness archetypes
so if we start in the bottom left corner
we have Seekers this type has both low
internal and external
self-awareness they don't really know
too much about themselves and they're
seeking the information but because
they're not aware they often have
feelings that they are frustrated or
they're stuck if we go up to the top
left corner we have introspector
these people have high internal and low
external they're clear on who they are
and what their values are but they often
don't challenge their views and have a
closed mindset and this can harm their
relationships and limit their
success in the bottom right hand corner
we have Pleasers they have low internal
and high external so they're focusing
more on pleasing other people and how
they appear within Society but this
means they Overlook things that are
actually important to them and they can
make it makes them feel like they're not
being fulfilled and in the top right
corner we have the small few who are
truly self-aware so true self-awareness
is when you have high internal
self-awareness and external they know
who they are but they're continuously
seeking feedback having an open mind and
adjusting to fit into their environment
and improving so building self-awareness
is an ongoing task and we have to ensure
that we are work working on both sides
of our self
awareness because if we don't it can
have a negative
[Music]
outcome if we do not build it correctly
we start to focus on the sort of
negative side effects focusing too much
on ourselves can actually make us a bit
self-absorbed and to the point where
we're not actually paying attention to
the world around us we have that closed
mindset we're not gaining Insight from
others it can also lead to distress
excessive self-consciousness or
anxiety there does tend to be an element
of vulnerability with self-awareness as
well and that negative Focus that comes
with it can really become a downer in a
cycle that we get stuck in people who
are externally self-aware tend to be
very concerned about how how others are
judging them based on their action and
this can lead to what's called eval
ation anxiety in which people become
distressed anxious or worried about how
they're being perceived by others it's
something called the sadder but wiser
Paradox that says learning about
ourselves not only makes us wiser but it
can make us sadder as well so how do we
change this how do we make sure we're
not mulling over these negative emotions
and instead reflecting objectively
aiming to find out
more it starts with asking the right
questions practicing that introspection
understanding ourselves and our
surroundings but introspection alone
does not equal happiness or success and
if we do it incorrectly it can make
things worse so much is hidden that we
in our unconscious mind that we often
end up creating excuses and form
conclusions that are not necessarily
true and research has found that we are
mentally not actually able to pull up
all of our different thought and
feelings from our unconscious mind so we
need to focus on moving forward instead
of fixating on what happened change your
reflective questions from why me to what
can I do to
improve from why is this happening to
what can I do to make it better change
your questions from why to what change
from why am I so upset to what can make
me happy Focus usingg on becoming the
aware archetype building both our
external and internal self-awareness
looking at what you're doing what you
are feeling and what your blind spots
may be focusing on learnings
improvements and moving forward from our
failures there is a technique called the
jhari window which is designed to help
people understand their relationships
with themselves and their others in this
exercise participants are given a list
of adjectives such as cheerful observant
outgoing and they choose those the ones
that they feel best describe themselves
and their own personality then some of
their peers get the same exact list and
they choose adjectives that they think
describes that
person and they you then compare the two
lists and find out which ones match to
describe the subject and those
are what is known to are others and
known to self so that's what fits into
the external self the ones that are
overlapping in other ways fit into the
other four quadrants of the window
depending on what the crossover was for
selecting them but these four areas
represent your your private internal
self things that you wrote down that the
other people didn't or even your blind
spots things that the other people wrote
down that you didn't write out about
yourself and those unknown adjectives
that neither person chose can be your
unconscious self so doing something like
this and and having a tool with impact
from your uh information from your peers
can help us understand how others
perceive us how that matches our
reflection and it helps us to focus on
which areas we may need to work on and
help us to change those questions from
why to
what there's also a lot of positive
outcomes with self-awareness when we
change those questions from why to what
we start to get those positives and
these are really increased understanding
of our self-development needs allowing
us to focus on what really are our
strengths and weaknesses higher levels
of confidence and creativity an open
mindset and the ability to adapt
acceptance and understanding of
ourselves and those around us we become
more proactive at work more willing to
take on a challenge or step up and take
the initiative we understand where we
can fit in what our strengths are and
where we may need to rely on the
strengths of others we end up making
better decisions building stronger
relationships having more effective
communication and research has found
that self-awareness is the most
important capability for leaders to
develop and it can create more
successful and Sai satisfied employees
more profitable organizations and more
effective leaders
if we want to understand ourselves uh
first we need to look at things like our
personality type personalities are
determined by genetics environments and
situations it's really the
characteristic pattern of thinking and
feeling or behaving and there's many
different ways to measure personality
and different types of Personality
scales one that I like is mys breaks
which gives you one of 16 personality
types it's described on the screen and I
know there's a a whole ton of tiny
little information up there and I could
do a full talk just on personality types
alone so if you're interested in
learning a bit more about this I would
definitely recommend uh going and
researching it a bit more afterwards
after this talk but basically what the
personality type does for you is it
looks at where you sit on the scale
within the the different areas it looks
at how you prefer your your world Focus
whether you're more inward or out
outward it looks at how you process
information how you like to make
decisions and how you prefer to live
your outer life or how much structure
you prefer when you're looking to figure
out your personality type I would really
look for some sort of framework that
gives you a breakdown of what each piece
means and where you sit on the scale
because it is a scale and it does move
around as well depending on your
situation some people may have uh
different personalities in a work
context versus a home context so if you
take personality tests in in different
times of your life you may come up with
different
results but doing these kind of
personality tests especially with a team
environment can be really helpful for
understanding your not only yourself but
your team as well have your team take
one of these and share the results with
each other it's beneficial for us to
understand how other people may
naturally feel and versus how we will I
had a previous role where I was working
alongside a colleague and both of us
were in leadership positions and our
roles were overlapping we were
constantly budding heads and just
approaching problems in different ways
and had a whole bunch of communication
issues as a a group we did personality
tests and I actually discovered this
person was on the complete opposite end
of the scale from me and that gave me
some brand new insight having
understanding of how she operated and
liked to operate versus how I did
allowed me to monitor my actions when I
was working with her adjust my
communication style to one that more
suited what she naturally enjoyed and
inevitably it helped us to work better
together as a leader when you understand
your personality and the personality of
your team you can use these insights to
adjust and work better
together in addition to personality
types there's many different types of
leadership styles and understanding what
kind of style works best for us and in a
given situation can really help us to
achieve our goals there's one Theory
that's commonly referred to that it's
called the full range Leadership Model
it has three distinct Styles one of
which is split into two
subcategories the first is L fair and
that's the least active the least more
of a passive engagement as a leader and
it gives all of the power to make
decisions to the followers it gives them
the complete decisions the complete
freedom to make decisions over their
work so this can be highly effective if
your team is super experienced and
really trustworthy but if you have more
of a a junior team that's just starting
out it may not be the best leadership
style to use the next is called
transactional leadership and that's
working on a a motivational system
through rewards and Punishment so the
first subcategory in that is management
by exception
and that's when the management actually
steps in when the team is not meeting
those standards so it can help in
certain situations where the team may be
falling behind and needs their extra
Helping Hands but it can also make the
team a bit frustrated if they feel like
you're taking over for them the next
part of that is transactional contingent
reward which is an active and positive
exchange between leaders and followers
and where their followers are rewarded
or recognized for accomplishing the
achieved object objective so
transactional leadership established is
more of a standardized practices within
an organization so it can be really
useful if your organization is growing
and going through some sort of
transformation the last is called
transformational and this is proven to
be the most effective within the modern
Workforce especially in the world of the
pandemic because trans transformational
leadership is all about that
humanitarian approach and it's driven in
the most Reliant leadership style on
self-awareness it's defined as going
Beyond
exchanging inducements for a desired
performance by developing intellectually
stimulating and inspiring followers to
transcend their own self-interests for a
higher Collective purpose Mission or
Vision transformational leaders are
Visionaries and the Really role models
who drive
organizations the another part of being
self-aware and being a great leader is
all about your communication
communication is often cited as the most
important leadership skill and skill in
working in a team and internal
Communications in the organization can
significantly increase employees
productivity and engagement and with the
recent move to our remote and hybrid
working communication is more important
than ever there's a famous
73855 rule in communication which has
created which was created by Professor
Albert merchan in
1971 and what he says is that the
meaning of a message is 7% verbal 38%
tone and expression and 55% body
language there's a bit of a debate on
the specifics of this Theory and but
researchers agree that somewhere between
70 to 90% of communication is
nonverbal so what does this mean for a
remote Workforce it means that we have
to try our best to still convey those
nonverbal cues in our communication try
to have your camera on when you can and
connect in that way remember that people
are watching you so don't completely
zone out and try to try to look forward
if you can I know it's very difficult
depending on our home situations but do
also pay attention to your tone of voice
even just in your writing in the emails
and messages that you're sending out and
provide supplemental information for
your team to absorb that helps give
context in non-verbal ways use those
emojis and those gifts to support your
message or send a video recording when
you can't have a video chat face to face
in the study of remote leaders ship
communication Effectiveness was also a
strong predicator of leadership
performance so having really effective
communication made it so that leaders
performed better in the remote working
world and communication also comes in
many different forms and styles so
understanding your own style is
essential and communicating that to your
team do you like to have all of the
details beforehand or would you rather
just have a short quick summary of what
happens and vice versa with your
teammates understanding how they like to
be communicated to can help you all work
better
together so acquiring strong
communication skills can help you to
better connect with your friends
colleagues and even your own
leaders for me the ne the most important
leadership skills that is really
underpinned and driven by self-awareness
is emotional intelligence this is
sometimes referred to as EQ which is
emotional quot quotient and how you
measure emotional
intelligence and the very most essential
part in being able to have some sort of
degree of emotional intelligence is
driving your self-awareness so people
with a high degree of self-awareness
have a solid understanding of their own
emotions strengths weaknesses and what
drives them an emotional intelligence is
the ability to recognize those emotions
understand what they're telling you and
realize iiz how your emotions affect
people around you it also involves your
perception of other people's emotions
when you understand what they're feeling
and this allows you to manage those
relationships effectively and use
emotions to your benefit there are four
components that you can break down
emotional intelligence into and the
first really is self-awareness the
ability to detect your emotions and
decipher what those different emotions
that you're feeling May be perceiving
emotions represents a really basic
aspect of emotional intelligence being
able to process emotional
information the next is self-management
being able to control and really harness
those emotions that we have around us
catch ourselves before we react in a
really harsh way because we're we're a
bit angry or maybe we're stressed out
being able to adapt and stay positive we
can use our emotions to F facilitate
different cognitive activities such as
problem solving and thinking and
becoming more
creative an emotionally intelligent
person can really capitalize on their
moods and emotions to really fit the
task at hand and the next category is
looking more external so that's the
social awareness the ability to
understand the emotions that other
people may be having to appreciate
people's that people experience emotions
definitely from ourselves and understand
how emotions may evolve at other time
and really being able to empath
empathize with other people being able
to detect and toer emotions in in
people's faces in in videos or in
pictures and when you look at empathy
that's a a whole another talk in itself
as well but empathy can be broken down
into three main parts the cognitive
section which is I know how you think
the more emotional section which is I
know how you feel and empathetic concern
which is I care about you and you really
need all three of these parts to really
have empathy and strong emotional
intelligence and be able to connect with
others and lastly we have using those
emotions for our relationship management
managing them in other people through
coaching and mentoring and being able to
diffuse the conflict or our situation
and being that
inspiration inspirational leader that
people may need
becoming a diffuser and lifting the team
up when they're down harnessing emotions
both good and bad and managing them to
achieve your
goals so why is this
important well although in the past a
good leader was usually more one who was
you know at the front giving orders what
we now see as a manager and they
controlled the overall performance of
the organization but now everything is
different leaders are expected to be
less authoritarian and more humanitarian
they're expected to motivate and create
a sense of belonging and empowerment
they are expected to make employees feel
comfortable which helps them to work
more effectively people want leaders who
are empathetic and understanding leaders
who still need to go grow emotionally
often have problems managing stress in
difficult situations so growing our
emotional intelligence can help us to
ensure we are able to manage our energy
effectively and have a really solid life
balance and get through the tough times
in a study done by the center for
Creative leadership in the United States
they found that the three main reasons
for executives who fail are difficulty
in handling change inability to work
well in a team and in poor interpersonal
relations people with high emotional
intelligence are curious they want to
learn more and are not afraid to ask
those questions they're able to
empathize and put themselves in the
shoes of others and diffuse situations
they make strong connections and are
great
leaders so how do you build up your
emotional intelligence you can start
really by just creating a list of the
different emotions that you may be
feeling
sit down and write down as many emotions
that you that you actually know of that
you can list and come to your mind
because having a bigger emotional
vocabulary can help us to then match
those emotions to the feelings that
we're having and being able to
articulate them if you find your list of
emotions that you can think off the top
of your head is not very big go out and
do some research and find out what more
emotions there are available in the
world
observe how you react in different
situations and reflect on reactions that
may have turned out poorly examine how
you handled stressful situations and
things that you have done in the past to
help you manage them as well practice
putting yourself in other people's shoes
let's say for example a team member
comes to you very upset because they
they got something wrong maybe they
performed poorly or the outcome was not
to the standard that they expected you
may have seen this happen and thought
man that wasn't a big deal like why are
they upset it it doesn't matter but if
they come to you upset and you tell them
that how do you think they'll react they
might be taken back uh think that you
don't care and frustrated that you're
not willing to help and maybe even
annoyed at you're not understanding of
them instead try to put yourself in
their
shoes understand that people react
differently to different situations and
everyone's definition of hard is
different
acknowledge their emotions and manage
your own to empathize with them in their
situation similarly before you send off
that angry email take a step back it
reflect and revisit with a new mindset
once your emotions have calmed down a
bit if you do react in an emotionally
driven way make sure you take ownership
and responsibility for what has happened
and work to improve it in the future
recognizing your emotions and reactions
are when they happen will help you to
manage them in the future and the
ability to do this is really grounded in
self-awareness another tool that's
really important in self-awareness
leadership is a concept called self-
leadership and that's actually really
just being a leader for yourself is a
process of influencing yourself to
achieve your goals because not all
managers that you may have or are great
leaders and so you can't actually rely
on people around you in leadership
positions to help you up to become
self-aware or become a great leader
sometimes you have to lead yourself and
you can influence your self- leadership
using three key strategies the first is
looking at your behavior having
self-observation setting goals for
yourself making sure that they're smart
goals that you're tracking them and
revisiting them and looking at your
little cues and
idiosyncrasies the next is by building
in Natural Rewards this is making sure
there's enjoyable features in your work
task and building in pleasure making
sure you're doing things that you enjoy
or making things a bit more fun by
making it a little game or giving
yourself some sort of reward at the end
the next is constructive thought
patterns this is evaluating one's
beliefs and assumptions in practicing
positive POS selft talk turn negative
thoughts into positive ones and motivate
yourself to be the best leader that you
can be taken together these strategies
really describe how individuals gain
awareness over their own beliefs and
their behaviors and then constantly can
consciously work towards mentally track
and realize their goals I find these
strategies are actually quite similar to
my tricks to overcoming imposter
syndrome which are to recognize
rationalize and
reflect and building those up and
becoming a self- leader and overcoming
that imposter syndrome helps you to
become a good leader
yourself when you do this other people
then perceive you as a stronger more
capable leader and the overall
performance of a leader is stronger when
they're perform when they're skilled in
leading
themselves closely related to this is
another skill called
self-efficacy and self-efficacy refers
to an individual's belief in their
capability capacity to execute behaviors
necessary to produce specific
performance attainments so self-efficacy
really reflects that confidence we have
in our ability to motivate our control
our behaviors and our social environment
it's the ability to believe in ourselves
to
succeed and this skill is very important
to motivation to resilience getting up
when when times are tough and keep going
at it to taking on challenging problems
stepping outside of our comfort zone and
becoming more engaged in our work
Studies have shown that when individuals
feel confident to lead it positively
impacts people's evaluation of them and
their followers see them as a more capab
capable leader so you can develop
self-efficacy through experience seeing
others around around you succeed and
support and persuasion from your team
and the people around you and it can
help you to manage your psychological
responses so working on these skills
will make us more confident stronger
leaders so leadership and building up
all these benefits of self-awareness do
not just benefit us they benefit our
followers the most important people in
leadership in being a leader they are
the people who put us in that position
in the first place they're they see us
as role models and end up modeling our
Behavior they using our success and our
our openness and our awareness as
motivation for themselves it helps them
to build up their self-efficacy and
their Pursuit for
self-awareness and you can also share
your knowledge and encourage the
learnings and encourage your team to
reflect coach rather than give answers
and use something called the fivey
technique to get to the real root of the
problem which is all about asking why
five times it helps you to shed root
shed light on the situation by getting
to the root of the problem those
continual questions help you to get what
is really happening beneath I once had a
manager who I actually can see on the
the YouTube chat today Adam Watkins he's
watching shout out to you but I want had
him as a manager and he pretty much
answered all of my questions with
questions and at the time I did find it
a bit frustrating but it was very useful
for helping me to get to the root of the
situation and guide myself in my
introspection I would ask him should I
apply to the Ry Leadership Camp he would
say what do you think I would say I'm
thinking it's a good experience I don't
know what do you what do you think and
he would say why and it would keep keep
going like that inevitably in the end I
would answer my own questions and his
line of questioning would lead me to
that answer encouraging my
introspection and you can do this for
your followers as well a study was
actually published earlier this year
that was looking at the connection of
self leader self-awareness and follow
leadership as well and basically it said
that if a leader has strong
self-awareness
that will feed into their ability to
build up self leadership which in turn
raises their self efficacy which in turn
makes their followers more likely to
become leaders and more likely to be
nominated for
promotion so having that self-awareness
as a leader helps your followers to
build their self-awareness themselves
and in turn it be makes them become more
likely to be leaders themselves as I
mentioned at the begin beginning leaders
can be an indie context there's not just
one at the top there's people in many
different situations so you need many
leaders in your team to be successful
and reach that
goal and there's also benefits that go
on to the organization Empirical
research has consistently demonstrated
that leadership behaviors influence
organizational performance workers are
more trusting of leaders who are
self-aware they're more inspired and
more MO ated external relationships with
clients and customers end up being
stronger in the words of Maya Angelo
I've learned that people will forget
what you said people will forget what
you did but people will never forget how
you made them
feel being self-aware and having the
strong relationships can make people
feel good and it creates those positive
connections self-awareness in leaders
and your team creates an impact makes
everyone more engaged in their work and
in the end produces better results for
your
organization we can all build
self-awareness first by working to
understand ourselves then practicing and
re-evaluating with the context of others
according to defal and Wickland Theory
anything that makes people focus
intention on their self will increase
self-awareness and they actually did
some research by placing people in front
of very large mirrors and videotaping
them then having them listen to a
recording of themselves while they were
watching themselves and and being
recorded in turn so I think this is kind
of funny because everyone absolutely
hates listening to themselves and
whenever I do a talk I go back and
listen to it afterwards listen to the
recording and it always makes me feel
quite uncomfortable watching myself give
a presentation watching myself speak but
I become a better speaker overall as a
result because I'm able to look for
those little ticks and and maybe things
that I'm doing that maybe I should
improve for next time so I'm able to be
help me become self-aware of the things
that I am doing there are also things
called self-awareness triggers which can
be really big events in our lives uh
things that are really impactful or
really change the way things happen
something like a pandemic you know um
but these triggers by themselves do not
fully develop self-awareness they need
to be supplemented by that positive
reflection asking the questions of What
Not why and without those triggers you
can also look to your team and the
people around you get that 360 feedback
which is encouraging you to give
feedback on yourself and look at how
you've been doing and also supplement it
with the feedback from your people
around you at all levels there's also
scientific tests to assess and Target
different areas of of self-awareness
that you may be missing you can take
those personality tests and look up
different leadership and communication
Styles paying attention to your actions
and the impact they may have on others
do you need to maybe work on your
mindfulness building up your emotional
intelligence your
communication uh trying to look more at
your external self having that open mind
keep it Journal take a step back and
slow down when your emotions start to
boil and really practice that self
regulation in summary
we have learned a lot about leadership
that anyone can be a leader it's not
just about the title but it's really
about having people to follow you we
learned what self-awareness is how it
can be negative if we don't seek it
properly but we can fix this by changing
our wise to what's we've learned about
different leadership skills Styles and
emotional intelligence we learn the
positive of these in leadership and how
they're all underpinned by
self-awareness Wess we have heard how
selfawareness can be beneficial to
ourselves our team and our organization
leadership through self-awareness can
make you a great
leader it can help us to become leaders
not just for ourselves but for our team
and our
organization I will leave you with a
quote from Chinese philosopher La Su at
the center of your being you have the
answer you know who you are and you know
what you
want so thank you if you scan the QR
code on the screen or go to that bitly
link there you can access all of my
resources that I use today I've uh put
up a whole bunch of different articles
and and different um blog posts that I
did as long as links to some personality
tests my slides will be available there
I'm not sure if they're up there at the
moment but I'll put them up there
shortly as well so thank you very much
everyone who tuned in today and I don't
know how we are doing per time but it
might take some questions as well um and
before that I
also have some swag to give away um from
our our friends at Microsoft uh if you
go to the links up there you can claim
your free Azure swag unfortunately the
the swag is only for people in Australia
and New Zealand due to shipping
constraints but we also have some Azure
passes there too so thank you everyone
for tuning in today and I think we do
have some time for
questions Let's see we do indeed well
done Melissa now I learned something
from uh from we know my company recently
got acquired by another company and they
have this tradition of instead of
clapping on a zoom call because no one
can hear it everybody does this ah it's
kind of anyway so I thought I'll just do
this there's also yeah there's also um I
think this is like cling in sign
language is I've SE use that too um it's
just it's interesting when you see a
zoom call with like 200 people and
everybody does this or that or whatever
but yeah um well done we do have a
couple of questions if if you don't mind
um yeah so the first one is as a leader
have you had like stressful moments
where someone may have behaved
inappropriately say with a client and
what' you do how do you how do you
manage
that yeah so it's I think it's about
first talking with the person in in a
private context as well you you know you
don't want to sort of call them out and
from everyone else because you never
know what might be happening and they
might not actually be even aware of the
situation that's right so so pulling the
person aside having a chat about what
happens making sure you're using facts
and really outlining this is what
happened and and this is the result and
getting their insights on you know how
did you think that went so they might
already be aware that something negative
happened they might be practicing their
self-awareness and realized after the
fact hey I should have changed that um
but they also maybe they haven't figured
it out so you can help coach them
through you know why it was negative and
work with them to uh improve it for next
time and you probably also have to go
and do some ground control with the the
client as well and use that that empathy
and emotional intelligence to help mend
that relationship yeah for sure yeah
that's an interesting one because it's
it's always easy when it's everything's
going smoothly like your team's doing
well it's always when something doesn't
go to plan that all these come out so
that's really good um now has you got
have you got any tools um for you know
recommendation for self assessment or EQ
or anything like
that yeah so um I in my my resources
I'll I'll share the uh link on on the
YouTube shortly um but there is some
free sort of quizzes online that you can
do to check your level of self-awareness
and they pretty much all also um require
input from your friends because that's
part of that external self-awareness so
it's about you know comparing the two um
in terms of building up your own
emotional intelligence it's you know
creating a list of the different
emotions that you know researching ones
that you may not uh and really just
practicing recognizing your emotions you
can um after the situation you use those
those what questions of um you know
thinking about what happened in that
situation your reactions that you had
was it emotionally driven where you
maybe you were stressed out so reacted
negatively and
practice you know recognizing it as it's
happening and and taking a step back
yeah for sure and I think it's important
as well to say this is not something
that's easy right this is all really
really hard but it's so worth it like
the self-awareness part especially so
and there's one last question I'll just
checking YouTube Oh many claps yay yeah
that's good if there's anything please
ask questions I can still see them so
keep them coming um all right so I have
one more just we wait see anyone else
asks um what was your most recent Focus
been on in terms of self leadership like
what was your reward for achieving it um
self leadership well I guess I can say
for example it can just be few little
things um that I reward myself with so
maybe I have you know I needed to do my
slides for this talk for example but I
really wanted to to go play Skyrim um so
that was actually something that
happened recently um I wanted you know I
wanted to spend my my day off my weekend
just you know sit sitting around playing
Skyrim but I was like no I need to get
my slides done and have that done before
I can go do it so it's you know you can
use little rewards like that just kind
of saying you know after this I'll be
able to relax get it done first then you
can do that you've only worked with
worked with cats hey yeah yeah
exactly that's I don't have anything
else is there anything you want to
mention like what where where can we see
you next what's your next gig
yeah I actually uh next week I'm
speaking at net com um so that's on on
Thursday next week so that's the the big
Microsoft NET conference where they're
releasing net 6 and my talk is net
internet of things so talking about
high.net for iot which is really
exciting very interesting very different
talk than this one for sure yeah yeah
definitely that's excellent well thank
you so much Melissa that's been very
insightful I mean I sat here actually
watching it on on the other computer the
whole time so that's very cool um so um
yeah I hope to uh you I think you'll be
on the stream for a little bit in case
people have other questions yeah ask him
there but other than that thank you very
much and I shall invite my co-host
William to the screen as well thank you
very much for having
me all right there he is hello William
welcome hello hello how's it going L
yeah I'm good I'm good we uh we're doing
the thing um there was a lot of people
on it's happening I know yeah 115 people
at the moment which is really good umot
and I I've got a little birdie told me
there's another two 300 people on the
the close track so uh there's still time
if you want to join on those you can go
to the website and get a ticket and you
can also join gather town I know I'm I'm
looking forward to this gather town I
haven't tried that before I created my
little avatars yes G town if you don't
know if gtown is like a it's like an
online um Event Hall I guess is that the
best way to say so like you would
normally mingle with people and walk
around and talk to whoever and go hey I
like your T-shirt or whatever it might
be right you can sort of do that in
gather town I think we'll find out but
that's happening at lunchtime which is
when is lunchtime 12:30 I think uh
looking at my list sounds right y I
should know because I've got to talk
after that
yeah yeah cool so um just want to let
everyone know that there is an agenda on
the NDC sydney.com website so you can
see all the talks that's coming up today
um and you know there's the Expo side as
well so if you go there you can sign up
with any of the sponsors there to to win
a awesome prize at the end of the day
and I think L is going to draw all the
prizes he's got the the wheel of names
and I don't know you got some magic way
of picking a random winner well sort of
yeah yeah we we'll get to that at the
end of the day it's uh it won't take
that long but it'll be interesting um
yeah just the first quiz I'm just
looking at schedule the first quiz uh or
trivia thing that you can partake in as
a as on a stream on YouTube uh is 11:15
Sydney time so whatever that is your
local time but 11:15 a.m. Sydney time so
in about an hour and 15 minutes roughly
um now we have a few minutes before we
welcome the next speaker um so I thought
what do we do some tech news um is there
something that what have you seen like
ignite was just on could we talk about
that what's the what what did you see
there oh ignite yes uh one thing in
particular for me uh a big fan of using
Cosmos DB um now they have a a way for
partially updating your model so you
don't actually um have to send an entire
you know if a big model let say arbitary
30 Fields but you only need to change
three of those you can send a patch
update to you just those three Fields
needs to change in the model you don't
have to send the whole thing back to
Cosmos TV so efficiencies you know
latency speed all that you everything
gets affected it's just quite nice
something I wish they' had for a long
time but now they haven't so really cool
have to update a lot of stuff yeah it's
funny how you when you start using a
product like say Cosmos DB for a long
time and you get sort of into it like if
you just start you go oh this is awesome
you learn about all the features and
then you start using it and little
things like that make a big difference
doesn't it because you start going I
wish that was a bit SL bit faster
because it's sort of when I do let's say
100,000 things or whatever it goes a bit
slower you get these little incremental
updates so yeah if you don't know what
we on about um if you're not into Cosmos
DB these are the little things that we
talk about that just make a product that
little bit better and a little bit more
usable um actually one thing that goes
along with that is um they've also got
mongod DB version 4 that can run on
Cosmos DB as well right so you can you
can bring your app you know if you know
typically you have to host it somewhere
else or host to yourself but now yeah
you can run your in in Azure
version 4 as well so it's up to date now
it's really cool it is very cool um
that's always been one of the the um
sort of not drawbacks but one of the
things about Cloud platforms that
Implement another product so obviously
I'm into Asia but if you do all the
other clouds as well um something like
kubernetes it's always been like one or
two versions behind because they had to
adapt it into the Azure ecosystem so
it's good they're catching up so I know
with kubernetes they also just um change
the uh controller that that does all the
kubernetes to Azure stuff so that the
kubernetes version is independent of
that so little things like that makes it
a little bit better yeah um I did notice
one more thing um about sort of mixing
clouds I don't fully understand it I
haven't read into it much but I saw that
um AWS single signon is Now supported
somehow in Asia I'll have to dig into
that a little bit further get you some
more news but I saw that headline I like
that's interesting that's cool so we can
have an AWS sort of s sign on identity
provider in Asia cool mixing Cloud
together you can pretty much use any
single sign on provider with Asia as far
as I'm aware um because you know I'm
sure Microsoft is aware that Azure ad is
not what everybody wants to use um you
know ACG where I work we use or zero
with AWS right it's it's you're always
going to have to be able to connect
those two so that makes sense to me
using AWS single sign on with Azure um
yeah that makes sense now Melissa was
talking about netc that's next week um
now we at one conference here and
obviously we Wen you don't want to take
Focus away from that but doet confence
is pretty cool and the main reason I
like it is um we have net 6 coming out
right it's pretty big deal what is your
favorite feature so far and what you
looking forward to about doet
6 personally I'm very biased but yeah I
love Blazer uh the hot reload stuff you
know I've already using it in rc2 uh it
it just works it's it's a game changer
really for us you know there was a
little bit
of uh chatter about you know it got
removed briefly and we brought it back
which is great A good Community win uh
you know lot of uh happy thoughts uh
regarding that that Microsoft listened
to the community and said hey cool yeah
you really want it we'll bring it back
um and uh it works really well so all
the Blazer updates with net 6 the
efficiency
minimal apis I don't want to sell all of
it but I'm already playing with
everything for net 6 so that final
release is going to be exciting oh for
sure yeah I've I've looking I haven't
used it that much I must admit um it
hasn't been quite in what I've been
doing I've been doing a lot more AI
stuff which I'll get to my talk later
today the last slot um last slot no last
slot
um um so yeah so but done at six uh it
just it fills me with joy um just all
the little I see so I'm definitely going
to join some of those talks and there
how many days is the conference is like
two or three days I can remember the
schedule but it's quite a lot of content
as well a lot of cool speakers as well
so yep uh I think you know we also have
to really mention now is NC Sydney uh
definitely wouldn't be possible uh
without our sponsors we've got quite a
lot of sponsors it's it's amazing
everyone's chipping in still it is is
great so uh they all have some video
clips that will be popping in in a
second somewhere so so uh yeah if
producers you can play the sponsor ads
work from our
sponsors I love running this company I
love running it because uh of the people
I deal with there such a great team of
people from a career perspective it's
the best move I ever did being a great
consultant which we are thisw is half
half between technical skills and
communication it's given me the
opportunity to work with lots of
different types of technology and
explore some stuff that I maybe only
dabbled in at University or before ssw
is a company that makes enterprise
software Solutions uh and that's what we
do we build software for clients uh on
demand we build bespoke Solutions using
the latest technology and the latest
best practices I've been involved in the
development of some mining software
being involved in the development of
software for a legal firm and everything
in between there even in just under two
years I've been working across so many
different
projects
it's just a really great place to come
into and I always look forward to coming
to
work are you an engineer looking to
impact millions of Australians we're
looking for big thinkers problem solvers
and challenge Seekers to help us
engineer the future of banking combank
engineering do you have what it takes
search engineering at
combank when you're talking Sovereign
ICT capability it's more than a safe
Pair of Hands it's people with very
specialized
capabilities it's why we created telra
purple but talking is one thing being
able to walk the walk is
another we've supported all levels of
government across Australia with
customized Technology
Solutions we helped government agencies
cope with a huge increase in demand for
support in times of need all while
shifting to remote working themselves
and our long-term collaboration with amb
ulence Victoria resulted in a digital
platform that came to the rescue in a
National
Emergency a perfect example of how
adaptable purpose-driven technology can
be We Believe purposeful technology
inspired and delivered by people can
make the
difference we believe we're uniquely
poised to help write Australia's next
chapter with
you hello
uh so yeah thanks to our sponsors now um
we have a few minutes before uh our next
speaker Aaron comes online um and just
on those of tech news that we discussed
before if you have any special news of
your own just drop it in the comments
below and you know we can use those
during the next uh little ad Break um
now I think L was actually supposed to
come back as well there he is
hello chasing the Llamas on the farm no
not yet that may happen
later um yeah no speaking of tech news I
have I have a good one I have a good one
that I was really excited about
um I'm just taking over here um vs code
online like vscode dodev um so this is
if you're familiar with Visual Studio
code and then it's just become like
almost a de facto development
environment for so many things like
Python and JavaScript and c and um
things many other things I can't
remember right now but it has a fully
online version now it is brilliant it is
like almost fully features you can do
extensions and all sorts on it um it can
even run locally so um it can use your
files that you have on your local
machine you load in the browser but it
runs locally it's it's magnificent I'm
sure there's still many more features to
come knowing vs code um but just check
it out vs code. um it's very cool so if
like if you're on a public computer you
can't install vs code you can just use
it there and if you can't use the local
file system you can use a cloud file
system as well um or you can use it on
your iPad of all things but it's yeah I
know it's really cool not sure I want to
develop I should actually try on my
phone got a big phone it's like remote
desktop on your phone don't do it it'll
just lead you know to to straight
jackets and rocking in the corner
immediately um don't do that even on
GitHub though like if you if you go to
any of your GitHub repositories uh I
think the shortcut was like your Windows
key and full stop and it actually opens
up that repo directly in a web version
of V code right so that was that's kind
of nice so you can browse through the
code navigate with all the shortcuts
that you used to and yeah quite nice so
lot of cool things a lot of Dev tools
and productivity things that just you
can go and code anywhere and go sit
there on an island somewhere even and
just work away enjoy on or on a farm in
the middle of
nowhere yeah you're you're a fair way
out of town aren't you you're I I'm sort
of I'm not quite halfway between
Melbourne and Sydney but it's not far
off um so yeah I am I am in the middle
of every of of everywhere now later on
today we'll just see if we can make it
happen I might just show you around here
and see what's outside but uh we just uh
got to make sure that works um now I was
just gonna mention because we can talk
about something not developer I think
but still techy um I got this starlink
connection and this is for Rural people
if there are people here watching it
from somewhere that doesn't have a fiber
connection one gigabit or whatever it is
I was on a uh a traditional satellite
connection which is a geostationary
satellite so the satellite itself is
like 45,000 kilometers away up in space
uh that means it takes a really long
time for data to go there and come back
about 600 milliseconds in fact um and I
had that for about six years and now the
good Mr musk has deemed me worthy to
upgrade to starlink which is what I'm on
now which means that I can stream
video like this in almost good quality I
think um it sort of looks all right at
YouTube looking pretty good um and it's
it's still via satellite and I'm just
I'm blown away I did not expect it to be
this good I must admit um what's the lag
like what's the lag it's about 40
milliseconds um sometimes down to like
25 it's it's as good as ADSL or even
some um you know um NBN Connections in
Australia and and that makes all the
difference I can hear you in real time I
can we can't play music together because
that's still off um but I don't talk
over you unless it's on purpose um yeah
I'm Blown Away now I actually I saw I
saw one of your Clips recently where you
know with the starlink you you got a new
router in the house or new access point
to sort of boost the signal uh did that
work because I don't think you quite
finished that uh install when I watched
it the Wi-Fi 6 access point is that what
you mean yeah that's right that's right
yeah yeah yeah so I have I I never knew
like I do YouTube videos and I do them
because I don't know how to do a thing
and I justes record me learning a thing
um and I never knew there was something
called Wi-Fi 6 it just wasn't a thing it
was just Wi-Fi right I knew that was
there wi-fi 2 and three and what
happened to the rest of them well there
is Wi-Fi 4 and five I think Wi-Fi 4 is
2.4 gz Wi-Fi 5 is 5 gz I think like
802.11 AC and 80 so now is 802.11
ax that's the like the protocol official
name whatever and yeah so I installed a
WiFi 6 and I couldn't for the life of me
figure out how to speed test this damn
thing um and I still don't know exactly
I've got a ton of of of suggestions but
yeah It's Tricky um because I have a
modern phone like a pixel phone and that
doesn't have Wi-Fi six so I can't
actually use a speed test thing on that
and then how do you test your local
network rather than your internet
connection um how do you know that your
connected it to the you know the best
thing and turned out I hadn't configured
the access point properly either so yeah
I'm learning there's a part two video
coming because holy
moly um yeah wi I'll wait for you to
figure it out basically put it this way
with Wi-Fi 5 you can get up to 400
megabits so if you're on a fiber
connection with one gigabit as an
example you can't use all of that on
your phone when you're at home with
Wi-Fi six depending on the antennas you
almost can or you just can like so it's
important in that sense for future
proving your networks um so now I have
one Wi-Fi 6 access point that I can use
the rest are still five um but it's a
start so ah cool um no that's good news
uh I might have to yeah just keep an eye
on that because uh same here I'm just
right on the edge of town there is NBN
around me but I'm literally one stet
away from where the NBN sort of ends I'm
like no I've still got some pretty
prehistoric internet going here but um
no that's that's cool newsl uh
interesting to see what you're going to
come up with and how well it pays off I
think it's time to bring in Aaron he's
our next
speaker see you L hey
Aaron bye L bye L we say bye and and
this is where we go wait am I on mute am
I mute can you hear me yeah you're here
you're here no I I I'm I was pretty sure
I didn't have myself muted this time so
yes fingers crossed that we have the
buttons good yes I got to hit all the
buttons on the stream deck and make sure
everything's
working now cool so you're talking to us
today about typ safe graph Quil with
tcri uh and I'm reading the uh the
abstract here and it sounds really cool
so there's code generation uh you're
going looking at um uh how to to have
efficient storage and a whole bunch of
cool stuff you're looking at the the
schema combining schemas oh wow um
sounds
interesting yes yes hopefully I we've
only got an hour U which seems like a
long time but we know how quickly an
hour can go past when uh when we're
presenting don't we yeah yeah it does
fly yeah so look good luck and I'm Keen
to listen to All of what you have to say
today so uh the show is all
yours excellent well thank you uh
everyone who is joining in on the stream
and uh and and watching from wherever
you are around the world um hopefully
you are watching the right session this
is uh typescript and graphql we're going
to be looking how to use those together
and how we can build typ safe
applications for those of you that I
haven't had a chance to meet before or
um haven't uh been we haven't seen each
other at an in-person event uh which I I
miss them I really miss inperson events
we'll get back there soon my name is
Aaron pal and I work for Microsoft part
of the cloud advocacy team I've been
doing web development
for going to say like 17 years now I
don't know it's it's to that point where
I'm just like I do I need to keep
counting I don't really want to keep
counting because it's it's getting long
and I'm kind I feel old when I say
things like that particularly to uh to
to people that I'm I'm coaching
mentoring that are just coming into the
industry but in that time I've been able
to work with a lot of different aspects
of web development I've built
applications that were like truly server
Centric where we were doing things like
everything was on the server you would
always send the whole page back kind of
web forms and predating aspet web forms
to API centered applications where we'll
building custom apis to um expose data
out to uh the consuming clients to rest
designed applications and more recently
I've been looking at graphql on the role
that it can play in the way that we be
uh build
applications um if you want to reach out
to me after this session if there's a
question I don't get answering in the
time or anything like that uh you can
find me on social media you can find me
on my email address um there I'll also
be uh I'm going to try and get into to
gather town at lunchtime um I'm actually
going on a long weekend away CU we're
finally allowed to leave our houses here
in Sydney um so I will I will try and
jump in for a little bit uh in between
packing the car uh to head out this
afternoon but uh do reach out because I
want to make sure that anything that you
want to know I can help you get answered
but that's enough about me and all that
kind of stuff you're here to learn about
application design and particularly
about graphql but before we get into
building an application and things like
that I want to make sure that we're all
on the same page of what we're trying to
do so we're going to build a game today
um this is a game that I built uh back
when we first started doing the
lockdowns and the only way that we were
interacted with our friends was via a
video call where we were playing like
trivia and stuff like that so I was like
well how do we build a trivia game so
let's start with the data model for that
because this is the the fundamental
constructs that we're going to work with
is the the underlying data set so we're
going to have a a quiz or a game object
that um is represented with a couple of
fields on that so we've got an ID so we
can uniquely identify games we'll have
players a game will have a state like
are we waiting for players to join is
the game in progress or has the game
completed we're going to have questions
that are associated with the game and
we're going to have answers that players
are providing to the to those
questions so then we end up with a
relationship to a players um object and
that might have like the name of the
player we have some more information
that we um throwing about the player
maybe not um but then on that we could
uh we we also have kind of a two-way
relationship between those dat models we
can go from players back to the the
games and we can go from the games
through to the
players and then of course we're going
to have questions so these are our three
primary data models um and it's going to
have the the name like the question
that's being asked the all the answers
that are available for that because this
is multiple choice and then the correct
answer that a player um could that needs
to provide to get a passing point for
that game
now this is a like it's a fairly basic
data model we've got some relationships
here and uh as a result it could be
there's a number of ways that we can
represent this out in the way that we
can shame it so let's start by and talk
about rest I know this is a graphic talk
but I want to contextualize things about
rest because that's what we've done a
lot of API development over the last and
number of years and uh this is the way
that I would model this in a very strict
rest sense so we have our um our primary
routes that represent the data models
and then from those we would either get
back like all the quizzes or a quiz by
its ID um all the players or a player by
their ID all the questions or a specific
question um and let's just think about
the scenario where you're trying to
display the um like the the the
completed game screen so for that we're
going to need to know the well the game
ID we're going to need to know what
questions uh were asked in that we're
going to need to know the answers and
we're going to need to know the players
and we're going to need to know the um
players and their answers and in a very
strict design we'll end up with a lot of
links that we end up having to follow so
we get back that first game from our
quiz endpoint and then that's going to
have back a bunch of links through to
the players and the questions so then
we're going to fetch to the players and
we're going to fetch to the questions
but we're also getting back out that we
may not need like we don't need all the
answers necessarily on the the completed
screen we just need the correct ANW so
that we know if the player provided the
correct answer when they um uh when they
submitted their their response um
through the question
and this is where res can have some
challenges in the way that a client will
want to communicate with
it and then this is where graphql comes
at a different approach to the way we
can do client server Communication in uh
data modeling so first off graphql isn't
a server it isn't a client graphql is a
query language we have graphql servers
that Implement a consumer of the query
language and can process that query
language break it down and then provide
that through to your database and
Provine queries against your database um
you can have clients that will construct
graphql queries that can be sent to
servers to process and things like that
but at the end of the day graphql is a
query language it was originally
developed by Facebook um it was built by
Facebook to solve problems that Facebook
has so something to bear in mind is that
graph is not going to be right for every
single project that you build because it
was designed for a very Niche set of
problems that Facebook has um it's
evolved since then or do I need to call
it meta now no I think we'll still call
it Facebook uh it's very much evolved
from what the original U problem that
Facebook was trying to solve so it's a
bit more uh general purpose but it's
like I said it's not going to be for
everything uh it uh Facebook has since
open sourced that they've handed it over
to the graph foundation and they manage
the evolution of the graph language so
then what makes graph really different
to doing a rest API design is that you
end up with a full view of the data
schema that's available for your um uh
from your backend system system from
from your servers and that for by having
this full scheme of you you can then
work out what you need at what point in
time as a querying client so this means
that let's say back to that scenario
where I want to show the um the the the
completed game screen well for that I'm
going to say I want the here's the game
ID and then I want players and I want
maybe the player name because I don't
need any other information about players
I need the game answers and I need to
know whether uh what the answer that the
player provided I need to know the
questions the question that was U like
the the description of the question and
then the correct answer and I can do
that in one single request but I can
also drop off the fields that I don't
need so this avoids an over fetching
scenario where we're getting more data
than we actually need at the client
which can be optimized then for maybe um
lower uh bandwidth available clients
like L when he stuck out in rural
Australia or mobile devices that don't
have maybe the processing power to deal
with exception large data models now
there are other things that are useful
about graphic whe that you can't do with
rest such as a um a subscriptions model
which allows you to do real-time
communication via websockets so in that
case um a a use case in context of this
game would be you're waiting for players
to join and then you have a screen and
instead of having to do long polling
saying is everyone joined is everyone
joined and everyone joined you open
websocket connections via subscriptions
to your um graphic server and as someone
as a player joins we drop a notification
send that back over the um the websocket
so that all connected clients receive
that
information so that's graphql in a
nutshell how does it look well this is
what a
graphql um query looks like um so this
or so this is a subset of a graphic qu
schema um what I've got is I've hidden
away a bunch of the type models and
things like that um and this is just the
entry point the way that you would query
against the data structures that you've
got with inside of your schema so we can
get back a game by its ID we can get
back all the games and we can get back
the results for a particular player now
if you look at this and it's kind of
like JavaScript like it's there you can
see there's a JavaScript Heritage in the
way that this is designed but it's not
exactly JavaScript I mean there there's
types that I mean types don't exist to
this degree in JavaScript um and the
things like using the Bane operator it
there's no semicolons either um I'm a
very much a semicolon um supporter in
JavaScript but that's kind of you can
see where that data model and that that
object model is kind of related back so
then when we perform a query against
this so uh we create a query so this is
the kind of thing that a client would be
creating we're saying we're going to
perform a query against a particular um
available query option with inside of
our schema we're going to pass that
through and then we're going to pick out
the fields that we want back as a
result we'll see a bit more of this as
we get into D and start building our
application now realistically you're
going to need you know four core
components to building an an application
with uh well basically any application
you're going to need some way to store
the data you're going to need some sort
of infrastructure to run it on and then
you're going to have a client and a
server that communicate together we're
really going to focus on the top two
pieces of this the client and the server
um uh for this talk obviously I'm going
to be using certain infrastructure and
I'm going to be using certain data
soures but the the stuff that I'm
covering I are not necessarily impactful
for the way that you could build this uh
application um so I want you to really
focus more around the way the client and
the server interact together so let's
just talk a bit about those components
so for the server um I'm going to be
building it on Azure functions so I like
using the Ser um programmatic model um I
find that quite uh quite nice
particularly from a price point uh for
the sorts of applications that I'm
building at the moment um and we're
going to be using Apollo as the graphel
server implementation so Apollo is an
open source project uh they have a
server implementation for graphql that
runs on top of a functions it also runs
across pretty much any common JavaScript
uh web application framework if you're
using Express or CER you can use it on
side of there it supports I think most
of the other clouds and their serverless
programmatic models and things like that
so again the infrastructure here is not
important but um I I have to have some
sort of infrastructure underpinning this
uh from a client standpoint I'm going to
be building it in uh react because well
it's a Facebook um Heritage language so
um I use I also prefer react That's my
kind of go-to web framework but the
stuff again that I'll show you from a
client standpoint is applicable whether
you doing Vue or spelt or angular
or like vanilla JavaScript without a web
framework like is that doable do people
still do
that anyway um that's going to be my
choice uh um and again you can swap all
these components out um it's not going
to be hopefully impactful but what is
the problem that we're ultimately trying
to solve well graphql is a type based
schema that is exposing our servers our
servers data out to a consuming clients
so it's got a type system within it uh
we Define types we can Define enom we
can Define interfaces we can have we can
Define custom scal Scala values and
things like that but then I'm going to
be building this as a typescript
application and typescript has its own
type system so we're going to be talking
to a database we're going to have data
models that represents the way the data
is stored in our database um we have uh
we then need to kind of communicate with
our our pseudo om that we've got in
there and then we need to expose that
back out as a as a JavaScript
application but we've got two
independent type systems now with inside
of our application we have the type
system that's represented with inside of
our graph schema and we have the type
our typescript application um they're
not necessarily compatible because we
don't want our underlying data
structures exposed in their kind of
rawness to our connected clients but we
kind of want something that helps us
along the way like I I don't want want
to add a field to my graphic schema and
then have it explode in the data access
because we didn't know that field
existed or kind of move things
around what does it actually look like
at code on the left here we have a um a
subset of the graphic schemer and the
one that we're actually going to build
through our demos today and you can see
that kind of looks it looks typescript
type definition e like it's not exactly
the same but you can see the the
analogies there um we can we see there's
enums we have types they um those types
have fields and types against them and
all that sort of stuff and then on the
right we have um our resolvers the
things that going to handle the requests
that have come into the server that are
then going to work with our underlying
data store that they're going to
probably want to know about the type
system that's there so that things don't
explode so how do we go about generating
these types well there's two ways that
we can do strongly typed graph Quil
applications um with typescript the
first is to go down a schema first model
so in this we have the types with inside
of our schema and they kind of look look
like our Javas or our typescript
Primitives so I like this because it
gives me a clean separation between the
types that are making that I'm making
available to Consumers and the types
that are actually Downstream with inside
of my backend um aspects of the
application and I don't necessarily
bleed out the internal
implementations so I'm going to be using
a tool called graph code generator that
will take the schema and generate some
typescript types and then we can use
those to do uh to have some type safety
between the way our result work and the
data that we need to expose out so we're
actually going to go schema first in the
demo that um that we'll get to in you
know just a few minutes the other option
is you could go code first uh so code
first is where we use our typescript
objects that we're creating and we
annotate them in a way that we can
extract the type definitions to create
our graphql schema so they Co that's why
it's code first we we start with the
typescript objects and we turn them into
a graphql schema now this gives you a
clear relationship between the types
that we've got with inside of our
application and the way that we want
those exposed out to our client now uh
if you want to go down this route um
check out typ graph ql.com um and that
has an ex uh that is a project that will
help you do that um my like I said we're
going to be going Co um schema first in
the application we building because
that's that's my preference and I that's
the model that I prefer to tackle but
that's enough slides at least for the
time being it let's jump over to V code
and have a bit of a look around at
building an
application so here we are
in my vs code instance and um I'll share
the links out to the git repo that we're
going to be working with um it's uh it's
publicly available up on my GitHub at um
github.com ARG typet Workshop like I
said the the link is at the end and this
is a workshop will go through uh
building from uh kind of Zero to Hero in
building a graph application so we're
going to start from the start um I've
pre- scaffolded with some useful things
that you're going to want with inside of
your um application it does have the
starting for the react app but we're not
going to get to that till quite late in
the piece um we have our API which is
where the Azure functions is running um
and it's got uh this also has a a um Dev
container so it's running inside of a
dockerized uh sandbox uh if you're using
vs code remote containers or if you're
using uh code spaces on um GitHub uh you
can uh use it with inside of that but
the first thing we need to do is we're
going to need to install uh some uh npm
packages so I'm come into the API folder
and we'll do
npm install and we'll do we're going to
need the oops aplo server Azure fun and
that's not how you spell server finally
I actually did that when I was um doing
my dry runs I kept typing Apollo SE not
sure what that's telling me about my
brain Azure functions functions and
we're going fun that's how spell
functions and then we're going to need
graphql and I'm just going to pin this
at the version 15 of graphql um because
version 16 of the graph library has
actually come out uh and it has some
incompatible types with uh the Apollo
server implementations they haven't
upgraded to uh graph um graph 16 as an
mm package okay so those are installed
and I'm going to use Azure functions to
generate a
new uh let's see I I might have it back
here no I don't uh we're going to use
Azure functions to generate a new
template
uh
template and we will
use uh HTTP
trigger and we'll call that that name of
graphql so we'll generate a graphql asra
function that we'll Now find with inside
of our Explorer excellent there we go uh
so obviously this doesn't have anything
graph in it yet we will get to that in a
moment um but one thing that we do have
to change for Azure functions is the
output binding for HTTP trigger it needs
to become a uh it needs to be Dollar's
return uh that's just for Apollo because
it doesn't know what you've named the
output binding that you've got with
inside of your function. Json file so
you just have to so it will return from
um the function Handler so you just need
to tell a functions to look at the
return value not wait for it to be um
set onto a specific uh binding okay and
to speed things up I am going to copy
and paste some code that I wrote in the
rebe so this is uh a super basic graphql
server uh that we will do npm start
we'll get that running while I explain
what this code is doing so uh in this
super basic server we are importing the
Azure functions um package we are
importing uh gql which is a template
literal to uh Define a graph schema it
has a single type cool our server is up
and running called query it has a um an
operation that we can perform on that
query called hello and that's just going
to return us a string and we have a
result resolver down here that is then
the thing that is going to handle that
request so it matches the schema um
structure so we have query hello and
then it's returning our string we
provide that to aure server sorry Apollo
server the type definition so our
graphic schema our resolvers and then we
create a Handler that Azure functions
can
consume so that's up and running let's
pop this into the
browser there we go and we'll come
across to Apollo
Studio Zoom in a few
steps uh let's resize our Windows a
little bit and delete the uh sample that
I play with so Apollo um studio is uh a
um this is a Sandbox application that
allows you to inspect graphql queries um
inspect graph servers um interact with
them test them out that kind of stuff uh
we can see that we have a root type of
query so that's the the entry point on
our schema uh it has a field called
hello which I can add to a query hit run
and tada
we have created our very first graphel
server um in uh fully in typescript but
at the moment it's pretty simplistic
like we're not really caring anything
about type safety or any that sort of
stuff we I just wanted to you prove that
we can make a graph Quil server work um
and we've done that time to go home wait
I'm already at
home you're going to be stuck with a lot
of terrible jokes as well because I
don't get audience feedback so I don't
know if uh if you're laughing or just
cry loud in with
me so uh let's jump forward in time uh
to the next point with inside of our
Workshop um just so I don't run off
script and break anything um as I said
this uh this does go through uh there's
like eight steps we are going to skip
some of the steps because it's about a
half day workshop and I only have uh 39
minutes left according to my countdown
timer maybe less depending if they kick
me off early so uh we're still here
we've still got our schema R the same
way but let's start extracting that out
into a separate file because at the
moment this schemer is embedded with
inside of this UMTS file
which it means it's it's inherently
undiscoverable like we don't know where
that schemer exists so I'm going to
create a new file and we'll call this
graph uh schema.
graphql and we will grab the type
definition
here done that cool it's all formatted
lovely and now we can get rid of
this
but how are we going to get those type
definitions we need to import them
somewhere and kind of pause that schema
and turn it into something that can be
consumed by
Apollo um I'm going to again install
some npm packages so to do that I will
sneakily copy and paste from my readme
file and we will put them into the API
folder uh so that will go ahead um Al if
you do actually go through this Workshop
yourself um and you install the vs code
plugins that I I recommend or you run in
the um Dev container um I have these uh
this code tour which is what these
little icons here are on the side um
which will uh which you can step through
and it will give you hints along the way
of um what to do at specific lines of
the code base and stuff like that so um
that's it's another way so you don't
have to kind of alt tab back and forth
between this schema uh sorry this uh
read file uh and again for speed sake I
will copy and paste our updated server
implementation let's get rid of the
terminal there we go okay so what have
we done we've imported three new modules
from a uh a collection of package called
graphql tools we're importing one that
will load our schema uh we're doing this
synchronously because of the way Azure
functions work uh we kind actually have
to like we have to read that before we
um return things um oh sorry return the
Handler so it's it's a little bit Cluny
it just means that yeah you're doing
synchronous um schem of creation um
we're then saying that we're going to be
loading from a file in disk this is
because you um you could be importing a
graphel schema from a number of
different locations if we were building
a maybe a graphel server that is then
sitting as a it's like sitting in front
of a number of other graph servers we
could be loading from a HTTP endpoint um
so this is what we call graph Federation
where you're bringing through a bunch of
graphql servers um and then exposing
them as one unified graphql schema
uh but we're going to be loading from a
file on disk so we're using the graph
file learner and then finally we're
using the schema tools to add the
resolvers to the schema so um we still
have our resolve object here we going to
load the schema and just a bit of path
uh messing around to go back and find
that because we're dealing with a compil
tespt output uh we're going to load it
from there we're going to add the
resolvers to it provide it to Apollo
server and then everything should go
nicely and we should be able to do npm
start again and our application should
continue to
run or be rerun given that uh it wasn't
currently running all right give that a
minute excellent looks like API is back
up come over here we'll execute the
query and there we go so everything's
still working we we've we've done the
first step we've extracted things out
into a separate location so fantastic
we're we're starting to get going all
right so the next next thing we need to
do is start building out a like a more
realistic schema the schema we got here
is it's pretty simplistic so let's start
building out the schema that's going to
look uh that we're going to need to
represent our uh our
game again I'm going to cheat and bring
in some of this stuff
from my uh pre-written script so we're
going to start with so we find um our
question so uh we have the ID and we're
using a special scal Val a scal of type
with inside of um the graph language
which is ID um just indicating that it's
a unique identifier and the exclamation
point indicates that this is going to be
a strongly typed sorry a non-nullable um
field so we know that we have to have a
question we have to have a correct
answer and then with the array here I'm
saying that you'll um that you will
always get a an array of zero or more
items and those items are going to be
strings and it will always be a string
it will never be a null or an undefined
or anything like that okay uh oh where
did my read me go I forgot to uh open
that in a pin manner there we go so we
have our question let's create our
game add our game in We'll add our enum
that represents game
State and what else do we need we're
going to need our
player uh select
that okay and lastly we'll have our
player result
let's pop that in save uh we will just
have to restart the server because it
while it's got a file system watch it's
not watching for changes to the do
graphql file um and let's have a look at
now what our uh our schammer is exposed
as to um connected clients such as the
studio
here oops Okay so we've had an error um
well that's what we want we don't want
things to explode immediately we want
explode when I expect them to explode no
so the reason it exploded is that um the
resolvers that we've got here and this
is where we're starting to lose some of
this type information um the resolvers
need to match kind of one to one or um
the resolvers can't have things with
inside of them that aren't with inside
of your schema and that's what this
error message has said we've defined a
resolver to handle something called
query but our schema doesn't have
anything that has query now we didn't
know that well we didn't necessarily
know that because well there's no type
information to help us along the way I
know that if I delete that um Apollo
will uh if something doesn't exist in
the schema it won't um kind of freak out
or just uh well it shouldn't have
freaked
out ah uh I don't have um I don't have a
rot type
um uh well I'll put in the thing I I was
trying to be clever and like jump
forward with inside of uh time but we
will put in here we go so we put in the
query uh and then that should uh oh no
we'll and we'll pop in the schema that's
the last piece that we
need um okay and then we'll restart our
server isn't live coding
fun um okay so the reason it exploded
was because um it didn't know where the
route was going to be for anyone that
wants to come and uh query your graphql
server uh because we hadn't defined any
of that inside of our uh schema now that
that's done now we've defined um a uh a
schemer object that indicates that the
that when you're performing a query
you're going to start like the root
query is going to be at this type called
query not game or anything else uh but
the problem is that well so our
resolvers aren't uh aren't there and we
don't need them there yet uh and if we
reload that well now we'll see that
things start looking a bit better we'll
see that we have our query route here we
could query for a game with a um a
specific item so I could perform that
operation if I
wanted um I could perform like a request
for all game
uh whoops uh not game State I wanted to
get back let's get back to the ID of all
games and we don't need that variable
there so now I can perform that query
and it's going to explode because we
haven't written anything that will
handle that um you can see in the error
message there it says cannot return null
from a non-nullable field uh query.
games and that's because our type system
with inside of our schemer has forbidden
us to return a null um and because we
haven't implemented anything we're
implicitly returning null so we're
getting some like we're getting some typ
information and we're getting that back
from our server we're getting it from
the way we're performing crws but we've
lost any of that with inside of our
actual
application so again we're going to jump
forward a little bit in time where we'll
uh start runting out some of the
resolvers I'm going to skip over the
data storage section uh itself um and
instead we'll see the way that I've
implemented data storage um in the
application but let's just close off all
the windows that I had open I don't want
to give anyone a sneak peek at what
we've uh got coming so um for data
access uh this Workshop has an in-memory
data store so it literally is just an
array of objects that is maintained in
memory and every time you restart the
server you'll lose all your game
information um or you can store it in a
persistent way using Cosmos DV pick your
poison uh and I do have the instruction
in the workshop which goes through both
ways of setting up data uh
access but for data access we I've
defined a number of different types that
we have here so we have um a base kind
of like a b a base type it's not it's
not a class it's just a base type um
called Model because everything is going
to have an ID uh and a uh and a model
type associated with it U the model type
is just whether it's a question and
answer a user answer or a game useful
for um storing in Cosmos DB so that we
can perform uh queries against that and
we can set up the data in there with the
appropriate partition
Keys we have our question model which
extends model with question category
incorrect answers correct answers type
and difficulty um so the data set that
I'm using here comes from open Trivia
API and this is the way that they return
their data structure so I've just kind
of mapped that through this is what I
want to store in my database um user
model we have our name um the identity
provider user roles user details so that
this could be um plugged into Azure
static web apps and use the um
authentication model there that gives us
some uh some information um we have our
user answer we have our game and then we
have our uh our three data sources game
user and question that we can
access um I said there's an in inmemory
implementation and a cosos DB
implementation we're going to use the
inmemory one uh for the time being and
we can see that I create that here it's
an Apollo data context sorry it's a a
data source um and I've strongly typed
an Apollo context which just is a way
that we represent data sources um and
we'll see a bit more of that as we get
to implementing type safety uh but we
have things like use a question game so
uh that's all being given over to Apollo
so when it starts it will understand
that we can access data but now we need
to do something with that so inside of
our resolvers let's go and build that
out um and I po the schemer here on the
side uh if I can remember the keyboard
shortcut which I can't which is
annoying i' I I recently changed my
keyboard and my muscle memory in uh vs
code has drastically decreased because I
was just so used to where keys were on
my keyboard and now keys aren't where
they used to be on my keyboard yeah I've
gone like crazy split keyboard layout
but let's just move on from me
complaining about my
tools okay uh so we need to implement a
something never mind uh so I need to
implement this uh this query type here
so we're going to have game games and
play results let's start with games
because games is the easiest one to to
do now I know that we're going to so
because I've worked with ap poly before
I know that the first argument to this
is going to be the parent um in the
object hierarchy that's being returned
from our server I know that the second
argument is going to be uh any arguments
passed through to the query or any
variables and the third argument is our
pooll context which is where we get data
sources they data source data oh I can't
remember whether it's data source or
data sources and I don't have any type
information like I'm I'm losing the
value of typt here data sources that's
what it is Data sources okay and then we
will turn data
sources. g game games I think it's games
get game
okay so that's how we perform games um
and let's just grab a bit of sample data
that I've
got ah where where was that there it is
um so this is just a sample game that we
can use for testing we'll embed that
into our thing here save and we get in
missing typ cool
okay uh and we'll go to API and
npm start okay so that let's hope that
this comes up and running
oops give it a
[Applause]
moment all right looks like like it's
looks like it's working the server is
up uh so now we do have a game there I
should be able to query this
and get games of oh it must be called
games it must be
called so now we're starting to see
where we're getting the problems of lack
of type safety now typescript is great
because it gives us that type safety um
graph is great because it gives us that
type safety but I don't like this data
source isn't any because it doesn't
understand anything about this knows
it's obviously not it's actually called
game not games so I didn't know that
because I didn't have any um type
support I didn't know this until runtime
and um anyone that's done enough
JavaScript development will know that
you can very easily end up with runtime
problems and there's a reason that uh
the compiled languages or or languages
that have type checking in them as part
of a compile step are quite valuable but
anyway let's uh do that
and did uh is that games okay games can
I read null from non-nullable field
query. games did I not restart the
server properly oh no it should have
been got let's get games not get game of
course okay there we go so now we've
created so fantastic um you've seen the
problems that lack of type safety can
bring um and some of those were
manufactured errors and some of those
were because I actually typed things
incorrectly uh but if we were to say
kind of like flesh this out a bit more
so we could do game and then again we're
going to ignore the first argument uh we
know that this receives an ID and then
we're going to have our uh data
sources data sources and then that will
need to be return datas sources. game
game.get
game and then we'll pass the ID into
there so now we can get back a game
based off of a specific ID so but like
what is ID how do I know that it's
called ID I know it's there because I've
got the scheme open side by side
but this is getting a bit tedious and
it's getting B frustrating so let's jump
forward again in time and have a look at
um what like how do we bring some of
this type safety information in here and
I'm going to skip over the first step of
generating types and look at the second
aspect of
it so when it comes to generating types
uh I said because I'm going schema first
I'm using a tool called graphql
codeen so graphql code generator is um
is a tool way you'll provide it with
your graphic schema and uh it takes you
have a number of plugins that you give
to it and it will give you some output
for
that let's take our graph schema just to
have a look at it in the browser what
it's doing oops okay so what it's doing
is it's creating a couple of things like
some utility types like a maybe type and
exact a few things like that but then
we'll see that we have Scala values so
ID string bin in float and how they map
through to typescript or JavaScript
Primitives so ID is a string string is
unsurprising a string bullion is a
bullion int is a number and Float is a
number because floating points are
difficult um we see that we have a
question here and we can see the fields
that are mapping to that we see that's
defined as arrays and so on and so forth
um if I was to change say question to be
um nullable now it's a a maybe type and
we can see that it has that the question
mark there indicating that this allows
allows us to assign null in
TPT uh and kind of so on and so forth so
so we like that's really useful for us
now we can get type objects that
represent our graphic schema and we can
generate this so I've gone ahead and set
that up with inside of this step of the
the application um I've installed graph
Coden um and I've created the c. yaml
file and I'm generating two things here
I'm generating uh the typescript
definitions and I'm generating the
typescript resolvers so the reason that
I'm generating the typ resolvers
additionally is so that I can come into
my resolver object here and then I can
strongly type it I can say that the
resolvers is um uh this object here and
it is of let's just AMPM run gen because
I think things are not quite right oh
oops com to the API npm run
gen generated type let's see the the
type signature I was looking at there
wasn't quite right there we go um so we
can see that the query um as we're
expecting there uh we have game which we
know and now that's got some type
information it know that it knows that
it doesn't have any arguments provided
to it whereas if I hover of a game we
can see if I can get it there we go so
it has uh it has game query arguments
and it's going to have a field called ID
we know that we need to return a game
object from here so on and so forth um
but we still lack that data source like
it it doesn't have a type yet so how do
we go ahead and give that data source a
type so that it's uh it's understood
with inside of our application well
that's where uh we have the
uh Apollo context so I've created a
strongly typed Apollo context here data
sources um user in game and question and
if we were to add that uh as a custom
bit of model
mapping which I'll grab from
here put it into my y file make sure I
get the indents correctly because it's
yaml and nothing says fun like Whit
space
significance says the person that is a
huge fan of
f okay so what I've said here is there's
a file called a po context uh and inside
of that is a type called Apollo context
and where you have the Apollo context I
want you to strongly type that
awesome now data sources is strongly
typed we know that is a probably called
games it's called game but we're getting
another red squiggle this time it is
saying that well it's a very long error
message that won't fit on screen but
essentially I'm I'm returning an array
of model types
asynchronously but this expects a uh
array of game not game model so how do
we fix that problem well we come back
and we grab some more stuff out of my
sample here which is model mapping so
this tells the code generator that where
you find types um map them between the
uh the the internal type that I'm using
for my backend system will map through
to this uh type that is available from
my graphic schema uh so we run gen and
there we go success npm
start all right uh looks like I've got
about five minutes left so I'm going to
be kind of powering on through a little
bit uh here oh oops I forgot to mpm
install on something maybe
uh or should I have I should have
actually looked at the error message um
it was not uh not what I thought it was
uh we'll pop through to here and we are
missing something there there okay uh
npm start so we'll get our server up
running um and then I'll jump through to
the fully completed application because
I don't think I'm going to have time to
implement this with inside of uh the
react application but I can show you
what that looks like and and how we can
do um type safety all the way through to
our connector client but there is still
one more thing that's possibly going to
explode um if I do this uh so I get
games I want the questions of this game
and let's get the question and the uh
correct answer and the answers all
right and as predicted this is exploded
the reason exploded is because it can't
find a field called correct answer in
the object model that we're returning so
why has that happened well it's because
if we think back to
our database types it's correct
underscore answer not correct answer in
Pascal
case so like our our type system is all
there it's all correct it's all giving
us this information but we need to help
it out and and explain how to do some of
the custom mapping so for that I can
come into the right level here and we'll
go question wait where am I ah I'm at
the wrong set of
parentheses and we're going to go
question so we can do uh we can give
some help to the way that um Apollo will
convert our backend data models into our
output data models so here we're going
to receive a um a question model we have
a look at that we're going to receive
the question model and I need to return
well I I need to return that particular
field of for our question which we can
do with return
question. correct
answer uh similar we can do that for uh
answers because we don't have an answers
property that we saw in our database we
have correct answer and incorrect
answers so again we're going to do
question oops not
Cubit
question and then we'll return uh we're
just going to randomiz these so that we
don't get the answers in a predictable
order uh this will be question do
incorrect answers
concat uh question. answer uh correct
answer okay save that wait for the
server to restart Tada now we have
helped with some additional model
mapping um to deal with some of the
custom data structures and everything is
looking just the way that we want we are
getting data back we are getting type
information we know that when we're
mapping here that it's a database type
we know that the question is going to be
expecting um question types of return we
know that this is expecting a string out
whereas this is expecting an array of
strings so that's all given us kind of
the things that we
need all right and the last thing before
uh William comes back and joins me for
Q&A because um I think I can see some
questions uh starting to pop in is let's
go to our fully completed application
and have a look at how we bring this
into the um the client as
well so uh loading that up there we go
okay so the last thing I need to do is I
I want to perform things so I'm using
react hooks here but again it's sort of
immaterial you can be using it with any
way to talk with Apollo client um back
to your uh your backend server uh but I
want to
say let's let's have a look at the
completed game um I want a uh I want to
perform an
operation if I can find it here where is
it
[Music]
or is that one that I'm trying to
perform okay we'll start with create a
game so I want to create a new game um
this is going to perform a mutation
that's going to need us to send some
data and get some data back so this is
the query that I or the mutation
operation that I want to perform um I
want this strongly typed so that I know
that I'm going to get back that string
ID well I can generate the types using
graph code gen that gives me this typed
document node so this is a um a thing
that graphql clients in JavaScript can
consume this um type document node can
be passed through to um any query
operator which then gives you back a a
mutation function and then because this
is a react hook uh it gives me back the
um the values that will be updated from
that react hook so I know that um
loading oh sorry I know that data that's
the thing that's coming back it's going
to be a create game mutation or a null
or an undefined depending at what state
we're in if we unpack pack that a bit
more um create game is going to be a
optional thing that can return from a
game but it's going to pick out just the
ID field so if we have a look
at dot notation we'll see that we have
ID which again matches the thing that we
wanted um the the operation we've tried
to perform against our graphic back end
it's all there as expected um and I
think I'm just about out of time so
let's jump over back to our slides and
quick L wrap up if I can if I can find
my slides where did they go there they
are okay so that was a lot of stuff to
go through in a very short period of
time um and yeah so we wanted to leave
some time for uh for questions now if
you want to get uh the if you want to
have a play around with this workshop
and have a look at the stuff that I
didn't get time to dive into you'll find
it on my GitHub at github.com
palgic T workshop I'll also share these
on uh social media and in the slack
Channel um uh with the NDC hashtag on on
Twitter um if you want to get them and
you don't want to frantically try and
screenshot or type them down graph code
generator was the tool that I used to
convert the graph schema file into
typescript um type definitions and if
you want to learn more about using
graphql and on Azure um I have I think
it's a seven part Series so far um of
doing that uh you'll find the the
starting point of that of how we get
started we kind of build out a bunch of
stuff that we've seen in the workshop
today um and again uh for for the folks
that are here in Australia um if you
want to grab some Azure swag uh the link
is now working uh looks like we actually
had a problem with it initially uh but
that is now working um so you can claim
your Azure swag um or uh if you want if
you don't have an Azure account you want
have a free trial um jump on there and
uh use the Azure pass to get ready to
have a play around uh but looks like uh
William is about to join us again so
thanks everyone for uh sticking around I
hope that that was interesting I hope
you learned something new about how we
can do
graphql uh in a type safe
manner thanks for having me so now over
to questions it's going to be really
awkward if William doesn't come back no
he is excellent hey that was really
smooth hey virtual
clut yeah well look I because we can't
be there in person I have to bring my
own audience Applause um I also have a
laugh track but I didn't use it because
I didn't think my jokes were funny
enough to Warrant
that I would you could have played it
would have been quite funny actually hey
uh Aaron yeah like I said that really
smooth session is I I'm actually was
taking a lot of notes here um and uh
there is a question that in the chat the
one from Ben
lowbridge so Ben's asking is there a
benefit to building out the application
schema first as opposed to the types
first so benefit is probably a
subjective term because um everyone has
um a view of what is beneficial in a
different way so uh the reason that I
prefer to go schema first than database
first is that that's tends to be the way
that I think about designing my
application I think about what the
client is going to be wanting before I
think about how the data structures are
going to be now in uh in my past time in
Consulting I definitely worked on
applications where we started database
first where we would design out a
database structure and and what was it
going to look like for us to store the
data and then turn that into an API that
we're then exposing to our clients or um
into an application that was going to be
consuming it or whatever it might be so
benefit is like I said it's it's a
subjective term um there are going to be
reasons that you would want to do it
there are going to be reasons why you
wouldn't want to do it that way uh but
think about it in terms of what is going
to be the best fit for yourselves for
the uh the the approach that you want to
take in the way that you're designing
your architecture and then ultimately
that should help you with um the
decision on do you want to go schema
first or do you want to go um data
modeling
first that sounds sounds good yeah it is
definitely a subjective you uh like you
said you get to a project and the
database is already there but for some
reason they decide hey we need graphql
now you mentioned graph you've done all
the demos here with the you know
JavaScript typescript but you know what
about all the other sort of platforms
other languages out there so net c f
what what do we do
there um well first off I'd say why why
are they important just do everything in
JavaScript um nothing goes wrong with
that okay sure just as a as a complete
segue um and uh something that I saw on
ignite's announcements was um there is
some updated support for Excel macros to
be written in JavaScript so like
JavaScript is taking over the world you
can write macros for excel in JavaScript
but I digress um if you're let's say
that you're building a net application
uh there's there's a couple of different
um libraries out there that will do
graphql servers uh for you um my pick of
them is hot chocolate um funny
name um serious project I guess um the
it's but it's a it's a very fully
fledged graph Quil server um
implementation for net it runs on aspet
uh it can run on Azure functions um uh
otherwise there's graph world.net um
that's just it's another project that's
out there another open source project um
and in my graphql on Azure series I
actually talk both about graphql net and
hot chocolate and we'll look at how we
can Implement with either of them um in
terms of uh like how do you like the the
data structures and things like that um
graph Cen will actually generate you um
C classes from a uh a graph schema so if
you are going down that schem of first
route and you want a way that you could
generate your classes to maybe you to
end end framework or us as as mapping
between your um your like your Entity
framework RM and your um your resolvers
uh it can actually generate you that
stuff as well so you don't have to go
down to code first route if that's not
the way that you want to tackle it so
that's the tool that you you've used
during the talk right the same
one um yes yes I think so uh I'm
definitely going to explore that one uh
a bit further myself
um yeah got another question here about
um uh the schema like you know so it can
be quite big we got a really complicated
application um can we split it up can we
make it a little bit more
manageable and you know what what's uh
any downsides to doing
that yeah so if we think about some
graph servers that are out there so
GitHub is a has a graphql server
component to it so instead of using the
restapi you can use graphql and there is
like there's hundreds of things you can
do with github's API um now I'm making
some assumptions here I don't actually
know how the GitHub graphic um schema is
implemented but I would expect they're
probably splitting it out as a as a
bunch of separate schema files now you
can um because you still need to expose
this as a unified front you can do that
in a couple ways first is through um
Federation where we uh where we have
something that will then bring together
a bunch of back bunch of schemas and
then expose them out as a sing unified
view um the other is you can just take a
schema with inside of a an application
and split it out over multiple files and
use um graphical tools so what I was
using for loading the scheme from a file
and then converting it into something
that Apollo could consume uh they also
have a plugin that um that is used to
kind of extend the graphql language a
little bit that allows you to write
basically an import statement so you
could have um the like the the types for
your your game and your player and your
question as separate things with inside
of separate files um and then you can
use it to just bring them all into a
single file that is then the thing that
you're serving out so that can be like
if it's maybe a a project that doesn't
warrant you creating a bunch of
different microservices that are all
exposed to graph but instead you want to
just avoid having one file that's like
hundreds and hundreds of lines of
graphic o schema you can use that to to
merge them all into a single file um and
then expos in a single server cool that
sounds great um I've got just a sort of
an obvious question uh when does graphql
go wrong or what's the sort of uh pain
that you may have uh encountered before
for others to be aware of Y so probably
the number one biggest thing that I find
painful with graphql is authentication
because graphql is a query language and
it's pretty expressive in the way that
you can represent it but it doesn't have
a good way to represent authentication
and authorization access because you are
kind of giving someone the power to get
very close to your underlying data
models and query against those how do
you do authorization against that so how
do you make sure that well like I might
have access because I'm authenticated to
perform this particular query but do I
have access to that field within the
database or that um that uh that that
other data model that's following a
relationship how do you implement that
so that can be a difficult thing to to
do because first off you need to make
sure you're modeling it out for your
clients to consume and understand the
things they can and can't do but also
you've got to have your resolvers
intelligent enough that they can deal
with that probably the other thing is
that graph is very well known for
allowing you to create a your own like
dos attack um against your own
infrastructure um so this is actually
possible with inside of the schem of
design that I have in that graphic o
query um you can go from a game to a
player back to a game back back to a
player back to a game back to a player
back to a game back to so you can end up
with this object graph that just gets
huge and if you haven't Implement your
resolvers to be intelligent enough to
per perform short circuits or to detect
recursive queries and things like that
yeah you can you can very quickly create
your own dos because you've got a query
that is just recursing on itself and if
you're talking to a database you're
building a query that's going to the
database that's then going building a
new query that's going to the database
um and and that's just so that's just a
a limitation that you've got in the way
the language is designed now there are
ways around that like I said you can
have your resolvers intelligent to
detect short circuits there are projects
out there that will um enforce those
short circu in with inside of resolve a
chain so you can't go more than like 10
10 Deep INF field traversals um or you
can just hope no one realizes that they
can bring down your infrastructure by
writing a very poor
query yeah so I was just thinking even
like when you what you said that deos
attack so that is your when you write
the query so you just nesting the same
types over and over deeper and deeper
right so you get a very wide very deep
sort of query and that creates that
dos headache yeah cool and and I guess
even if I think about subscriptions can
you um you know somehow you can sort of
you know exhaust web socket as well if
you want to subscribe to literally
everything or is that not really a
problem anymore uh no it's it's
definitely a problem and the other the
other challenge with um subscriptions
and web stockers in general is that you
end up with a very tight coupling
between client to server so scalability
becomes a problem so if if we think
about infrastructure where we're scaling
out
um we've hit a scale limit and we want
to add more infrastructure to it or we
want to scale up the size of our
infrastructure more more CPUs more RAM
well how do we maintain those socket
connections across scale UPS um also we
talkers don't work in a serverless model
because they're kind of like anti-
serverless like the point of serverless
is that it's event driven and then if
you're like I want a persistent
connection well how are you having a
persistent connection to something that
is inherently not allowed to persist um
so yeah you you you definitely can and
um you can definitely overload a system
using websockets um using the
subscription model um mostly because
limits the ability to
scale cool so I in a sense really you
know we have to make sure that we're
picking the right tool for the job you
know it it's built for purpose and you
know if if things change down the track
then you we have to be mindful of that
we don't want to create a a real big
problem well that looks like all the
questions I have Aaron uh thank you very
much great talk uh I think L is burning
to to come back on screen he's got
something cool in store for us coming up
you there
Li
well you got someone new yeah well it's
my twin hello I'm ready for the quiz are
we ready are you haven't changed your
shirt I
know it's just I just have lined up over
here this just a whole wardrobe just uh
no not really but you know it's uh it's
special we got something really cool you
can win so um I'm I'm Keen I'm Keen um
anything else you want to add what I
want to add oh well uh do we actually
know what the prizes are we haven't
actually listed can win so okay so let's
put up the slido Joiner thing while I
explain how it all works I think that's
probably a good idea um so we have this
quiz now you can use that QR code to get
onto it you can join on your phone or
whatever now the the most important
thing is that you don't do the quiz via
the live live stream because there's a
lag and you're not going to do well so
join the link on your own browser
instance something right don't just
watch the stream um and then there's a
time for each question so there's 10
questions and in this case it's gonna be
about Sydney surprise um and see we're
already joining so as you join I can see
and we're g to get hopefully lots and
lots and lots of people to join So the
faster you answer the questions the more
points you get right so it's not just
about getting them right it's about
getting them right fast right so that's
important because I didn't know that the
first time
um and then also um you get also a lot
of points off if you get it wrong I
think so you actually better a strategy
is better it's better to not answer the
question if you're not 100% sure right
because you can lose points yep so
there's a bit of strategy to it um and
the prizes the prizes so we have five
five NC hoodies so they are like limited
editions correct I have the original
2016 hoodie here you can see
2016 nice I think it says somewhere oh
my hat no hang
on I can't quiz without the Hat there we
go um so there's one of those for each
of the top five and then the winner
also gets a ticket for next year's NDC
and not just any ticket it's an all
access ticket so that's workshops and
conferen a lot right that's pretty cool
um that's pretty
yeah it is pretty cool so please join
the quiz join the quiz and you know
there you can win actual stuff um we see
a bunch of names in there already it's
good yeah yeah yeah we're just gonna
give it a minute now Melissa asked there
uh if if if she can win pants we got
hoodies but maybe we should have pants
as well yeah well you don't know if I'm
wearing pants or maybe I
am it's one of those questions yeah it
is I know don't want
answer no you don't um so yeah please
join uh I did put something in the
general as well so if you're in room one
or two or three or four just join room
one live stream
um come on people I'm ready but I'm
gonna give everybody a chance to join uh
because once we start there's no way of
stopping it like it's just gonna keep
going so um I see some familiar names in
that list yeah I know there's uh shout
out to denish got Li Matt
G Melissa jaob oh
yeah might be a different Jacob I don't
know I'm hoping fism spelling eror is
supposed to be Batman but you know oh
it's bman I know bman yes yes he's a
lucky winner from uh our m.net NDC um
ticket raffle so bman won the the full
ticket for NDC Sydney this one yeah
right that's his name so we got we got
34 people come on people um I'm just
going to give it one more minute and
then we're going to jump into it because
uh we got other things to do so but the
Hat makes it better must do it's nice
and colorful I don't have a hat I have
to find a hat for the next one yeah so
just to recap if anyone's just joined
make sure you join the slider on your
own browser instance on device don't
look at look at it on the YouTube stream
because there's a lag and you're not
going to do well uh you might even miss
some of it completely so do it on your
own instance how long do we get for each
question I think it's like 10 or 15
seconds right I don't
remember I thought it was 20 but it
might be 15 um but whatever it is the
quicker you answer the more points you
get it's 20 seconds I just right 20
seconds um all right so we are 39 can we
get to 40 and then we'll start the quiz
so if you're ready everybody fingers on
I'm gonna hop off last you take control
all right bye William um yeah so put
your finger on the buzzer actually
there's no buzzer but you know uh so
there'll be four um I think it's four um
it's like multiple choice right so four
options for each question so are we
ready 41
people here we go stting the quiz now
all right so first question which actor
once worked as a painter on the Sydney
Harbor Bridge Mel Gibson Tom Cruz Paul
Hogan or Russell Crow and you can see
the timer goes down here 10 seconds to
go quick quick quick get it in we got 16
one come on everybody answer that one
see it looks like there's a there's a
trend towards something and time's up
alrighty so this is what you voted and
the correct answer
is PA Hogan so half of you got that one
right well done let's see who's in front
we get a leaderboard every time here o
Matt
88 oh dear okay I don't don't know how
to pronounce that let's say with Matt
Matt Chris Patrick Bren and Chang
excellent all right so question number
two here we go how many light bulbs are
inside the Sydney Opera house 155,000
73,000
17465 or
8,700 and you might be able to Google if
really quick but that's cheating so
don't do that um Got 5 Seconds four
three oh it's exciting oh there a bit of
split here so everybody's convinced that
it's not a it's a lot everybody's
convinced that it's a lot it seems but
what how many is it really the correct
answer 15,500 not as many as you thought
174,000 that's a lot of light bulbs
that's a lot but yeah um cudas to uh to
the quiz question maker thing that was
very good all right who's in front we're
going to have oh oh Brighton's on front
now very good all right all right so
next
question here we go that's it in 2017
the new southwes government named its
newest fery what Charlotte freshwater
Queens Cliff or faery MC faery
face which is fantastic again oh God my
inner six-year-old loves that um and we
got another five seconds come on answer
everybody and we got oh everybody's got
an answer in I think yep there we go
fantastic so this is what you thought y
yep very good that the correct answer
is fairy mcf face yep they actually did
so if you're not from Sydney yeah um
someone had a bit of humor I think this
was a public poll that suggested this
but anyway who's in front now it is oh
Patrick tan is on top now see the time
has is important 45 seconds for the
three questions um all right 45 seconds
left I think is what
really is um all right next
question NC Sydney is typically held at
which location Hilton in Sydney IC
cityne town hall or four seasons total
Landscaping sorry I'm giving it away but
that's pretty funny um all right com on
five seconds five four three come on
everybody
and there we go yep Hilton Sydney is the
most popular answer and the correct one
is it is indeed Hilton uh Sydney
fantastic so the lat board now I'm I
think I'm right in saying that it's
going to be at the Hilton next year as
well but I'm sure yakob will correct me
if that's not the case but let's go with
that for now well well done Patrick
you're still on top fantastic all right
next
question which was the opening date of
Sy Olympics in 2000 was it the 14th uh
of are these American dates yeah they
are oh interesting anyway 14th of July
15th of September 14th of November or
15th of May oh okay so giveway if you're
not from Australia if it was in May
it'll be kind of miserable because
that's sort of um springish but a lot of
people saying 15th September let's have
a look what is the correct answer it is
indeed in September well done everybody
so who's on top now is it still Patrick
oh different Patrick Patrick now so
there's a bit of a competition here at
the top lot to win all right next
question Australian television so oper
home and away is shot partially at which
beach Bondi Manley Coogi or Palm
Beach what do you think uh if you've
never watched Home and Away you're not
missing much it's rubbish but a lot of
people like it um it's a typical soap
thing it's the same storyline for the
last 20 years I
think yeah okay a lot of you saying Palm
Beach Bondi Beach popular second let's
have a look what the correct answer is
it is in De P Beach well done okay is
Patrick still on top now which Patrick
oh Patrick is still there well done Matt
is in for it as well Samuel and Patrick
number two Patrick 10an maybe that's
Patrick number one not sure and Tom is
snug in there well done Tom next
question all right blank is the oldest
street in Australia so which street King
Street Jo Street pit Street or Sussex
Street which is the oldest in Australia
interesting so a pensioner street or
something got three seconds to go
everybody yep oh last struggler there
all
right there we go that's it George
Street is what the popular uh answer is
let's see what the correct answer
is it isn't Geor Street well done so
where does that put our leaders
now o Patrick is still on top there very
good there's not much happening at the
top let's see if we can uh change that
up a bit or if they're just too good
next question in New South Wales it's an
offense to disrupt the wedding of
funeral be in possession of more than 50
kilograms of potatoes correspond or
engage in business with pirates Splash
mud on public bus
passengers right I like the pirat one
but I actually don't know this
one um don't know what the potatoes
would relate to anyway all right so you
all said pirates that it's an offense to
do business with pirates not very
strange isn't it we used to be anyway
let's see what the correct answer is
it's no it's Splash mud on public bus
passengers right fair enough okay so
that should hopefully shake up the
leaderboard a bit let's have a look uh
we got and oh Matt is now on top and Jay
whoever Jay is has got bit further up
now in order if you win by the way we
are going to need your handle somehow we
need to be able to contact you somehow
to be able to send you the stuff right
just bear that in mind so we are going
to reach out out after this uh either
today or tomorrow or maybe early next
week when we know what we're doing and
next
question is who won the gold medal in
men's 400 Meer freestyle swimming in
Sydney Olympics in 2000 was it
Christopher Thompson was it Grant
hackard was it Ian Thor
or Matthew
Welsh oh we've got quite uh there's a
lot of people went very quickly for one
person let's see okay you might be
guessed who you all think it is I
thought by a mile but were you right
were you right let's see what the
correct answer
was it was indeed the thorpedo Fantastic
name so where does that I suspect that
won't change much on the
leaderboard oh J moov moved up so you
were quick on the buzzer there see Matt
still one question ahead one right right
answer ahead all right I think we have
is there one more question to go yeah we
are up to the final question now Sydney
airport is formerly known as Nancy bird
Walton airport Kingsford Smith airport
mascot airport or Alice Springs
airport all right what do you think what
do you
think oh five seconds to go last
question got to get it right got to go
right come on come on
and what do we got oh you also said
kingf Kingsford Smith hard to say all
right what's the correct answer it is
you're right Kingsford Smith airport
well done so who was the winner this is
now it's getting interesting you
ready who we who are our five winners oh
Matt you do you made it you did it
congratulation matt8 y I think I think
it's Matthew y actually
um J's number two obviously we going to
need your handle so somehow to be able
to uh to to contact you make sure that
but all five Matt Jay Samuel Patrick and
Benjamin you all want a hoodie and Matt
you want our NDC 2022 all access pass
tickets so well done everybody um so
that's it for the quiz there's one more
quiz with same prizes later on in the
day um but for now we're just going to
have to uh have a quick word from our
sponsors because they make all of this
[Music]
happen
International women's day is a key
period of Time For Us within the shelter
and the opportunity to raise funds sits
right beside that just days before
International women's day our website
was
hacked we contacted telra purple and the
team just didn't even take a second
thought we had a call late in the
afternoon asking whether or not our team
could help knowing that the users
contributing to the shelter through the
website were trying to make a whole lot
of difference anything we could do to
help there was was really important to
us as a
group they took a website that had been
completely destroyed and they rebuilt it
in probably less than 48
hours the kindness of strangers is
actually what makes this shelter run
tells St purple they took their skill
their love their passion and they used
it for purpose and they used it for
[Music]
good and finally the top spot on our
list of medium best workplace winners
for 2021 rocketing up from number nine
in 2020 to the top place this year
congratulations to our number one best
workplace in the medium category mantle
group mantle group is a business that
truly lives its principles customers
rate its Service delivery as excellent
Executives embody the best
characteristics of the company employees
and management are in it together as one
employee put it the co crisis was tough
for many businesses and watching a team
of over 250 people reach consensus to
get through the darkness together will
be one of the highlights of my working
life to be satisfied with great place to
work here for us as an organization is
extremely important it helps us
translate feedback input from our team
and from the organization to make us a
better place to be on Australia's 2021
best place to work list is a great mil
Stone it's we're super proud to be
amongst some really great organizations
uh in this list we really put focus on
on the team um during covid times tough
times we really centered our business to
focus on a few things that really matter
to keep our team employed to keep people
safe but also to keep productive
throughout the last 12 months the
message I'd like to give to our team is
a massive thank you there's so much
gratitude as a collective group people
that make up mandle group and I'm super
proud of everyone's efforts to
contribute to making it a great place to
work it's never one person in mandle
group it's always a a team that
collectively delivers on our promise as
as an
organization oh I'm back surprise I'm
not wearing a L's hat or anything like
that and I am still unmuted fantastic
we're getting the hang of this stream
deck oh sorry this streamyard thing when
it comes to uh presenting uh but you're
not here to see me present I've already
done that and you've had enough of me uh
instead uh we've got our next speaker
who's going to be up in just a moment um
and we're going to have JK and he's
going to be talking about anty framework
core and some common mistakes so I asked
JK how he would like to be introduced
for today's session and he said nothing
special to introduce me so um apparently
nothing special U to to say about JK I'm
just kidding JK is fantastic he's been a
um a huge feature at NDC over the years
um he's a Microsoft MVP uh he is a
solution architect at ssw who uh we
heard from earlier today they're one of
our partners here at NDC uh but I would
like to welcome JK to the stream and
we'll get ready to hear about some
common mistakes that you can have with
ND framework core and how we can go
about solving them hi everyone Thanks
for great uh introduction um yeah so I'm
going to talk about uh EF Co common
mistakes that I have uh uh found in
production in lots of different projects
uh it's mostly basically almost like a
group therapy of going all of the pains
that they have gone through in the past
and uh hopefully also show what are the
actual impacts of doing those mistakes
because most of the people say hey just
don't do this but you know what does it
actually happen when you do it so we're
going to have a look a little bit into
that and hopefully with that you'll be
like okay we definitely shouldn't do
that excellent sounds good I'm looking
forward to it uh but we'll welcome you
to the stage with a round of
applause that's it got to bring that in
um oh and oh Sor one final thing before
I hand it over to to J hey kick off um
for the winners of the quiz can you make
sure you reach out to NDC info NC there
we go it's across the bottom of the uh
screen now info at ndcc conferences.com
um so that we can get that stuff too but
without further Ado let's learn about
eny framework core and how to make it a
bit less
painful hey everyone all right my uh
screen sh uh hi everyone as mentioned
before I'm going to talk about some of
the common mistakes that I have found in
EF core uh lots of pain that I have gone
through it looking at other code and
trying to figure out why is it slow and
kind of also address uh one of the
issues that some people may have
regarding EF core uh saying ah it's slow
we shouldn't use that um in fact a lot
of issues uh that I have found is
basically just misunderstanding of how
EF core works and with some of the
tweaks sometimes I got even up to 100
times uh performance Improvement just to
add a few things so hopefully what we're
going to see is uh some of the issues
that you might have in your project you
can then fix them up a little bit and
bang you'll get a lot of performance uh
back uh also better memory and in the
end what is even more important better
stability to your application uh because
the application no longer needs to work
as hard as it did
before all right so a quick introduction
uh for myself I'm y kovka you can just
call me JK uh I'm solution architect at
ssw an AI Microsoft MVP you can follow
me on all of these uh socials um I'm
also organizing couple of uh couple of
meetups like APAC AI Global AI podcast
the full snack Brisbane uh user group
and predominantly I'm a net core and EF
core developer uh I'm also dabbling in
the AI but this is my main uh main thing
that I do every day and I really like to
perfect my art and this is why I have
focused quite a bit to figure out what
are the actual best practices for EF
core now um why I like to use EF core uh
is one of the B big reasons for it is
basically you get a nice balance between
features you get uh good flexibility as
well as performance uh anyone who looked
at how EF cor have developed since uh
the start of 1.0 all the way to EF 4 six
they can tell you it's not just that
we're getting a lot of features with
every single release every single
release brings us also a lot of
performance improvements which
ironically means that some of my slides
might actually no longer be relevant in
say EFG 7 maybe Microsoft will say okay
too many people have issues with that
one maybe we can solve the problem for
them so that's one really cool thing
about EF core on top of it you can
switch between different databases and
in my opinion um it's really really good
for relational
databases um not just because you have
joints and Prett performant um you can
also switch between different database
engines so you're not stuck with just
one
engine oh and we can't forget about
about migrations database scolding and
there's a lot of tooling around EF core
which is why I really love EF core and
if you have any issues and you're
thinking about hey we might need to
switch to some something else because of
performance issues or something like
that hopefully this is going to help you
stay on
track all right so one of the
motivations of why I wanted to build
this is basically a lot of issues that
uh people complained about that I have
seen say hey this is running slow uh was
uh were very easily fixed uh another
thing that I also found is that when I
fixed those issues the code actually
looked much more simpler much more
straightforward and people could read it
more easily uh which was ironic because
we actually make it more performant yet
it's more maintain able and more
readable than the original code so
sometimes optimizing a code isn't a bad
thing and uh sharing the best practices
um and those back practices are going to
be backed by uh benchmarks and tests so
you can actually not just see the
numbers uh most of them you'll be able
to just pull my GitHub and try to
replicate uh that for uh for
yourself and lastly I had some scars
regarding EF core and what I've seen and
I hope that I'll never need to see them
again all right so test methodology for
this was I used at the beginning a bch
benchmark uh tool called
benchmark.us uh memory consumption
especially the beginning of those more
horrendous um queries to just show you
that Yes actually it has a huge impact
especially when your database starts to
grow um then most of the tests are going
to go onwards with bomb Ander which is
kind of like a simple load testing tool
you can say uh have five uh active
connections and for 60 minutes try to
make as many requests as possible so we
have a little bit more um Real
Performance information we don't just
get one hit and then see how uh the
database and our application behaves we
actually are uh hitting uh the service a
little bit for a minute to see whether
the performance get worse uh over time
or we have a stable uh
performance then I also use Postman for
that doing one hit um uh queries and
also so most of the examples that I do
return back uh the actual squl statement
that was executed so that we can compare
uh what is actually executed on SQL
server for each of the
cases and all of these samples are in
Net 5 and EF Core 5 because I started
this demo about uh three months ago four
months ago and I really wanted to um
show one of my clients hey this these
are the the issues that we're having and
here are the better examples of how to
do
it all right and also this is my machine
in case you're interested what is the
performance metric for my uh what what
Hardware am I using to do all of this
performance test the SQL Server is on my
machine as well as the application so
that might not be the best perfect um
testing machine for for doing that uh
but I think uh what I have tested in
production it's a good enough indication
to tell you which code is better than
the
other all right so for the test data I
have downloaded from this link and this
test data has some simple tables like
customers employees products and sales
the most important one is the sales
which have seven million sales in it
just to drive home uh what can happen
when you write a bad code and then the
database starts to increase in size then
all of the sudden something that was
okay in performance when you develop the
application when you push it to
production a few months later suddenly
the the entire website doesn't work
anymore and I'll show a few uh pitfalls
that actually found in actual production
that caused the entire website no longer
working all right so one of the common
mistakes that we'll uh look at uh today
is going to be going from iable to
innumerable I'll show you some of the
pitfalls uh when you do this kind of
casting uh then not using snot tracking
uh you might not that EF core when you
get done from the database they're
trapped and with s not tracking uh you
can make them not not tracked and we see
the impact uh of that then getting all
data when it's not needed sounds obvious
but in a lot of
cases uh obvious doesn't seem to be
enough um explicit joints uh they are
sometimes really good uh when you do the
quer you do do include
including additional tables but they can
backfire and I can show you how you can
uh avoid those
issues then we're going to have
pagination that is also very common
issue that they have found where
pagination just W implemented
correctly uh and lastly over complex
saries are going to sprinkle a lot of
wisdom all around uh the session but
these are the main points that we're
going to to go
through and you know
when when I first started doing EF core
and when people say look you can quickly
screw up with um uh queries I was
thinking how bad can it be and for years
that kind of was in my back of my mind
but in the last two three years I really
started to look into okay how bad can it
be and let me just say that
Sometimes some questions shouldn't have
an answer and you know this might be one
of
those and let's start with something
very
innocent
counting you would
say well yeah we have here an example
that is obviously horrible right we have
naive count we have here the table sales
then we do two list and then count I
have seen this in production but you
know it's an easy fix you just remove uh
two list ands done right but there is
one less obvious
one so here we have an again sales table
but we say sa it under a variable which
is I
innumerable and then we count now
conventional a wisdom considering how C
Works would be that they should be fine
right like it's inumerable so when you
do do con obviously it's going to
execute on the database
right well they're kind of the same
thing so when you run this as an
innumerable you are getting all of the
data from the
database so this is one uh thing that
was pretty interesting uh to find
out um so yeah when you cast uh to
innumerable from that point onward
everything is in
memory and there's also the problem of
Na where um or anything that actually
has a method like this over here where
you return you're basically returning a
table but a table is not iable it's I
inumerable uh and now you can start to
think about wait we have used repository
patterns and they are returning I
innumerable and then you start to think
oh all of the data we're trying to get
from the repositories we're getting all
of the data from the from the database
without filtering first and then we're
filtering in
in in memory and then you're starting to
realize
how many places you have a performance
issues so in what I innumerable is one
of the issues that I found to be the
biggest performance and memory issues in
most of the applications and you should
avoid them as much as possible if you do
uh repository pattern maybe consider
using I quable uh for the methods that
you know that they're going to be
filtered on a higher level I quable is
not linked to EF core so if you have a
different different database engine
you'll still be able to use I cable uh
despite you know making that uh giving
you the ability to actually change uh
what is going to be CED in the
database so what's going on so why is
this a problem well first we download
the entire database obviously but this
other issues as well so because EF core
supports entity tracking what happens is
that all of these entities are being
tracked and in order to make them
tracked it consumes a little bit more
CPU and it consumes a bit more
memory uh and then once we get all of
that data we're processing them in
memory uh we're doing the filtering
we're doing selecting order bu and all
of that stuff we're doing on the net
appc application rather than on SQL
server and if that's not issue enough in
the end of the day we also need to run
all of these data through garbage
collector so garbage collector now has
to do a lot more work then it would uh
be necessary uh if we wouldn't uh need
to process everything in memory if
everything would be on SQL
server and just to give you a feel for
uh for scale so for instance if we have
7 million rows and each of them have
five
integer that on its own is already 140
megabytes of data you're downloading
from SQL Server that's already a lot on
its own and we're talking five integer
we're not talking about text and other
things and tracking also adds about four
bytes per property uh per row although I
found that uh that metric might not be
correct uh I'll need to double check on
it but at least it seems to be four
bytes per Pro property per row as far as
understand it so minimum consumption
would be 218 megabytes per core and now
imagine you're trying to count all of
the uh sales and that takes 280
megabytes
uh to count all of the rows uh that's
quite a
lot and also it's slow and uses a lot
the
CPU Now The Simple Solution here is very
simple you change from I inumerable to I
quable and this actually prevents um the
query to be executed in memory and gets
executed to SQL
server and to go back to how bad can
this be now if you have a small database
it's probably going to be a difference
in couple of
milliseconds here we have 7 million uh
Records
so yeah we can see here native count
takes just about 3.6
seconds um and takes I think this is
about 2 GB of
RAM um now this is not a perf test
especially for allocation because um
what the net Benchmark is doing is is
running the test multiple times and I'm
trying to create and dispose ef4 and
some of the memory of the previous
execution May bleed into the next test
so it may not be the perfect task but
you can see here that the difference
between the uh the one that we did with
I quable versus I inumerable
the difference in memory is massive it
you cannot even compare this uh this is
like 100 thousand times
larger uh and you know well performance
is great to have a faster and faster
execution uh which here you can see that
it's basically 63 time
faster uh I think the most important
metric here is that you you don't
consume all of the RAM on your um net
application and similar thing here for
um doing the W Closs um inumerable
versus
iable uh obviously the performance is
100 times faster as I promised you we're
going to look at things that makes 100
times faster and changing from I
inumerable to iable is one potential
candidate to increase per performance uh
even in the scales of 100 times and you
can see here that allocation is also a
massively smaller than what we had
before and you know to just drive the
point here I used Bomer and I'll show
you example how I used it um to
basically load balance this for a minute
with five connection uh as much as it
could and the results that I got is that
the naive count actually managed to do
only 0.1 request per second and it
totaled with 10 responses for five
connections constantly pinging uh for
one minute so that is actually pretty
terrible response time uh compared to to
that uh when we have improved it we're
just changing innumerable to I variable
you can see that all of the sudden in
one minute we got uh one more than
thousand requests back and the request
per second uh increased to almost 18
requests per second so the increase is
massive all right so let me before I
switch to this let me show you
in the code how this actually looks like
so over here I have the worst case
scenario um so over here what I have
done is I use I varable for this but I
could use in numerable and for the
result uh I used uh two list don't mind
tag with context for now can remove it
just to not confuse anyone uh I did two
list and then uh count so this is going
to cause U performance issue and here
the query to uh to query string I use
this this is an extension method to EF
core where you can convert a i variable
into the actual sqle statement that it
would ex execute there's one caveat to
this is that cannot do against count uh
first of
default um in C Max and couple of others
where you actually need to execute the
query so this uh two query string um is
not going to you're not going to be able
to do it against first of default and
those kind of things it's basically
almost expecting it to be a
list so that's one one issue with that
but you know it's good enough for our
case and what I have here is the
application
running I'm going to restart it just for
sake of
argument and what I'm going to do is
let's clean this
up just to show you what I'm doing is
I'm going to
take the name of the
controller is
examples
count
slash and this is worst
case and I'm going to bring up uh my uh
T task manager so here we can see that
we have 0% 300 megabytes on vus Terminal
so when I run
this you will see that CP usage jumps
significantly uh the RAM usage jumps
significantly and this is now happily
processing behind the
scenes so we wait for 10 more
seconds and we should get a results by
the way if you're interest interested
about the bom
Tool uh let me get the browser over
here you can get it on the G H
page
Bomer uh from code
sber Bomer and it's a really good
um really a good tool for you to
Benchmark uh things a little bit more
organically than you know hit with the
postman and see what's the
result now this takes a little bit of
time after it finished because it waits
for all of the requests to finish so you
can see
that it takes a long time to just finish
off
everything well now it went to 17
GB this
is this is why you try to AV inumerable
or two list
prematurely Okay this may take a while
is it
because
interesting why is Ed using that
much okay usually take that took a
little bit
faster anyways I'm trying to show the
point and I think I got my point here um
usually it finishes much sooner than
this but I'll kill this because
it takes way longer than usually
does and what I
[Music]
also okay when the St completely
Frozen that's all right I'll just kill
kill
that all right so here we can see
Zero that's wrong
I have tested this right before doing uh
this test um anyway so I'm going to run
this and I'm going to show you in
Postman over here um there's a few
things that I have done uh when we run
this um when I do one request and by the
way you'll be able to get this all in
the
GitHub when we uh run this this is going
to also respond with a specific request
uh with a specific
answer and what I'm doing is when I'm
getting a response I'm actually using
Postman to show um the result in a
little bit more stylized way with a
visualizer so hopefully yes we finally
got a response for the worst case now
when I visualize this is the qu that's
been executed on the SQL
Server now if we do the best case which
basically means this we're using I
quable you can see here that the query
changes so let's visualize this so you
can see that instead of doing the proper
select statement we just have select
count from sales and then SS but that
doesn't actually
matter so the major different here is if
I scroll down a little bit further is
that I just do count and that's
it all right let's go back to the
slides hopefully that bomb in here is
not going to cause too much uh problem
because I wanted to show some of the
performance uh uh issues that I haven't
put into the slide but we'll see as we
get to there now another thing that you
might want to consider is asot tracking
Now asot tracking what it does is it
excludes tracking on the entities uh and
that results in using less memory less
CP usage and those uh entities are not
tracked now that means that you cannot
update or delete um unless you retract
them now if you track them again
manually uh all of your properties might
be uh marked as changed and then if you
do an update it will update everything
so maybe not the best thing to do so
just use asot tracking when you want to
get R only
data but the impact of doing that is
pretty
significant uh now I don't usually see
this uh much performance Improvement uh
here we have literally five times uh
faster performance and we even uh use up
four time less memory than the uh test
uh than the initial uh code which the
only difference is that we added SN note
tracking um but what I have seen in
practice is that you get at least
33% uh better
performance and you get at least 50% uh
more uh less memory consumption so if
you can uh if you can just have the data
as spe only do use as no tracking it's a
oneliner that can give you huge
performance benefits so here you can see
that we have uh the same uh method
without esot tracking uh we got about
100 requests per second we did the same
which just adding Asal tracking and we
ended up with four times better
throughput uh than with without it so
it's a very easy way to get better
performance another issue very common
issue that I have found is also using
explicit includes uh that means that you
have not include and say we're getting
the customer table now now one of the
issue that I found found with this is uh
they usually put it into a method uh
they say okay this uh say the sales
table includes includes all of the
tables because you just want to make
sure that all of the table that you
might need on now uh but that is a
terrible thing
because even if you don't need that data
even if you do mapping and you don't use
any of that data it will generate a SQL
statement that will include the uh all
of the tables uh in your joints so you
have now an unnecessarily complicated
query and to uh solve this is for
instance over here we have a uh include
over here and we're getting all of the
data uh for that salesperson and then we
are separately doing the map in uh from
the um from the full sales uh table with
the uh sales
person now alternatively you can
actually uh do the mapping in the
database and as an added benefit you can
directly reference these sales person
that first uh name and that will result
in a implicit join uh that means that as
you can see here I am actually not using
any includes and if I uh uh if there's a
spec change that actually we don't need
to have the salesperson first name or
things like that um and we no longer
depend on the salesperson once we delete
them from uh this
mapping we suddenly have no no joints in
our uh SQL statement so you don't have
to constantly think about am I using an
include too often which have pretty
significant performance benefit uh
performance impact you you just have you
can just forget about it one note
however for this one
is if you practice as a method you need
to do it as a expression of a function
if you just uh do do uh as a regular
mapping uh thing let me show you as an
example say
we we go to the r
clause and let's just
take this one
here let's say that we do do uh select X
new
uh uh this is sales yeah so let's do uh
sales
model and let's just say that we what
we're trying to do is we're trying to
get quantity equal x quantity we want to
do sale ID X sale
ID and then we want to do product name X
product
name it's going to be product. product
name
name and let's just say that we are
returning sales model
L sales
model let just simplify this and I'll
just going to
put over here we don't need to
complicate
things uh
just bear with me for for a
moment so here we have a simple example
of how we do the mapping and what you
can do is you can actually do
control uh r m or you can
do
control
dot control Dot and then extract as
method and what you'll notice here this
is an
expression so this is going to be
executed on your
server now if I do the similar thing but
instead of this I'm going to
do this so I'm going to return the
sale
model and this is going to be
X I already have an
X and I
use map in
memory I use this
instead just do this this is now going
to be process in memory so everything
after this is actually going to be in
memory sorry not in memory uh this is a
different
trick in later EF core actually this is
executed in the server side but you will
lose this mapping over here so this is
going to result in null um so uh because
you can get only the actual uh sale uh
table sale uh entity uh it will not not
know that you actually also want to have
a reference to the product table and
this mapping over here is going to fail
whereas in this case uh where we
returning back an expression um it will
understand oh wait you're referencing
product uh so I should uh also do an
implicit join to this
product so this is one of the common
mistakes that I have seen and that
results Ed in ugly code uh that is
absolutely not necessary uh this looks
pretty nice to me and it's reusable so
you can use it in different uh queries
and also very performant because you
only get the data you
need already done the
Nemo and also the performance impact I
kind of forgot to add the performance
impact on this but uh let's do this um
we have
here did I forgot to add the MK okay I
did forgot uh but uh the performance
impact
here oh no I have here
sorry so the worst case scenario here
would be that we include
everything so if we go back to the
example joints and we got for the worst
case scenario worst case scenario is
we're trying to get
everything uh and this everything result
uh results
in need to run the application
first need to fix this
first inting
everything
the joy of doing everything uh live so I
think I can just do that and. that was
the original code I should be able to
run so the impact uh of this is going to
be
that
running I just make sure okay it's just
not putting it in the
foreground the impact of this is the
worst case scenario is going to take
obviously take a long time to run uh but
if we look at the um query you can see
that we have all of the inner joints
that we have
specified but if we look at what we're
actually using we can see that we're
only using the sales person we're not
using the product we're not using the
customer but we are still executing all
of these squares so right now it was 6.4
seconds if you run this again it's going
to be slightly better I think because
that was a cold boot yeah 4.6 but it's a
horrible
performance um now you
can it's not necessarily A Bad Case I
would uh discourage you from using this
you
can add the
include in the query and that's going to
improve the performance uh significantly
so that's only 2 seconds um but if I do
this
again it's going to result in exactly
the same problem as we had before uh
it's not going to improve performance
even though we're not using that table
now the time that you actually do want
to use uh include is when you're
updating uh the uh
the element so for instance I want to
get uh all of the sales uh for this
salesperson say we get list and we do um
wait query do uh to
list and then I actually want to
update you
complaining does not
Definition h
interesting a new one uh list is it
because I'm reusing it
h I didn't have my morning
coffee got to at async so when you're in
situation when you actually want to uh
do this and what you want to do is for
instance you want to go let's say first
one and then you want to go to the uh
sales person and then update some of the
information of that
person then in that particular case you
do want to do include because uh all of
that is going to be tracked uh and when
you do uh de DB context
May
context do
save
changes uh that is going to be updated
as well so the included uh tables are
also being tracked and you can update
them just fine now here it wouldn't
update because we have as not tracking
so in that case you would need to do um
with not tracking and for instance if I
do
uh change the name to be uh JK that
should work just fine what are you
complaining now is seeing method not
accepting ah because I
need save changes I
think yeah now it works if I run this
even though this is um this is a
included uh table it's going to update
so this is one case where you actually
do want to have
include and just to show you the best
case scenario which is with the implicit
uh join if we run
this this is not only going to need to
run
this
it's not only going to uh give you a
much more uh efficient SQL statement so
here we're not only
um efficient with the uh joints we're
also efficient for what we're asking for
and if you're interested at the end I
can show you that uh reducing the number
of uh items you getting from the
database actually impacts the
performance so
you can uh this is kind of almost double
performance gain and to in my eyes it's
actually more clear what you're trying
to do here you can see it's very clean
uh I can here I know that um this is
only read only data we're filtering
about that and we want to have it in
this shape so in my opinion that is
actually a much more cleaner code it's
very concise and as a bonus it's high
performance and it has uh it's very
memory efficient so for to me this is a
win in all regards so usually what they
tell you is don't do premature
optimization this would be the exception
of this there's almost no um side
effects of doing
this all right so the next thing that
there's a common uh issue that I found
is the
pagination uh usually uh it happens
because um what we're trying to do is
filter data we uh get the filter data so
we do two two list and then we count
them uh already and only after that we
apply tag a take and Skip and some
developers do that because they don't
know that they can use I quable to their
advantage
so for instance if we go to
the pagination
controller uh the common mistakes that
we have over here so this is the worst
case scenario here we have the query uh
we did the filter now what I have seen
and this is a very common scenario uh
you wouldn't believe how many times this
happens is we got all of the data which
is not too horrible because we are
filtering
first but what happens then is we using
uh that data to in memory process um
additional things like sking the page uh
taking um taking a slice of the results
and then mapping it just so that at the
end we can use DB result. count um so
that we can actually get the right uh
number of results so that we can then
also show the right number of pages and
stuff like that which um may look as a
reasonable code but a much better
approach to this is Leverage The I
variable here we have the query we do
the same thing as
before but what we do is we make a
separate request with this iable to
count everything so what that means is
we are telling the database that I want
to have um I want to know all of the
results based on this filter over here
and then what we do is we uh basically
do the pagination so we skip couple of
items we take couple of items and then
we uh make another request at the
database uh to basically get that one
slice of data that we're interested in
now this sounds like it should work
worse because we're doing two requests
into the database but one interesting
thing here is that it actually is the
reverse so if we do the worst case
scenario we can see over here we have a
very simple uh request we have one join
so that's not interesting but what you
may find is that this takes about 2
seconds to
run but if we do in the database for
instance uh we end up having uh a bit
more
code but so you can see here we have a
bit more variables and stuff like that
but what you can see here this takes
only
milliseconds this is on a completely
different ballpark so don't feel
uncomfortable doing uh small calls to
the database they can actually be a
significantly better way of getting data
than trying to get a lot of data from
the database and then process it in in
memory so I'm I'm just going to jump in
um a little bit we're we're up um on
time and honestly I could have I could
leave you go for like the next um
however long you left cuz like this is
really interesting really a really good
look at um a bunch of stuff so um I I
guess my first question is what's your
what's your next big tip for people um
that are wanting to to learn about some
of these common mistakes yeah so let me
there's two big tips one would be um the
um the thing with over complicated uh
queries and yeah apologies for that I
was thinking that I don't have enough
content but I end up having too much um
we all have been in that space um so one
thing that and this is all on GitHub and
I have done some performance Benchmark
and I'm going to improve them but one
thing that I learned is um there is a
thing where you can actually split split
queres into multiple ones there's a
feature called aslit queries there un
caveat to it unfortunately don't have
time to get into it uh where it allows
you to split up the queries into smaller
queries for instance salesperson there
might be only one and it will carry only
one
salesperson uh instead of duplicating
multiple ones in the same row that saves
you a lot of sto a lot of transfer and
also a lot of SQL surfware um process
but you can also do it manually which I
found to be almost two to three times
faster than secq server uh sorry then EF
core which is but it's very simple you
just query the person ahead of time and
then carry all of the data that you want
for that person and then uh just a
simple for for Loop uh you join those
data together and this is like two three
times faster if you struggle with
performance in this particular
case another thing that I want to last
oh yeah go okay one last thing yeah
cancelable queries so this is very
important uh you may see that I'm doing
in the um uh request I'm doing
cancellation uh token and I'm including
those cancellation tokens in the two
list in the safe changes in first of
default async and the reason for this is
if you cancel your your HTTP request the
this cancellation token gets cancelled
and if you um if you don't um listen to
this canellation token uh what happens
is the SQL Server will still go on so if
you have that count example where it
took six seconds to process this six
seconds still going to happen in SQL
Server yeah oh that's that's a really
good tip I i' never to capture the
cancellation token of the HTTP request
and use and kind of pass that um
essentially as a kill code through to
your underlying database um calls as
well just before we we um wrap up with
you oh oh I see that's the the slides um
sorry the links to your demos um I did
have someone ask a question that I also
was wondering the answer to the
implicity include stuff um is that new
to Entity framework cuz I always
remember old yeah having um the problem
with the implicit include is that uh
most people um use them incorrectly so
for instance they did the manual mapping
and the manual sorry they did the
mapping and they did the mapping say
cell model uh
map cell right so they did this uh which
is wrong uh and this cause the implicit
mapping to not work uh if you struggle
to uh to figure out how to do this just
make the selection do control Dot and um
basically introduce why don't you want
to introduce the method anyways usually
it gives you the intelligence to
introduce a method and that is the right
uh way of doing
it cool well um excellent thanks for
that like I said that was really really
excellent and I I loved how you step
through all the demos and kind of broke
each um step down piece by piece cuz
that um that I I I was able to really
follow along um how how you kind of got
to each step of the process and how you
uncovered um the different changes that
happened along the way um but yes
unfortunately we are we are just about
out of time um and it is well it's
coming up to lunch at least here in
Sydney I know that you're in Brisbane
and you're like lunch that's still at
least an hour
away um but uh I'm going to invite uh L
back to the stream um well at least I'm
going to hope the L is there because
we're having a change over in our
producers in the back end oh no there he
is and um he still got pants I still
depends on I apologize for the poor
video quality but it'll all make sense
in a in a
moment yeah because what are we doing
Aaron uh so um something that we wanted
to try this time uh and try and make a
bit more of a like a um interactive
virtual conference is uh this is gather
toown uh so if you if you signed up for
NDC um or if you want to join um go over
to the NDC Sydney website and sign up um
you can jump into GA town and it's a
it's a virtual networking experience so
uh we can see L running around um what
so what are you doing lar so um so this
is yeah it's like a virtual space for
events right cuz we we now live in
virtual world at least for a little bit
and it's a it's a nice way of kind of
bringing people that are otherwise just
on a YouTube stream or a WebEx call or
whatever onto the same sort of
experience so we're going to try this um
now with the camera as you can see on my
screen I have the camera off here now I
put two cameras on before so I've got
like one camera right there I'm talking
to you and there's one just above it
which is the other
one when I put both on it my computer
went hang on what are you doing I'm just
not going to let you do that so we'll
see how that goes but I might have to
cut the camera for here for that one and
put the other one on on
streamyard uh sorry on gather town right
so here we go but the idea is that you
can come and join me now if you do talk
to me on on the call actually as you can
see this is streaming to YouTube this
just my screen share um but do go in and
try and find someone you don't know you
know walk up to them like I'll do now
I'm just G to cut this camera so
apologies I'm gonna go off the camera
there and I'm going to turn the other
one on here
and we'll see so there we go so I'm in
the corner down there as you can see and
now I'm going to try and go and talk to
Dave and now we'll see how it works with
two microphones as well that's gonna be
interesting anyway I'm gonna go down to
Dave I was just busy uh creating my own
avatar and joining in and seeing how
much of a mess that I can make it by
also being on that's right so now I've
walked up to Dave and Dave can hear me
and I can hear him but whether the sound
is going out to YouTube that's another
thing that we're trying I don't know
um that's
right we're going to test the the limits
of rural Australia networking no no it's
El's Network um so I'm just gonna turn
the oh I don't know what I'm doing can
you hear me on the YouTubes and can you
hear Dave can someone just put that in
the
comments all right you're now banned
from this this the
hey guys that's awesome um yeah okay
well yeah so can he L not Dave is what
I've got cool all right so that didn't
work so I'm gonna mute
[Music]
on so
I
then then I can I can join so you can
have two copies of me I don't know which
one's the
Audio I I know it get it gets very
audio
oh we probably won't hear audio on
stream from uh the people that joined
unless L shares his screen with desktop
audio
um
[Music]
so
no can only hear Aaron giggling that's
because Aaron's in streamy audio he's
not in gather toown
audio ah so um but I'm on audio now at
least so you can hear one quarter of the
conversation because there's four or
three other people here go to gather
town uh you should have a link in your
emails um otherwise just uh reach out in
the which track are we going
for the general track um if you don't
know how to to to join uh and someone
will help you get there uh it's kind of
neat actually so please
do um we can't get the audio to work
where the screen here which is
interesting this is a oh look at that
see I could hear that
yeah it's probably through me
um yeah
exactly you are hearing me vi
streamyard well that's both y so but
otherwise people can't hear
me no it's odd cuz I have shared it oh
but now it's not sharing hang on why is
it that different so it's sharing it oh
now I'm sharing the whole window okay
I'm gonna try again I'm gonna stop
sharing soorry Chin Chin's gonna go oh
God not again um I'm gonna share Chrome
tab again and I'm G to share tab audio
and now try this gen are we gonna get
audio through
now uh I don't know so we can still each
hello somebody yeah we'll
see if it go through so yeah
okay so if I if I mute the
stream
thing yeah hey
sure
not working but
I yeah I probably
shouldn't oh someone said they heard me
on YouTube
it's not I'm not sure I'm not sure it's
worth it but never
mind like his Avatar should yeah his
Avatar should do
more we can so I'm I'm watching all the
the various communication back
channels so I can yeah I can see how
organizers like
Channel as well as listening on YouTube
listening on streamyard listening and
gathered down yeah now that I know that
they can hear me I'm gonna stop
talking producer
hello I'm gonna close the stream because
that's
[Laughter]
trippy the
be
Al a proximity audio that's
interesting bye
YouTube
so when you walk into some of these
darker areas that's the private spaces
oh wow this is a bit laggy there we
go oh so we got two over here Stephen
and Eugene see they're in a private
space see it's how it's gray oh Aaron's
in here JK why are you all in there I'm
just gonna walk
fast can't hear anything and probably
has gone on far too long is someone
saying on
YouTube um what we can do is that you
can also just go join gather town
instead of watching on
YouTube Dave go away dve there he is
trying to
get because then we can go and talk to
other people that are not on
YouTube
so it was worth a try
though I
think all right because this is
interesting with the sound
I'm just going to stop the screen share
go and join there we go hello everyone
actually I can change the camera over
now I think let's do a better camera
shall
we that's better there we go all right
so yeah please don't unjoin GA on they
didn't quite work as we intended audio
through tabs and screen sharing is
tricky um but H do go and join gch
because that will actually give you all
of what I just showed you right so you
can talk to people meet new people that
you might not have known that's kind of
one of the reasons of going to
conferences is that you pick someone
else's brain on what makes them uh
interested in technology and what they
think is a cool developer thing so go do
that um I'm G to hang out and gather
town for the next while and you can all
come and find me if you want or find
someone else um but we will be back with
sessions at 12:30 I believe it is let me
just check the schedule um sorry 1:30 of
course um and and yep we'll be back at
1:30 um
with David W just
talk um sorry Williams talk William
liberg G to get my schedule right um so
we'll see you all
then for after
lunch
[Music]
e
la
[Music]
for
he
[Music]
[Applause]
la
[Music]
are you an engineer looking to impact
millions of Australians we're looking
for big thinkers problem solvers and
challenge Seekers to help us engineer
the future of banking combank
engineering do you have what it takes
search engineering at
combank and finally the top spot on our
list of medium best workplace winners
for 2021 rocketing up from number nine
in 2020 to the top place this year
congratulations to our number one best
workplace in the medium category mantle
group mantle group is a business that
truly lives its principles customers
rate its Service delivery as excellent
Executives embody the best
characteristics of the company employees
and management are in it together as one
employee put it the co crisis was tough
for many businesses and watching a team
of over 250 people reach consensus to
get through the darkness together will
be one of the highlights of my working
life to be satisfied with great place to
work here for us as an organization is
extremely important it helps us
translate feedback input from our team
and from the organization to make us a
better place to be on Australia's 2021
best place to work list is a great
milestone it's we're super proud to be
amongst some really great organizations
uh in this list we really put focus on
on the team uh during covid times tough
times we really centered our business to
focus on a few things that really matter
to keep our team employed to keep people
safe but also to keep productive
throughout the last 12 months the
message I'd like to give to our team is
a massive thank you there's so much
gratitude as a collective group of
people that make up mandal group and I'm
super proud of everyone's efforts to
contribute to making it a great place to
work it's never one person in mtle group
it's always a a team that collectively
delivers on our promise as as an
[Music]
organization
International women's day is a key
period of Time For Us within the shelter
and the opportunity to raise funds sits
right beside that just days before
International women's day our website
was
hacked we contacted telra purple and the
team just didn't even take a second
thought we had a call late in the
afternoon asking whether or not our team
could help knowing that the users
contributing to the shelter through the
website were trying to make a a whole
lot of difference anything we could do
to help there was was really important
to us as a
group they took a website that had been
completely destroyed and they rebuilt it
in probably less than 48
hours the kindness of strangers is
actually what makes this shelter run t
St purple they took their skill their
love their passion and they used it for
purpose and they used it for good
Hello everybody welcome back to uh the
afternoon session of NDC Sydney 2021 my
name is Dave I'm G be one of your
co-hosts for this uh next little bit um
if you haven't yet please don't forget
to check out the expo at expo. NC
sydney.com uh most importantly you can
enter and win prizes it's which is
probably what we're all here for um but
I'm not going to waste any more of your
time because you're not here to see me
uh let me bring on my our next talk uh
speaker who needs no introduction
William welcome back to the stage the
virtual stage uh and uh yeah you're
going to talk to us all about uh arms I
believe uh arms and bicep yes Dave uh so
I got to talk a bit about um how we
automate infrastructure creation or
provisioning in Azure uh using this new
tool called bicep awesome well I'll let
you take it away folks please ask
questions and I will uh happily parro
them at William after the talk take
William all right thanks Dave so hello
everybody uh I'm going to be talking to
you about flexing your biceps with Azure
and we're going to start off with a very
rough definition of infrastructure as
code now the point of infrastructure as
code or ioc is to automate the provision
in of your resources in
Cloud uh usually now it's it's been
triggered by the success of cicd
pipelines becoming very popular play you
that's these are the tools we use to
automate everything we do uh sort of on
the platform side and even on the build
side right so we want to build our
software and want to provision our
Hardware uh and you know we don't want
to do it by hand so the cicd processes
along with infrastructure code is is you
know a big part of what I do as well
every day now why we do this is to help
manage our cost risk and to increase the
speed of delivery for our applications
but the cloud infrastructure Cloud
applications that whole landscape is
getting very complicated there's there's
hundreds thousands of different services
that we can uh deploy into the cloud uh
you know from all the different
providers but for me I see a lot of the
sort of just data formats like Jason
yaml and XML everywhere you know this is
what a lot of uh sort of the go-to
choice for people to Define their
resources uh and the configurations for
those resources as well but they're just
data formats and then to get them to be
a bit more Dynamic a bit more
intelligent we've tried to shoehorn uh
like programming constructs into them
for instance so we'll look at some of
the the classic arm Json templates uh
and compare that with the bicep and
other sort of ioc providers out there
because for me as an engineer I like to
keep everything simple so I want to
follow that uh keep it simple and or
keep it sweet and short uh principle so
you can say that in different ways but
that's my
favorite a little bit about myself uh my
name is William I'm a lead software
engineer at zenix uh so spend a lot of
time do with customers building new
projects for them but also play a big
part in the platform side to make sure
that we can uh migrate customers into
Asia that need to or enable them to get
into Azure as
well uh you can find me on Twitter have
uh a GitHub repo as well uh and Linkedin
so if you want to engage me in any of
those feel free also have a blog site
called Azure
gems. and a lot of today's talk will
also go on there and you can find me on
the mail.net Meetup page as well so uh
yeah like I said big fan of azure pretty
much every day I do something Azure
related uh and and net been using net
since version two uh
since
200 five I forget the day or the year
now it's a long time ago but skipped the
first version think what's this crazy
new technology I was a a very dedicated
C++ fan back then uh but then you know
net 2 came around changed my life it
changed my career basically as well so
been doing net ever since uh currently
big fan of Blazer we assembly pairing
that with some of the serverless
offerings like Azure functions and
Cosmos DB so can definitely write up
some really cool applications using
those services but the new favorite is
uh Azure bicep so that's is the tool
that we're going to be looking at
today and just for the agenda so I'm
going to quickly cover what is azure
bicep compare that with the other uh
providers out there like terraform and
palumi and then see how do we use Azure
bicep what we can do with it there's a
cool new feature out called bicep
Registries and we look at how we can en
capsulate our complex architectures
using these Registries and demos
everywhere so yeah we're going to going
to have some
fun now first I have to explain where
arm comes from so it's actually the
Azure resource manager we can see that
the Azure portal po shell the Azure CLI
and even other rest cles they all either
talk directly to the arm rest API or via
one of the uh sdks from Azure so net
python
go I think there's a variety of them now
can't keep up so many but it's a way
that we interact with the irm or aure
resource manager to go and create the
the resources or the services that we
require for our applications so data
stores we apps VMS this just a whole
whole stack of them but what is azure
bicep so first it's literally we start
with a file it's some code in a file
infrastructure as code this time time I
think we're going to be dealing with
real code rather than sort of a a weird
mishmash of of data format with some
programming sugar added to it we're can
start with the bicep file and we're
calling this arm bicep because once we
actually take this bicep file and we try
to deploy it in the background when we
call the Azure CLI bicep build it takes
the bicep file and transpiles it into
the
existing arm Json that we used to and in
a moment we'll see what the sort of
differences are
with between these two files um but you
know up until recently we actually had
to do this manually it have to do the
build and then we can deploy the Json
file that was output from that but the
the tooling has improved a bit so we can
actually deploy the bicep file directly
so sort of like just in time compiled
for us you know we don't have to care
about turning it into adjacent file so
again then that file the B file will hit
the armm interface and it will just go
and provision whatever resources we need
you can see there's you more than 250
available resources in Asia right
now uh and just to recap there's two
types Jason and Biser but they're both
called arm templates so I guess now we
have to be a bit more specific when we
talk to someone which one we're actually
talking about but I kind hope when we
say arm templates you're just going to
mean bicep ones you don't want to touch
the old Jason one anymore uh because
we'll see why and both of them yeah so
they they end up translating to calls
into the armm uh to make these resources
that we want
appear and just a further definition of
of bicep so it's it's a domain specific
language DSL so it's actually
dedicated uh language to describe the
resources that we want we're not
piggybacking off something that already
existed trying to make it do what we
want this is dedicated for creating
stuff in Azure way simpler to write
something in bicep than it is compared
to Jason now they've added a few extra
sort of cool things to it so you can
actually have more modular templates and
we can actually reuse our code a lot
easier than we previously could um but
it doesn't matter you know in the end it
still provide transpar to the Json
equivalent underneath uh but it's
actually quite a lot of Json underneath
you don't really want to be playing
around with it and the stuff that we can
do in bicep you can definitely do in arm
you that's it's all everything has to go
through arm Json but they've just made
it so much
easier and so this is what a basic very
basic bicep template would look like uh
in this case I'm just creating a storage
account and just like the um Json files
that we used to we've got input
parameters so just highlighted with the
param keyword give it a a symbolic name
so in this case storage account name and
we can give it a type uh in this case
it's a
string then we can go ahead and Define
our actual resource and we're going to
look at a few of these during the talk
today but in this case I'm creating a
storage account uh start with the
resource keyword storage account
symbolic name so it's like an object in
reuse or like a variable in in most of
our program programming languages in
fact it's an object so we'll see later
if you use that dot notation you can
actually drill down into that resource
to you inspect some of it properties and
reuse them and then we actually specify
after that the resource provider type so
these are um sort of carryover stuff
from the um Json templates um instead of
a type we just give it there the Holst
string there with an API version and but
it's really cool they've made this a
whole lot easier as well with bicep with
the tooling provided in vs code um and
we get some really cool intellisense as
well now another thing that we can do
with the bicep is that once it's run
through and provisioned a a resource for
us we can actually pull some properties
out of that resource and uh send it as
an output so we can either print that to
console or we can actually wire it into
another arm template or bicep template
so it's definitely uh quite useful to
wire up multiple things and create a
longer
process so that basic storage account
example uh it's on the left hand side
now the screen's a bit tiny but just to
sort of show that the bicep on the left
a lot simpler than the arm Json on the
right hand side so when we take the
bicep file we build it or transpile it
we uh we get the the thing on the right
hand side there so you can see it's
almost half the length uh in this case
and it does vary a little bit from
resource to Resource and the number of
um properties that they have Etc and all
the different constructs that we're
using functions and conditionals all
that but generally it saves a lot of a
lot of key stricks a lot of time big fan
of
that so I'm going to quickly jump into a
demo and if that
works there we
go um now I'm in this
code and I've got a folder ready to go
and create just a a storage
account and if I can type correctly I'm
call it storage account. bicep
what you need to do first obviously to
get going with this you need to install
the bicep language service and there's a
cool little extension here you just
click that one install that current
version
4.108 that's the latest one and once you
have that installed you can do some
really cool things so if we go and type
in the resource well RS for short we got
a pop up so we can already get some
intelligence here to say you are trying
to create a type of resource let me show
you the ones that are available so you
can scroll down here and look for all
sort stuff you can see there's all the
various API flavors of cosal DB data L
firewalls key VA there's is quite a lot
of stuff already there so some nice
Snippets so what I'm looking for right
now would be storage so if I
just out that one click enter
automatically we've got all this code
done for us it's quite nice so what we
then can do is give this a symbolic name
I'm just going to keep the one called
storage account but you can obviously
change that to whatever unique variable
you want then uh we need to give it a
name so I'm just going to call this
um
store
21 uh we can change the version and we
can see here they automatically got some
intellisense to show us all the possible
values for that the the type of Sor
count that we want all the different
numerations here so I'm going to keep
the latest one V2 and even here we can
change the skew type
but works now well not long ago the this
one was not available so they they're
constantly improving the Intel sense
from a lot of the feedback on GitHub and
so forth is when uh a particular
resource uh property is not available uh
it means that there might be a piece
missing from the arm Swagger definition
so the Azure and bicep team are working
quite hard to sort of make sure that all
these um bad definitions or missing
definitions uh get fixed up so now
that's cool now we can actually easily
see what type of storage account we want
to provision so I'm just going to pick
this standard one
here and this is already a done bicep
module you can actually take this one
and deploy it so let's see if that
actually works so I've already got a
little Parell script here just to go and
create a resource Group for me so so
it's a group create give it a name give
it a location and then we want to go and
deploy this template to our Resource
Group we make sure we save the the
correct file so in this case storage
account. bicep not
Jason um and give some parameters I was
going to
say Let's do let's add a
parameter want to have a parameter want
to have storage account
name so we can actually make this a bit
more Dynamic I want to hard code strings
um and it's a string we can give it
default value we can just call
Fred but it complains about something
here to say
literals
uh strings are defined using single
quotes in bicep so that's right so what
we also have is a linting tool that's
sort of built into the bicep language
service it tells us when we're doing
things wrong and we can actually
configure that as well we'll show it a
bit later so strings are all done with
single quotes in bicep cool and we're
say see here that we're actually not
using our storage account name parameter
so I'm just going to take that and put
it in
here cool so don't have a hardcoded name
anymore so I'm going to copy this make
sure that it is the same in here storage
account name yep all right so now for
the scary bit let's just go make sure
I'm in the right folder and I'm going to
deploy the storage C straight
away there we go uh it's gone and
created a resource Group for us and it
should now be spinning around in the
background to create the storage account
as well so if I go to my Azure portal
refresh hopefully see that here NC
storage there's the resource
Group and I'll quickly get to the
deployments tab
we can see here our storage account is
actually being deployed right now which
is
cool and what we can also do is you see
the inputs that went into this template
so that's the name we gave the storage
account there aren't any outputs just
yet uh but the template that we actually
it's running against we can see here is
now the Json template that's the uh the
Json equivalent equivalent of the bait
Bice set file trying to say that fast
five times um so let's see it here we go
the resource uh has been completed can
go there here is our storage account and
we can see it's all it's all working
great so here we go and the CLI finished
for us which is really really awesome so
we have a a bicep file that deploys a
storage account nice and simple uh Happy
Days so we can actually see just to show
you one more thing if we look add the
storage account you go control space see
there's other properties there identity
so if we old tab on that it'll tell us
whether it's an object or an array we go
in there order to complete here's all
the other fields you know it's nice and
discoverable it's it's how you want a
programming language or a domain
specific language to work so the tooling
is really great we don't really have to
go back to the the Microsoft doc site uh
often it still happens now and then
something that's missing like I said
earlier but this is a lot a lot nicer so
you know we can go there and we can sign
even tells if the bullion and gives us
some Auto completion that's so
cool leave that there and
um what I also want to show you so I've
created a resource I've got parameters
but there's a whole lot more we can do
like I said it's a it's a a domain
specific language is like a programming
language so I've got a whole bunch of
examples here I'm going to start from
top and work my way down so the basics
that goes into a biasp template is
parameters so like I said I showed
earlier we can have a parameter give it
a name give it a type and default value
you can actually have it just like that
no default value so then it becomes a
required
parameter but we can also say these are
the allowed values so you can't give me
an input other than these three so I
only want to have Australia east
Southeast and West us as my locations
where I'm going to deploy this resource
and so if I try and give it one that
says East US it'll say can't do that
sorry denied so we can then also go
further and have real comments in our
code now which is not it's not ajacent
thing you can't really have comments in
Jason until recently they they said did
make that work but uh yeah now we can
actually add comments make our Bice file
sort of be a bit more descriptive and
have some good information in there we
can add other decorators so apart from
allowed there's things like
description and max length so you can
actually say what this input parameter
is for you give it a description the
name of the project and the maximum
length so 32 characters or if it's a
different type of value so for numeral
types or integers we can give it a Min
and max value which is really cool and a
description so we can just pile up all
these things and we'll see later on when
we reuse another template uh how useful
it is when it shows you uh these
descriptions when you're reusing a
template we can also go a bit further
and include secure strengths now what
this means is you still give it an API
key or a password or something sensitive
it's just that when your template is
being deployed that value will not be
displayed anywhere it will not be logged
but the Trap is if you do assign it to
something else that you do want to log
or um you pass into a script that then
goes and prints into the console then
you've exposed that key so just be wary
that it's not going to be a magic
solution you can still do the wrong
thing but it already just helps you for
the basics so that you don't want to
expose keys or stuff like that by
accident now we can also go and Define
variables using um functions so a lot of
the arm functions pretty much all of
them they've all carried over into bicep
so here for instance I'm creating a
variable called storage account name and
I'm following a convention so fixing it
with the name storage and I want to make
sure it's a maximum length of six and
I'm using a hash of the resource Group
ID so it's going to be storage and some
random characters after that as an end
result is yeah quite nice so you can U
create some conventions for all your
resources in Azure makes things nice and
easy to understand easy to
follow and um last up in this little bit
is outputs like I mentioned you can
actually print values uh to the cont
console or into other modules when uh
this one has completed being deployed so
and you can give hardcode values you can
pass in other variables or you can do
the same thing and Define it with
functions as well so whatever you need
you can output from your template which
is really
nice um so I've already done this one to
show you how to create a resource at
storage account so I can skip that
one and one of the input parameters for
instance here this one enable Geo
replication it's a Boolean so you can
give it a value of true and false but we
can actually use the conditional
operator in the code to say if this is
true do this otherwise do that so if I
enable Geo replication I want use a
standard GRS type uh storage account or
a premium local redundancy uh store so
um yeah nice and easy so there's other
ways you can do this as well you can
have the comparison operators most of
most of the logical operators that you
uh expect to be available are there so
you can actually find the whole table in
the in the
documentation so the next one is modules
this is what makes arm templates or
bicep templates extremely useful so we
can go and create a uh bicep file and
basically every bicep file is already a
module we can reuse all the files that
we've created before and chain them
together so that storage account that
we've created earlier I can actually
reference that using the module keyword
give it a symbolic name tell it which
file we want to use and this will
actually do the intelligence for us if
you have them stored in folders it'll
discover that for you and show you the
options that are available and then for
instance in this case I'll just I'm just
going to go Del this
line and show you what happens so it's
giving me a red squiggles and saying
something's wrong uh it needs to have
the
prams uh included so if we go control
space it'll show us what we can do
parameters are required press Tab and it
already knows that other module that
we're referencing the storage account
module this is the input that it
requires so it it sort of completes it
for you much easier to discover rather
than you have to go look at the other
file and do it all manually so save a
whole lot of time so I'm going to just
replace that with what the original one
is and what I haven't shown you yet is
that what we're doing here is string
interpolation so we give giving a prefix
uh using that dollar and squiggle
bracket syntax we can then
render the value of another variable
into the string and if we actually tried
something different if we try to do just
basic string
concatenation which oops should work and
normally it does but you can actually
say
um oh maybe it doesn't work oh yes
that's right doesn't work that you have
to use conat and then you do
this and we do this and then it will
give us a yellow sque that's right so
the recommendation is actually to use
use the string interpolation instead of
this function fair enough so it's very
helpful it tells us what's best practice
and I'll show you later actually how you
can configure what you think your best
practices are cool so string
interpolation we can do modules we can
also do looping so um very simple we
want to say create multiple storage
accounts so we give it a value uh two in
this case and when we deploy it we're
going to go and create a base name
reference that storage account module
cool and we're going to Loop through
this range this this count of ours twice
so we get an index variable called I and
we can then reuse that inside of this
object so if you notice there's a square
bracket here and here so we want to
create an array uh of objects and here
is individual object inside so it's
going to loop around and create us all
these storage accounts with whatever
logic and properties we put in the
middle here cool but we don't have we're
not limited to one way of doing uh
arrays or sorry Loops we can actually
use array elements so if I've got an
input of a number of strings I can then
re iterate over that using the the for
each sort of syntax that we used to in
other um languages so for name in
storage names I can then go and get that
that name uh element and just use it as
I like as normal cool and there's one
more one now there like a combination of
the two types before um same thing I've
got a an object here with some input
values and I want to Loop across that uh
and not only do I want the individual
object but I want to have the index for
that object as well so uh it's very
useful so you know I find when we're
doing VMS and network um setups you know
to Loop through a lot of these
configurations that we pass in that this
is very useful it makes it quite nice
and easy always make it s of part of
some of the naming Zone one zone two Etc
now we can do other things so we can
actually tell our bicep template you
know what sort of scope we're dealing
with so by default when we try to define
a resource or use a module and when we
deploy it it'll go to the current
Resource Group so when we deploy
something to aure we always have to
specify a resource Group name because
we're using the deploy group
create okay so by default this is going
to go to that same Resource Group that
we specified but we can actually with
bias is much easier than in the the arm
Json to deploy things to other resource
groups so it's you can change the scope
use the resource Group function and give
it the name of that Resource Group
pretty cool much easier so you can
actually deploy things across multiple
resource groups from one template uh you
know because you might want to keep your
databases in one place versus the um the
application because of some arback that
you want to add to that Resource Group
you know all sorts of reasons why you
want to do that and this makes it way
easier
uh and then we can actually go through
and and do the same thing but even
further than different resource groups
we can go to different um subscriptions
which is also really cool so you can
actually deploy uh to your uh Disaster
Recovery subscription or even later we
can see different tenant then uh you
know it's quite nice to do that all from
one place much much easier and uh so
here again of I another version of what
we saw before is that by the at the top
of the template we can complet change
the scope to go uh to subscription level
resources uh instead of Resource Group
level resources and I can actually go
and create resources in this case as
well and more you know storage accounts
VMS apps Etc so we have a lot of power
available so even on the tenant level so
we can go and deploy uh I've got a a
Management Group template here to a
particular tenant uh you know policies
and all the other things that we want to
have um in terms of governance for our
subscription or our tenant sorry we can
do that as well it's all very easy very
nice and simple
now and one sort of interesting thing
that sort of Chang the way I do my arm
templates now is this comes from the
Microsoft docs actually to is to use
config Maps so normally we pump in a lot
of parameters for each environment so we
might have a parameters dodev Json file
so it's got all the development
environment specific values that we want
to use in terms of scale performance
tiers and then we have another one for
test eting production so forth but an
alternative way of doing that is to
actually sort of have those values or
those performance figures um inside of a
bicep template for the different
environments so we Define the values for
a web app the skew for a web app in
production and same for staging and same
for development and in our code what we
do is so we we as an input parameter we
say which environment we want work with
and then when we create a resource uh
when we say looking at the skew name we
can just index into our config map for
that particular environment name and get
the web app skew name which is cool and
I think there's a typle here sky but
anyways I'm not going to run this one
but you get the idea so it's it's quite
nice it's nice and easy to follow we can
see everything it's quite cool all right
so that's the basics of arm templates
there Bice templates all the programming
constructs you want we can do loops
conditionals modules and changing the
scope is quite
cool all
right so what AZ your B said not you
what does it not
do um so it it's not a full
configuration management tool it's it's
really just responsible for provisioning
resources in aure and then that's it you
know there's no further configuration
after that so if we spin up a VM we
don't get to then say what software to
install and rules and policies to apply
to that that VM that's those there's
other tools available for that but you
know so things like chef and puppet Etc
they are definitely the sort of
full-fledged configuration management
tools and some of them even do Cloud
infrastructure provisioning as well but
uh yeah in my opinion sort of the bicep
is sort of an arm templat it's a much
nicer tool to use in some of those but
you know your mileage might vary uh if
if the best tool for the driver is
usually the one you know the best as
well so um you know no problem using
those tools at all so I'm going to
compare bicep with terraform and palumi
the ones that I've used the fairb in the
past and uh I sort of summed it all up
in in one big big
table what sets Azure bicep apart from
terraform and palumi is things like
State
Management where Azure bicep has access
to the LIF state of your resources in
Asia whereas terraform and palumi they
actually manage that state outside of
azure by themselves and there's a whole
lot of good reasons for that you know um
applying uh when config configuration
drift comes into play someone's been
messing around with the resources in in
the portal then we can have this known
state that we want things to be in and
we can use that to then correct that
drift and bring everything back into um
what we need it to be now Azure Bice can
do the same as a declarative uh
templates this is how things needs to be
but uh it live queries the states rather
than managing it outside and uh the uh
the way that palumi does it is very
similar to terraform as well but the way
that they offer it is a little bit
different so by default palumi has a
manage service so they do that for you
out of the box so if you have an account
that state is stored in the palumi
services for you whereas with terraform
is usually stored locally but you can
store that in Cloud elsewhere with some
of their other sass options but you have
to pay for that so it's not just free
out of the box um bicep it's a DSL for
itself terraform HCL which is a hashy
COR configuration language again
dedicated way of doing things it's quite
nice quite simple it's extremely popular
uh also where I work everyone loves
using terraform I'm currently trying to
convince everyone to use bicep we'll see
how that goes um and then there's palumi
but it's different it's using our common
programming languages to to get the job
done so they support a whole lot of them
c f JavaScript hyperscript go Python and
you can do some really complicated stuff
that you may not actually be able to do
easily with bicep or
terraform but it just yeah even though
I've had great success with it it is
actually a little bit harder to learn
and get used to it there's a few quirks
in there especially when it comes to
wiring up the outputs to inputs of other
resources where I I found palumi which
is a little bit hard to get get sorted
for me but but um these are all awesome
options they differ a little bit in uh
the way that the projects are managed so
we can have modules in both Azure bicep
and terraform but in palumi sort of it's
a code project so they're sort of like
monolithic applications or deployment
applications or or micro projects it
depends on the size but um it's specific
to that stack that you're trying to work
with it's a it's a lot harder to reuse
the palumi stuff compared to what we can
with bicep and terraform uh multic cloud
is a big thing for some people but it
doesn't really matter too much now I
think the best tool for the job is the
the cloud provide a specific tool to use
uh it's just yeah if you want to use
something like terraform to go multic
Cloud you will actually need to be
skilled up in both clouds to know what
you you can do it's not going to
magically solve that problem for you but
some people just like to see that it's a
tool is multic cloud um now the support
is provided by each of the respecting
companies Microsoft has called palumi um
but even though with terraform you can
deploy your resources into Azure if
something goes wrong you have to go to
hashy call for support Microsoft might
support you directly um you know
depending on a bunch of stuff I guess
but they're all open source which is
great you can see how the things work
under the covers and contribute for in
different ways so yeah go go and have
fun with that it's really cool now the
last one the learning curve measurement
is totally subjective I just made this
up for what I feel like uh your your
view on that might be different so uh
for me spending a lot of time in arm
with
Jason getting into bic is super easy so
you know there's no learning curve there
for me but the terraform pum was a
little bit more work to get used
to so how do we really use bicep uh
properly uh well first you have to start
by installing the tools uh you can do
that with the CLI or P shell and you can
choose your your flavor there doesn't
matter uh if you want to use it with the
CLI it's not already on there and you
just go a bicep install and when there's
an update you can just run as bicep
upgrade and you can run all this stuff
in your devops pipeline so as your
devops and GitHub actions or GitHub
workflows you can use the to do all your
work as well so I'll just go and show
you another uh quick
demo and might have to cut it short
because I think we're running a low on
time
um
so I have a bunch of stuff in here one
of them is called a full stack web
application and inside of here got a
whole bunch of stuff so I've got a key
Vault there's a database there's a
storage account uh got two may have been
by accident um and then actual web up
itself so I've spent a b of time
crafting up this application got a whole
bunch of inputs you I also want to have
project names environment names and tags
you for bilding and other discover
discoverability purposes all the allowed
inputs and then I go and Define my
resources I've got log analytics app
insights uh which then here oh this is
one I haven't pointed out before is in
arm templates you have to always have
the depends on property to say how the
re resources relate to each other so
that it can work out the most optimal
way and the dependencies of how to
deploy your your template so you can't
chicken and egg problem deploy database
before there's a server just won't work
so if you put the dependencies there
it'll deploy the server and then the
database and you know this is what's
happening here so it just by reusing
this object that resource that
implicitly creates that dependency for
us which is really cool and so as we
going on this a whole bunch of stuff
here just defining a web application
like normal um and uh adding key Vault
Secrets policies there what have I got a
whole bunch of stuff yeah I even
actually adding some R back here so we
can use
um turn on a authentication between our
my application and Azure monitor is cool
so you can't just uh spam the Telemetry
using the instrumentation key you must
actually come from that application so
micos asual make sure the app is
authenticated with Azure Monitor and
only that app can send stuff to Azure
monitor which is quite nice um so what I
want to do is to actually deploy that
app and just let it run while I move on
to the next bit so if I go to
there I'm not on Linux anymore so I want
to go to
Registries and then I want to
deploy web
app this all work
still um so I've created just a poell
file same deal as before create a
resource Group and then go let me show
you and create the deployment so I've
got the the template file here just
given the resource Group and name uh and
some input parameters and that should be
good to go so it'll take a couple of
minutes and uh we'll come back to this
uh shortly now what I mentioned earlier
devops big part of what we do every day
just to show you that it is uh totally
uh nice and easy to do in say GitHub
actions GitHub workflows here's one
workflow I have set up for this
application we can go and run a a job
here to lint or you apply the linting
rules to our bicep template file we just
do that simply by running the a bicep
build uh command and giving them that
file so that will actually run against
what configuration we have in our folder
to you say hey are you following best
practices or not like hardcoded strings
or passwords and inputs or if you have a
secure input with a default value that
might not be allowed uh or even
outputting a secure value that you know
that'll fail that sort of best practice
step here for you then you know we can
can go and validate the template compare
the sort of resource that we're trying
to deploy with uh into a resource Group
and the magic is sort of down here
instead of uh create we're using the
validate keyword on that same template
so they'll just do like name checks and
see if it all complies and will be uh
good to go then after that we apply
another one called what if so this is
where actually we want to see what
changes are we going to be applying to
our existing resources in if you run
this step and sort of like the
terraform plan I think when it shows you
what you're going to do what's going to
change if you run this deployment so
this is the equivalent for uh Azure armm
and here's just a step for deploying the
application I'll skip that part and then
the final one here is to deploy the
actual infrastructure so it's just a
little bit more complicated than the
other ones because I'm actually doing it
all by hand not reusing some of the
available keup actions but yeah just for
demonstration purposes that you can
actually do it all with the CLI and
output some of those values from the
template um the magic here is just that
that sort of D- query properties.
outputs so I want to get the outputs
from the template and write them to
GitHub um my actions or so my my job so
I can reuse that later in further down
in the workflow think which is down here
we can ignore the problems that we had
there it's a hard with this
um
here so here I'm reusing some of the
outputs from the template in the step
where I'm actually uploading the
function app to a storage account with
the run from package setting enabled so
yeah let's have a look and see oh we
have an error here deploying our
application conflicting error of Vault
the same oh somehow I have a key volt
with the same name somewhere else well
that's that's okay we can move on from
that we'll get back to a different
example so cool bicep uh yeah we can
definitely go and write the templates
you know create a workflow with kidub
actions here's some of the basic
commands uh sorry first one is bicep
build and then we can have a deploy
group validate to make sure all naming
and resource types are correct uh and
then run a wi if to see we can actually
use the wi if step to to go hey uh
there's a manual check or approval check
here on this step to see are we changing
the right resources you someone else can
uh check that PR for us and say oh
you're you're dropping database you know
please explain you know we don't want
that to happen um so that's what what if
is really good for and just to see any
sort of configuration changes all that
so you can bit of a subjective check
there to make sure what's going out is
actually what you want to happen rather
than after the fact go oh configuration
is missing well we lost the database uh
that will definitely make it easier for
us to to spot it then also just the
final one just to deploy the actual
template as deployment group create with
all the parameters cool and if we open
up our GitHub workflow and you check the
the actions tab this is what we would
see so I created the dependencies there
initially to to build up and to check
for best practices and validate the
resources and after that run the wi if
deploy the application sorry deploy the
infrastructure first and then the
application all green picks exactly what
you want to see all the
time cool now the next awesome feature I
want to talk about is private Registries
and what they let us do is to um in our
F in our bicep files we can actually
reuse other bicep files because each
bicep file essentially is a module and
then these modules can go into a
registry and what we can do with that is
just if we have a complicated
application or a set of resources um
then then we can reuse them much easier
so we can Capt it all and we can
actually use tagging uh to do our
versioning just like uh asure container
registry you know used to putting our
container images in there it's just
using the the open container image
format so we can actually store anything
in ACR that we want and in this case why
not store bicep module files in there
which is pretty cool um so I'll jump
back to the demos there real quick and
uh we'll see here I have a registry
file I did actually go and create a a
container registry already with a biet
file and I'll quickly show you that that
registry and just call it very
appropriately Bice Flex registry go in
there I can go and look at my
repositories and we can see I've already
uploaded a whole bunch of modules so
I've got a full stack app I've got a
keyo um database storage another storage
and a web app so for instance if I open
up the the web app one I've got
different tags different versions of
that web app cool but why is that so
useful um I go back to the code real
quick and I'll go to this fullstack web
app and a whole bunch of inputs at the
start but we can move over and see here
I'm creating an application by
reusing the modules that are stored in
the container registry using this
special notation so uh BR that's sort of
the the schema defining for um the ACR
what we want to use we specify the asual
actual repository itself so bison flex.
a. and then the path towards that module
that we want with the version tag which
is cool so in this case I'm going to
specify version 1.2 but what's really
cool as well is that if we take these uh
properties out or if we start from
scratch we actually get intelligence as
well even though it's stored back in a
registry in Asia uh it actually restores
that that module onto my local machine
the local case and and interprets that
just as if it was a file on my local
machine actually is and then we get the
intelligence which is so cool uh really
nice so we can have as a team for
instance doing a lot of cloud adoption
framework work have all our bicep
modules stored in a registry and then we
can pick and choose uh which modules we
need and orchestrate a deployment to a
uh a subscription will attendant with
that super easy and I've gone here I'm
just referencing modules for all the
different things I want in this
application cool now uh with that demo
of the one that failed before pretty
much have the same thing um but I want
to deploy it from the
registry what's different here is
nothing it's exactly the same way to
deploy it is just that how it references
the application sorry references the
modules is what's different
so I'll let that run and uh it's going
to do the same thing and it might come
back to it a little bit later but that's
it so we can actually reuse all of our
modules and pick and choose them apply
our best practices and and yeah it's a
whole lot easier you don't have to have
everything on one machine to get the job
done
right cool so just an overview like if
you do want to have a proper workflow
with the Registries it's very similar to
how you would do it with containers but
you know you have the dev team do some
work uh commit the work into the git
repository want to run that validation
and linting rules that we had seen
earlier but more importantly is also if
I want to store a whole bunch of
resources or templates in the registry I
want to make sure that they really
really work so you want to run a type of
smoke test on them now this is where
things vary a lot you every service or
every resource going to have to test
differently you have to come up with a
whole bunch of uh different ways of of
of implementing these so if it's a web
app you might want to use something like
k6 to do a quick load test or spoke test
on that if it's a database or storage
account uh if you've enabled U or
disabled Public Access try and access
the application Al try and access that
storage account and see if it works or
not uh and then you know pass or fail
the test cool and then you can go and
merge the code and publish it to your
Azure container registry nice and simple
but the really hard bit in here it will
be the smoke testing bit so um hopefully
now that the the sort of ACR and private
Registries is a is a a real thing we're
going to see some cool examples of how
we're going to do some real test driven
development with arm templates or bicep
templates so definitely looking forward
to that and just a way to to publish our
templates to the ACR I forgot to show
you this in the demo we just run the
bicep publish module file name and then
the target container registry with a
version tag so you can upload those
templates or modules quite easily
cool uh pros and cons let's see there
might be a
few uh Pro for me there's no State
Management in bicep um there's uh
definitely a problem with that that sort
of live state that we get to use is not
very accurate so sometimes it gives you
a couple of weird results but I'm sure
that's going to get better and better
over time we have a simpler programming
syntax compared to the old Json uh
format uh there's a visualizer in vs
code but it doesn't really work that
well when we try and visualize a um I'm
going to try this one here with web app
click this little icon here and it
should work it out for us here we go and
we can see all the resources that we're
trying to provision but if we try and do
that with one that is using a whole lot
of modules let me just clean this up
make some more room
we only see modules it's it's not really
giving us the full architecture of the
application and all the relationship
relationships between the resources yeah
maybe one day this will work a little
bit better where it sort of expands out
a bit nicer but still that's okay it is
a con but it's not that bad we can
change our scoping so we can have one
templat that can work at all different
levels of azure a big thing that's
missing the active choice is not to
bring userdefined functions from arm
templates into biceps it's one thing
they didn't bring over
but if you listen to the reasoning it
actually makes a lot of sense you want
to not have some really crazy Dynamic
logic in there you want things to be
very declarative so that's probably why
they decided to to drop that uh
modularity it's great we got modules
it's easy to reuse code uh makes a whole
lot of sense and reduces your workload a
lot um there's no resource provider ales
oh yeah I was going to get to this so
those long resource provider names like
this one here yeah this is still not
very pretty well hopefully one day they
can make this look a little bit nicer
but uh we live it for now but I think
that's one thing that can definitely be
improved validation awesome so we can
make sure whatever we deploy should work
pretty much every time but not always uh
parameter files if you want to have a
parameter file that inputs into a bicep
file it's still adjacent format which is
unfortunate we have Registries really
cool feature and hopefully in next few
days there'll get a public registry
provided by Microsoft but yeah wait and
see what that's going to look like
trying to get keys and configuration or
connection strings from resources in a
bicep file is a little bit ugly it's not
as easy as you'd expect but uh it's no
different to doing it in the arm
template the Json templates but again I
wish it was a little bit nicer uh to to
to get that done now Microsoft says this
is totally supported day Zero support so
anything you can do with the arm Json
templates you can do with biceps so all
the stuff that was announced recently at
ignite we you can actually deploy them
with bicep straight away we don't have
to wait for terraform or plumi or
whoever to build in support to uh to
provide those resources which is quite
quite nice uh one dir thing is that it's
hard to discover modules that are in a
repository so um hopefully you know it's
early days they will improve that over
time as well so you have to actually
know what's in that container registry
to be able to reference it and actually
know what it does there's nothing that
lets you dig into it and see what's
actually in there yet um and the cool
thing is you can actually take your old
old um Json templates and convert them
into bicep which is really nice it's a
cool tool for that it's just uh a
decompile give it a file name and it
does a conversion for you which is
really nice here's some useful links I'm
going to put all my code all the slides
up on my GitHub uh repository you can
capture that link and I'll put it in the
comments as well here's a whole bunch of
links to Azure bicep on GitHub Microsoft
learn uh the architecture Center which
you can go and find some really cool
template the architecture to deploy and
some of them are in bicep already um and
there's also the bicep playground which
you can sort of use to turn your bicep
templates into arm or arm into bicep and
it's just a nice little tool to play
around
with so just to sum everything up uh
Kiss by Design so Bice I think is still
very simple it's much easier to use than
arm Json um it definitely has a very
nice Improvement in the programming
syntax and saving a lot of time you I'm
a big fan of this one less keystrokes
it's much better
uh and reg Registries are awesome I'm
going to definitely use a lot of this
and uh you know there's more coming
because we're not even at version one of
B yet and now infrastructure's code is
fun again yay thank you very much
everybody thank you William that was
excellent uh well done um I just have a
couple of quick questions um yes sir we
have a few minutes so the first question
uh is from Ryan on YouTube and I'm just
going to expand it a bit because it's
the host's prerogative um the question
was can you use net libraries from bicep
um but I guess to expand that a bit is
there a sort of a library story behind
Bice with bicep other than the modules
you've talked about is there any you
know libraries to use it or to you know
that's a great question I I think the
answer is probably going to be no
because they don't have the the user
defined functions feature yeah uh I
think because they want to limit it to
be very declarative and not move towards
that sort of uh imperative programming
style model right um I think the answer
is going to be no but you know Happ
would be wrong uh it' be hard for me to
see what benefit there is really but it
might actually violate that kiss
principle that I mentioned but yeah we
wait and see could they could do
anything right well that's right I mean
that actually brings me on to the next
question I guess you said it's you know
it's not at 1.0 yet uh and we're waiting
to see in some respects so I guess the
the big question the $64 million
question would you use it in production
is it is it ready or are we still
waiting I'm using it yes for sure
Microsoft is supporting it already so
since version point4 I think umol yeah
so I'm using it already it works great
no complaints look the things that are
missing is only maybe the programming
experience but in terms of capabilities
all that's working it's beautiful okay
and so then the next s the final I guess
money question uh if I'm uh I'm at work
and I've got a bunch of arm templates
I've written and I've invested lots of
hours in uh how do I essentially sell
this rewrite even though I know you said
I can
Dey how much quicker is everything going
to get if I use bicep versus Arm
templates going forward is it worth
conversion the conversion may not be
absolutely necessary because I think the
Big Time Saver is from The authoring
Experience right so if you have a bunch
of an plates that work and they don't
need change then don't don't bother
changing it I guess if you do need to go
back and make some changes the
conversion should be fairly
straightforward you may have to do some
clean up a couple of things I mean it's
not always perfect but when you have a
reason to do it try it out it's it's a
good experience in my opinion so far so
yeah really happy with that but if you
don't need to don't worry it's not going
to change the speed things get deployed
at all okay that's good to know and I
guess because it is arm under the covers
right so arms not going anywh y okay
correct yes cool well thank you very
much uh we thank you we now get this
weird transition where William
transitions from being a speaker to a
host because he's hanging around and
we're very Carey to have you but uh we
are we're gonna do I have to go away now
I can't remember we have to see the r i
everything turned off so I don't know
what's happening cool I'll stay here and
we're going to bring in L and you and I
both get a bit of a surprise because I
have no idea where L is but he has
threatened to not be his desk so uh I
guess we'll just wait and find out
together um lar for those of you who
don't know is somewhat in the country
hey it's roaming lar
hello I'm not in my desk that's right
I'm I'm not at my desk because I thought
we needed a bit of a change and it's
such a lovely day outside that I thought
we'd go and say hello to these girls so
just something that's not Tech actually
I'm going to make a tech Rel
but see if they come over there we go
this is not a recording right this is
live this is live I'm just walking here
um this is very live hello girls well we
practice it very
well is this your neighbors or is this
your property well it's my padic but
they're actually a neighbor's llamas and
they usually come
over come on here we go look at them all
yeah they all got up because they know
see I've got M moms here num Noms MH so
come on
girls but it's not all just llamas well
it is all llamas isn't it but I think we
can probably make a tech connection here
really come on is electric fence I was
gonna say is an electric fence is that
how we're gonna do it it is actually but
it's not on because llamas are easy they
don't they don't gos a number and give
you a shock is that how this
works well it could no let's not do that
um so here they all are that's the
that's the girls that's the herd say
hello girls they're like what
um they don't want to eat today there we
go they're just very curious animals but
I thought I'd just make a tech
connection to this because they're all
here um I didn't int sorry this one has
grass on its ear it looks ridiculous um
I didn't I didn't intend to to have
llamas like I'm a nerd right I'm not a
farmer I I work in software development
training now hello but everybody loves
llamas like who doesn't love llamas so
what happened was that I I we got the
land and the neighbor asked hey can I
put my llamas in went yeah sure whatever
and it just kind of took off because
everybody Lo loves llamas so I thought I
needed to learn some more about Azure
and um I set up this project that I I
call a lamama cam and it was a way for
me not only to share llamas with the
world but I actually have a whole lot of
knowledge about aure Media Services now
because I stream everything through well
aure media servic the Llama Camp stuff
so it's like just another and I usually
use this as an example of hey if if you
don't if you want to learn a technology
there's nothing better than finding a
project that is sort of either makes you
laugh or or makes you curious or share
something with the world right so these
guys I mean the girls don't know they're
on the internet but I don't think they
care absolutely having having some kind
of side project to force you to learn
something or or work on something or
even committing to do a conference talk
about a subject you don't know about not
that it's a real thing
it's a real thing conference driven
development there we go for those
looking yeah that's very true for those
people that don't know it's uh it's very
very common to write the abstract and
then forget about it and then go oh
there's two weeks to have to do the
conference so yeah um that's not unusual
so any I'll share them do you get a lot
of llama drama given that you're not a
farmer oh man absolutely I'm the Lama
drama Farm I just had to get that out
I've been think about
so yeah they're very cool so these are
very easy um there's another herd up the
back but um yeah this and it's actually
not far because my office is right there
there we go in the water tank just yep
that's it uh there this gambling is hard
but yeah that's so I just sit in there
before so I just walked out here and
they're right here so um I think I
almost saw the Windows XP heel behind
you on that is the one um yeah it's uh
it's actually up there uh yeah it's a
bit it's behind the trees but yeah there
is it looks a bit like Windows XP yeah
that's right if I had known I'd have
taken my uh camera outside and shown you
uh I don't know my my trying to grow
grass yeah subbs that's
it so but thank you styling this is all
possible right yeah it's been working
well yeah so I'm just going to change my
AR understand it's supposed to work
because don't they constantly move
around the come to my talk at 4:00 and
I'll tell you well where else would
I this smooth yep so um now I can't see
the YouTube comments while I'm here but
if you got questions about llamas go for
it I usually get a few
questions um no they don't sped yeah so
far no questions on llamas but uh people
just like what is going on why is this
guy showing llamas there's a few few
puns oh they're all looking at you now
or looking at us I guess very expected
what are
four what are they for what are they you
know do do you do you shear them and
make jumpers well not you but the
neighbors do you shear them make so so
he doesn't do much with this group here
H there's no male in here there's a male
in the other padic so we keep getting
new llamas which occasionally show up on
llama cam um but you know apparently the
first crop of wool is the best wool you
can do I don't know I don't know
anything about llamas um as such sorry
about llama farming llama facts go for
it
um so and occasionally the there would
be males that jump out and apparently
they become lunch for Lions I've been
told so right that's the the less less
glamorous area or yeah yeah just over
the hill yeah there's a zoo it's a zoo
not far away L
line yeah what's good this is this is
good you know the petting zoo in the
conference is a it's been a trend in the
last few years so I'm glad that we could
uh we could do this virtually as well
yeah for sure it it's it's kind of
interesting so I have it's it's lam.com
that if you want to go and have a look I
think actually it yeah it turns off in
about 25 minutes uh because reasons but
um I want to use it well because I get
yeah I get I get a like a motion
notification every time there's llama in
front of it in my on my like internal
system thing and I want to use that so
that I can me you know promote it or say
push notifications or whatever and then
someone said well why don't you uh have
a thing so when you donate a dollar on
whatever llamas oror or something it
feeds them like oh yeah but that's a lot
harder because there's there's 12 acres
of padic so if there's no llamas a lot
of the time people go oh that's boring
yeah yeah we'll see that's a lot of eth
to no no I have I have about 35 Acres
covered in Wi-Fi it'll be fine
cool I have I barely have four bedrooms
covered in
wifi yeah yeah well lockdowns and stuff
what else do you do when you're stuck on
a farm so and a nerd I don't want to do
farming no
no well speaking
of well I was just going to tell
everybody to go and uh register for the
competition if they haven't already
expo. sydney.com
all right I'll join you in just a sec
all right
thank you coming back heading back
inside
I yeah I think we've got a the quiz
coming up four minutes to
kill uh quiz is a bit later I think
isn't that that's at uh
3:45 oh yeah all right cool what have we
got next oh yes I see I just got the the
the schedule back up uh so wait for the
we to synchronize everything that's
right and then we've got uh Brooke our
next speaker but uh yeah cool so I'm
just looking at the comments there
someone asked if there was a way to
convert arm to bicep yes um just a
command Matt Wix posted the the answer
there a bicep decompile and then the
file name you can also use the bicep
playground website to to do that for you
as well um that's Co how good the how
good's the decompilation like in terms
of you know does it make codes that you
would have written or is it a bit you
know complicated it's good it's quite
good yeah cuz I think that that the
scope of how they want you to do things
is is fairly uh
straightforward you know you can't do
too many crazy things so then when it
decompile something from arm template
it'll be pretty useable like there are
sometimes just naming and a couple of
links that you have to change but for
most part it's it's totally usable as is
yeah that's pretty good welcome back
can Li hear us I don't know oh he
playing sorry there was a slight freeze
and
away it's always good to prove that
these things are real but yeah if this
was pre-recorded surely we would have
pre-recorded some better
material yeah but exactly right so no
it's um oh I can see the Windows XP last
Tim saying that's very true I'll take a
picture lat and put on Twitter how about
that I think it's day for it I don't
know I assume it was producer Landon who
was changing your name throughout that
whole segment but it was a very very
good job uh so there's there's a team of
people behind the scenes trying to make
fun of L it's going well that's my job
yeah yeah it's um uh what do we got we
got five minutes all right so I'm going
to look at ah okay there's no questions
on YouTube which means we can talk about
what we want hey now I had a little
because there was a question earli on
YouTube so humor we here lovely people
about how the sausage is made as in how
do we make all this happen right because
when you see a live stream you know you
sort of go oh that's nice and it's it's
today's running really well I haven't
been on mute once even you know but so
the so I thought I'll just give an
insight into how all of this works um
because there's quite a lot of people
involved to make this look as good as it
does
um so first of all we have streamyard
streamyard is a web product so you go to
streamyard tocom and it's a way that you
can share a single link with a presenter
they click on it and they're in your you
know stream back Channel essentially so
there's a broadcast studio I think they
call it broadcast studio yep yep that'll
do so there's a producer for streamyard
that can see everybody so they can see
all the people that are currently logged
in they can see all the assets so that's
all the overlays and all the videos to
show up the sponsor videos and all this
and they click all the right buttons at
the right time super important so
there's two of those two producers um
there's someone so obviously we're here
talking to you um but then there's also
um you know making sure that speakers
are there to start when when we're ready
and we talk here in like you know five
minutes Brooke's G to be on for example
um we got to make sure oh and no I
didn't drop out oh it's bit jerky jery
getting choppy so I don't know if I'm oh
choppy choppy anyway I I blame Elon um
there's also like a whole run sheet so
we know exactly what's happening at all
times who's doing what that's really
important because otherwise we step on
each other's Toes or someone doesn't
show up whatever um then there's one
person that sort of ties everything
together for this live stream remember
there's three other rooms as well but
for the live stream um to make sure that
you know all the videos are doing
looking good and that the you know we
get we show the sponsor videos enough
times and we note all the Prize winners
and that the the slider thing is working
there's all those things
um and of course there's the whole NDC
team because the three of us and Aaron
don't work for NDC right we do this
because we love it um so there's a whole
NDC team that you haven't seen that sits
behind the scenes and do all the other
things as well um so it's a big
operation um there's a lot to it it is
and you bring up a very good point L
about the sponsors because uh we
wouldn't be able to do this without them
uh in some extent so uh I think we
should probably let them have a few
minutes of time sounds
[Music]
good we don't want to sell technology
for the sake of just selling technology
it needs to solve a business problem
there's a number of different ways in
which you can technically create a
solution make something work but with
the wrong attitude with the wrong
mindset um technology will not solve the
problem the technology kind of happens
in the background but it really is about
attitude and aptitude the most important
thing in bringing purpose to technology
is the people it comes down to
communication and relationship building
and having that mutual respect with your
customer if we as a team uh as
individuals are Building Solutions
that's moving people forward that's
helping uh make people's lives better
bringing purpose to humanity through
technology that really drives home to my
heart through personal experiences puts
a smile in your face to be able to put a
smile on your customer's face that makes
me feel really proud uh not just of my
team but also proud of of our
[Music]
company
I love running this company I love
running it because uh of the people I
deal with there such a great team of
people from a career perspective it's
the best move I ever did being a great
consultant which we are this is is half
half between technical skills and
communication it's giv me the
opportunity to work with lots of
different types of technology and
explore some stuff that I maybe only
dabbled in at University or before ssw
is a company that makes enterprise
software Solutions uh and that's what we
do we build software for clients uh on
demand we build bespoke Solutions using
the latest technology and the latest
best practices I've been involved in the
development of some mining software
being involved in the development of
software for a legal firm and everything
in between there even in just under 2
years I've been working across so many
different
projects it's just a really great place
to come into and I always look forward
to coming to
work are you an engineer looking to
impact millions of Australians we're
looking for big thinkers problem solvers
and challenge Seekers to help us
engineer the future of banking combank
engineering do you have what it takes
search engineering at
combank
hello everybody we're back so uh our
next speaker is Brooke Jameson and uh I
think Brooke is online so if we can
bring Brooke into the view hi Brooke how
you doing hi a tough act to follow with
Al llas but I'll do my
best oh look I I just had a read of the
the talk abstract and uh the title is uh
how to become a Tech conference speaker
and the abstract is very inspirational I
think uh I wish I probably would have
had the advice that you're going to give
you know a few years ago when I started
getting into this uh it seems really
cool uh I think we're going to have a
lot of takeaways from this today um and
but Brooke where where are you based in
in Australia you in Melbourne Brisbane
Sydney I'm in Brisbane currently in this
gray box which does not symbolize
Brisbane at all but yes up in Queensland
it looks more like Melbourne gray
weather yeah no I'm not wearing all
black that's how you can tell
cool Brook I'm looking forward to this
talk so you know the show is all yours
perfect um I'll just swap over to my
slide tab cool great and we'll get
started um so like I said earlier in the
chat as well please leave comments um
and questions along the way that I will
get to at the end um and first of all I
would just like some take some time to
acknowledge the traditional owners of
the land I'm broadcasting from today I
don't normally show this map but I
wasn't sure how International the
audience would be today so this is map
of different abinal language groups
across Australia so the language groups
and the cultural Clan groups are a
little bit different but this at least
shows you more about what's going on so
um I'd like to acknowledge the yera and
tourable people who are the traditional
owners of the land that I'm broadcasting
from today and as you can see here I put
a little circle around Brisbane but you
can really see how rich this Heritage is
in Australia and if this isn't something
that you know about definitely take some
time to look into it because there's
such a rich history here and I think
that's something that Australia really
could and should share more with the
world oh and I've lost my tab but we're
back cool I'm so how to become a Tech
conference speaker and so what I'll do
today is I'll talk through a little bit
more about why I'm doing this talk and
then at the end just smash through with
actionable things that you can actually
take away from this but I wanted to
start to talk about really what has led
to all of this so this first picture is
me probably about five years ago um I
would I had such bad anxiety that I
tried to go to events I would force
myself to still get ready because that
was in my wheelhouse and I would always
force myself to get public transport to
The Venue um but then I would usually
just have a panic attack at or near the
door and then immediately go home and I
did this for a while honestly I kept
forcing myself to go because I knew I
did want to get better at this but it
was a journey um so it led to this
second pH phase which is something I'll
call the fake it till you make it phase
I just kept trying to power through I
would stay in the venue I'd finally get
into the venue fantastic um stay for a
few minutes and talk to people and then
leave early and I just kept doing this
all the time um another good point is
that all of this I was doing on my own
as well I think if I had waited to go
with a friend I still would never have
gone to an event of any kind yet so
really just faking it till I made it and
trying to push through as best I
could I finally started to make some
friends at this stage brisbane's
fantastic because there is a really
vibrant Tech and startup Community here
and everyone's really excited to meet
everyone else so once I started to see
some familiar faces and make some
friends this whole process got a lot
easier and I would be so excited to see
people that I hadn't seen in a while at
events and it just started to get a
little less
daunting this stage is where I started
plotting a little bit more so I would
find myself I really loved going to
panels um just because I feel like that
was the most engaging for me and then I
could always in the back of my mind
think about things that I would like to
say on that panel if I was asked one of
the questions or I would even if I was
super Brave that day start asking
questions at the end of panels really
just starting to go through working bit
by bit the way up um and the final stage
I have sunglasses on at this point cool
obviously um and this is where I started
speaking at conferences so I worked my
way up and then started speaking at
speaking at really small virtual events
um and then I've done
really large in-person conferences as
well so really just approaching this
from an incremental
standpoint um and this is really what I
wanted to talk about today because when
I was down in stage one um I kept seeing
people posting advice on how to become a
speaker but they were all really
extroverted and outgoing and
neurotypical and I just found that I
couldn't resonate with it at all and it
wasn't they'd never had to try so they
didn't really have any strategies to
make things easier because it came so
naturally to them so most of this talk
is just me showing you that it is
possible to make iterative improvements
and I'll step through what lots of those
improvements and lessons are that I've
learned along the way so that you can
learn from my mistakes so it's not as
bad for you um and I'm really hopeful
that at the end of this you'll be able
to start applying for some conferences
or start applying for some meetups
locally in your community so that you
can work your way up and then just put
all of the pieces into place so that you
can start making this for
yourself because the whole thing is to
work out why you actually want to talk
some people want to talk at a conference
because they want to be known as the
really smart person or they want to be
the most authoritative topic or they
want to really be the one that owns a
specific programming language or
something like that or they just want an
ego boost I didn't want any of that so
until I really worked out why I wanted
to speak at conferences um I just really
couldn't force myself to make those
extra leaps so working at the start
about why I wanted to do that was a
really key part for me um and this is
pretty much that so this is a picture of
my house very personal to share um this
is an art I made for myself you can tell
I made it because there's tensil glue to
it and I don't
think you could buy it like that but um
be who you needed when you were younger
is really my core value my motto that I
live by I think the world and especially
Tech would be a much better place if
more people lived by this so if you're
writing documentation it for the U
developer 5 years ago 10 years ago
something that would have really helped
you to understand those Concepts and if
you're living in that aspect it really
helps and I brought this into conference
speaking as well because when I was at
going through those stages when I start
to really think about when I decided I
could and should start speaking at
conferences there's a few speakers that
stood out to me and I saw them on panels
or I saw them doing a keynote and I just
thought this is something that I could
do I could be getting through this um
and it wasn't until I'd seen one or two
people that really did change the course
of my life so that's really what I go
into speaking with um every time I talk
I just want one person in the audience
to think that they could also be a
conference speaker I'm not trying to be
the most knowledgeable or anything like
that it's just more about how can I open
more doors for more people and that's
really what drives me and that helps me
so much because it makes me less nervous
um it's helped me so much with imposter
syndrome because I'm just making sure
the goal posts that I'm actually going
for are meaningful to me but also
attainable which is really good so this
might not be what you want to go into
speaking for this is just from me but I
would say find out what it is
specifically for you so work out why you
actually want to talk at a conference
and then use that to guide you along the
process because that will help you to
start talking at conferences but it will
also help you to understand what you
should talk about or which specific
conferences you should really chase
after if you can get to the core of why
you want to talk in the first place um
and just so as well so I'll go through a
little bit about me now because this
will help you to understand some of the
conferences that I've spoken at um so
the first this is how I represent my
resume which is a bit weird but um the
first part of the set diagram is my math
background so I studied pure maths at
University I've also gone into to study
data engineering I now work at blackbook
which is an AI machine learning
Consulting fund um so that's a really
big part of everything that I do this
really ous technical background um but
then on top of that bringing in Creative
problem solving I've always been someone
who's solving problems or looking at
things from different directions so
that's a big part of everything that I
do as well um I've also worked as a user
experience manager for a global prop
Tech firm and really bringing in all of
my design and marketing and Behavioral
Science knowledge applying that to
everything that is part of what I do as
well and the last part which is not a
skill that I ever wanted to have or
tried to have and this really does come
from a part of my life earlier that
we'll get to in just a little bit but
talking to people in the media because I
realized uh after my degree that there
was no point getting to a result if I
couldn't tell anyone about it so being
able to not only do the technical
aspects at the start but then be able to
Pro problem solve using those technical
tools and then do that in a user Centric
way and then talk to people that's
really where I fit into all of this um
and I think it's important to go through
a diagram like this not just to tell you
about me but also because I think
everyone should do this drawing a
diagram like this for yourself or a way
that helps you to understand your sort
of pillars of information will really
help you to then dissect what sort of
conferences you could or should speak at
um you can look at the same problem
through different lenses then because if
I was doing I could do a talk about
artificial intelligence at a user
experience conference or at a design
conference or through a PR lens or
something like that just being able to
understand your different f assets of
knowledge and really unpack them in this
way will help you to be more strategic
about what conferences you can actually
make available to yourself um so we'll
get started now with the other parts of
it so more practical
tips and this is my previous life so
what do fashion models and Tech speakers
have in common the part I left out of my
diagram is that I modeled in Australia
and overseas uh during and after
University um once again not something I
ever set out to do it's just a very good
job to have during University um but
there's it wasn't until I actually
started doing conference speaking that I
realized how similar so many aspects of
conference speaking are to modeling and
I think a really core part of this at
the end of the day is in neither field
no one tells you how to do it um no
one's upfront about this is what you
should actually do or this is a pathway
that actually works because everyone
wants to sort of Gat keep other people
out of it so it keeps more jobs for them
um and I just have never had an interest
in that I have no interest in that so I
really want to break that down to make
it more attainable for other
people and so I went through some
transferable skills from my past life um
and the first and key point is that a
bad head shot will haunt you um when you
have you have to send a headshot with
every single speak speaker application
and every time the graphic design teams
of that conference will go to town with
that headshot so I would recommend I
still hate having my photo taken um I
it's a chore I don't like it but being
really deliberate about making sure you
have a nice photo that you don't mind
being on every single website until the
end of time is going to pay dividends
long term um and make sure it's
something that does actually look like
you in person and something that really
reflects what you're trying to achieve
with your speaking and everything like
that I know it's uncomfortable most
aspects of preparing for speaking are
uncomfortable but it's just one of the
key things that will really help you to
look more legitimate as a speaker and
book more established things as well as
doing that in a way that
ties in with everything else you're
actually trying to achieve so I know
it's uncomfortable just power
through and this idea of being able to
show yourself the way that you want to
be seen um you really have to be
strategic about your brand and think
about what is my speaker Persona if you
want to call it a Persona or something
like that to make sure that how that
actually ties in with everything else um
some people when they do speaking they
only speak from their company point of
view so they only ever talk about the
company that they work for through that
lens I have never really done that um
but it's more about everything that I do
directly ties into the work that I do
but it is still coming from Brook the
person not Brook the employee of the
company and you have to be really
strategic about how to do that in a
mindful way that's really respectful to
your company um but also will keep
things fine for you if you do end up
changing companies or jobs so that you
still have some sort of continuity there
and so to be strategic about it you have
to understand what your brand is so that
exercise with drawing sort of overlapped
circles can really help you to
understand where you sit at the
intersection of and that can help you to
then work out what you need to do but
the same thing with modeling is no one's
ever going to show you how to do this
stuff um it's just the good people that
rise to the top have done this so you
just have to find a way that's natural
for you to be able to do it and you have
to be really strategic from the absolute
start and this part as well is so
setting goals and work out how to
actually reach them speaking like
modeling is a huge pyramid so with
modeling you don't walk in and book the
cover of Vogue for your first job that's
not a thing so you end up doing you do
smaller they're called test shoots where
you don't get paid um and that's where
like a new photographer or maybe a
student photographer or something like
that upand cominging people will work
for free to everyone boosts their
portfolio um and the equivalency to that
in speaking is doing your local meetups
which maybe are in person in a room with
20 people and obviously they're not
going to pay you for that because people
aren't paying for tickets for that so
working out what are little things you
can do I would say at the bottom of the
pyramid for speaking as well is also
filming video content somewhere on the
internet just because that shows that
you can at least speak and it's a way
you can break out of that catch 22 of
how do you get experience um and then
you can move up to sort of mid-tier
conferences maybe start to do some
larger events that are ticketed and then
you can get up to doing more
international events and things like
that so you have to really plan
strategically how you're going to move
up through the pyramid but you can only
do that if you realize that it's a
pyramid on the start so modeling is the
exact same and the same thing in
modeling is no one ever tells you this
um no one really plans this out for you
you just really have to be in charge of
that so work out what your goals are and
then how you can reach those in a way
that aligns with your brand that you're
giving out and then what you would
actually like to bring to speaking as
well and as part of the pyramid
transitioning from free gigs to getting
getting paid is really hard it's the
same thing for modeling when you start
to get paid it's really weird um some
people just start booking really large
campaigns or they might do a type of
modeling that pays really well speaking
is the same there's different types of
speaking that pay different amounts um
and it really does change regionally as
well especially in Australia it's really
hard compared to America where lots of
things are paid um a few ways to get
around this number one is uh just as a
side note I've always donated my speaker
fees um because it's a nice thing to do
and because I would have to work a lot
harder to actually raise that money for
charity but also when I do International
work um I can just donate that money to
a women's shelter or a local queer
organization something like that that
will be near there so I'm not ever
having to do the double tax transfers
it's a lot um and then the other side of
getting donation money is that you can
you're making sure that people are still
valuing your time and not expecting you
to work for free but you can get through
those early stages of charging weird and
small amounts of money um that would be
sort of uncomfortable if you build for
them I guess it's weird to send if you
sent someone an invoice for like $40 or
something if you're just thinking about
an hourly rate um that's always
uncomfortable but doing those as tax
deductible donations to registered
Charities is a good way to sort of break
out of that Loop um and the other part
of getting paid for speaking especially
in Australia is especially in Tech you
can understand that even if you're not
getting paid by a conference to talk if
you think about the amount your salaried
as a job if you were getting a new job
would you get more money if you had done
speaking before um so work out how much
of an increase your salary would get
over the year as a result of the
speaking you're doing and then think
about that as payment for speaking um is
often a lot more sensible in terms of
how you can actually get extra money
from this and that also means you can do
a more varied range of talks that are
going to lead to the end goals you and
your employer would then also want so
just think about it more creatively
about how you can actually unlock this
and then think about it within the realm
of that pyramid as well and the thing
that people never understand about
modeling is that being on time will book
you more work than being really skinny
or pretty or something like that um
being on time really friendly I would
get repeat booking from that just
because I was super organized with
things um they always if still running a
business there still time is money being
on time and the same thing goes with
speaking um knowing being known as a
person who's really on time and up to
date with deadlines is going to be so
valuable long term because of reputation
really does stay with you so when you're
freaking out about thinking oh I'm not
good enough at this I'm not good enough
at that you can always be on time and
you can always be friendly and this
really will just carry with you and
think about little things like this you
can do that will set you apart from the
pack early on because it makes it so
much more
attainable and now please go with with
me for a brief self-help tangent that I
know will be uncomfortable but it's also
helpful so just stay with me through
this um but have you tried speaking to
the manager within when I'm talking
about mapping out your values and
mapping out your different facets of
knowledge and information it really is
important and I know it's deeply
uncomfortable I hate it I hated every
aspect of it but I wouldn't have been
able to make those incremental growth
step changes I guess if I wasn't really
actively trying towards with this um
I've worked so hard with different
medical professionals and mental health
professionals to get my anxiety and
neurodiversity to a point where I was
working with it not against it um and
that's really helped me to have success
in this field and no one ever talks
about this with regards to public
speaking um it is stressful it's
stressful for everyone but that doesn't
mean it's not a learnable skill so
approaching this with a self-development
mindset not to get too woooo but it will
actually help you along the way um and I
really would find out whatever this
actually means for you and this is what
will help you to be a better speaker
because if you only watch speaker
training of American men who are used
car salesmen teaching you how to do
sales speaking stuff I don't know maybe
that resonates with you but it doesn't
resonate with me at all and I never
found myself in that like I couldn't
resonate with it and I couldn't see how
I would actually apply it but getting to
know yourself your value and then you
can BR to a conference will help you so
much more to place yourself in strategic
speak roles that you're trying to get to
and would really help you to map that
out so it's worth it have you tried
speaking to the manager within yes I
found this on a surrealist Instagram
page um a big part of that as well is
being genuinely genuine I don't know
better way to phrase this but audiences
are smart they can tell when you're
hiding something they can tell when
you're putting on a
facade audiences are smart in that way
so your best bet is to be unashamedly
yourself people always will find it more
endearing if you make a mistake but
you're really just absolutely yourself
when you're doing it so being really
upfront and vulnerable and honest with
your audience will always go such a long
way even when it comes to maybe you're
worried about technical details of
things I always get very stressed about
if I'm doing what I feel like is a very
technical presentation just because it
never seems like it's it's just always
so much harder so work out what it
actually is to be genuine for yourself
so work out a speaking style that works
for you specifically um if you're really
introverted find a way to work with that
don't try to fight that just get to the
core of who you are allow yourself to be
yourself and then just power through
with that um people will tell you to try
and put on a mask or something but it's
just not worth it um and people will I
don't know I wouldn't like to go to a
conference talk that was like that so
instead think about the conference talks
that you really actually like to go to
and what did you notice about it and so
I don't know for me always it's when I
really feel like I have a genuine
connection to the speaker because I feel
like I know them a little bit better
after talking and that's what I always
look for in a conference when I'm
remembering back on the conference talks
that I really enjoyed going to so if
you're being yourself that always helps
so much as well and it will help you to
be more consistent you're not going to
be having to try to put on a consistent
brand if your consistent brand is just
you the whole time so be genuinely
genuine I wish I had a better way to sum
that point
up and so now we're going to get into
the more actionable tips I guess um and
so much of this section which broadly
I'll call work smarter not harder is
because I just I don't like a lot of
these tasks so I've just worked out ways
to optimize them over time to really
help just make everything a little bit
easier and run more streamlined um so
many aspects of this come back to you
can get better at talking before you're
even talking at conferences by just
being more alert and aware when you do
go to events so maybe next time you're
even you haven't even bought tickets to
a conference and you're looking through
the agenda sheet of a conference be
alert and work out which talks do you
actually want to go to um are there talk
titles that really stick out to you or
there's some abstracts that you think
are really well written make note of
them somewhere keep them in a list I'm
sure if you're very on the ball you
could probably make a machine learning
model that reads in all the talk titles
you were interested in and just spits
out new talk titles for you I'm sure you
could do that um but otherwise just
think about it yourself keep a notes
file on your phone or something and just
be more aware when you are watching
people talk especially when in-person
events start again yeah fingers crossed
um being able to look at what's
something the speaker says or does that
really engages the audience or is there
something that they do that you notice a
body language change in the audience
just being more aware when you are sort
of
passively listening to conferences or
stuff that you would normally be doing
anyway will help you so much to get
speaking experience and confidence and
little tips and tricks without actually
having to get up and speak in front of
people um and that's across the board
one of the key tips and then I'll sort
of go through now different ways that
I've actually applied that but just be
more aware and think about what you're
doing so even if you really didn't like
some of my slides keep a note of that if
there were some aspects you really did
like keep a note of that and think about
that with the rest of the talks this
afternoon as well think about how you
would do it differently if you wanted to
or what parts you could incorporate
think about that so obviously don't copy
things word for word from any speaker
but think about how you can make it your
own be genuine in doing
that with the worst graphic design learn
some graphic design principles is a
really key tip um sometimes if you're
doing a presentation at work there might
be someone who's going to make all your
slides for you and make everything look
really nice for you it's unlikely you'll
have someone to do that for other
speaking things so learn some graphic
design principles work out how to make
things look nice that's a really easy
clean way you can keep reproducing that
work as well so you don't have to think
about it every time just learn some
basic principles and a lot of this
you'll start to get an eye for when you
just are more engaged when you're
looking at other things so if you really
like not this slide obviously but if
there was a different slide that you
really liked the composition of workout
why it was like that or if you liked the
design of something work out how you can
achieve that design um you can make slid
different graphic designs in each
PowerPoint is actually helpful you make
social media person if you just change
the slide size or things like figma if
that's something you use with your
different ad
work out what's going to actually work
for you and how you can get to those
principles over time will help you so
much as you move through and just keep
working
on what this is actually going to look
like obviously don't do this um and
we'll talk about more about how to make
it a little bit
easier and so the first step is to make
your own slide templates um this is
helpful because it makes it faster every
time you need to present at a conference
because you can then just you're not
thinking about what to put on every
slide you've sort of made a template
that you can use over time and this is
also really helpful when you start to
get a few different conference talks
because maybe there's some common slides
between and if you've Ed the same
template you can sort of drag slides
across and it will look really
consistent which is super helpful over
time so make your own template that you
can reproduce um and work out how to
make it your own so this is well when
you need to understand if you are going
to do it as you as an employee of your
company or you you as a person working
out where that actually fits in the
middle because if you're going to do
your first talk as you as a person um
you probably can't use your company's
slide template for that so just thinking
about where this actually does fit in
and I would say as well the easiest tip
to make it look like you know what
you're doing with graphic design is uh
well the first one is just to have
slides that aren't white people always
think you've tried harder when the
background is not white because then you
can't paste an image in it's got a white
border um it just looks like you've
tried harder um and then the other side
is just get good fonts and colors and
things like that but especially with
virtual conferences I don't know the
composition but my face is going to be
very small compared to the slide um and
sometimes if it's a zoom conference the
picture is tiny tiny in the bottom
corner so these are going to be full
screen it's going to be what most people
see so making sure it actually looks
nice will help you so much along the way
and the easiest way to make this even
more consistent is to make your own
style guide um a style guide if you have
worked with one especially if you're a
front end developer you would have seen
a style guide and it's just sort of
these are the brand colors these are the
fonts that we use this is how we do
things so it sort of just gives you a
recipe for all different types of media
and materials you can have it through
your social media posts even just making
sure that it is your style guide this
just makes things really reproducible
they're common in businesses because
there might be a huge marketing team and
there's different people designing
different pieces of material but they
all need to look the same so it's a way
of making it reproducible in that sense
but just make it EAS EAS on yourself and
make a style guide that's yours because
then as I was saying you can swap slides
between slideshows and things like that
and then it really helps you to have
people will know when they see your
slides because it looks a certain
way um so this is Spotify
designs I found it just online if you
start searching for brand guidelines you
can find them there's probably one at
your company you can start
with and the easiest thing is to just
start with the style guide that you've
used before and then work out how you
need to fill in the blank to actually
make it right so the IBM design language
is actually really really thorough
especially for accessibility reasons but
essentially they've got this is what our
logos look like these are the colors so
instead of thinking about just making
your sty guide colors about what the
actual colors that they've chosen how
many boxes do I need to fill in does
your maybe the Star Guide you're used to
working with has maybe four core colors
and then they've got a whole color set
for visualizations and accents and
things just think of that as a in the
Box technique and just replace all the
colors with colors that are for you and
it will give you more of an idea about
how to fix it and if you start with a
style guide that youve you've used
practically before it'll really help you
because then you already know your way
around it there's whole books on how to
make a style guide you don't need to go
that far just think about what's the
minimum pieces that you actually use
day-to-day if you're using a style guide
to develop something especially if
you're a front-end developer um and then
think about how you can actually make
that for yourself and then it will give
you a complete style guide at the end
without having to think too much and
then if you end up adding extra elements
and stuff to that you can just keep that
in a file over time so it grows with you
and can evolve with you as
well um if you don't know how to do font
pairing so a font pairing is when you
have a heading in one font and then the
text in another this website's really
helpful so you can scroll down and
they've got examples of different font
pairs um if you have a font pair it
looks like you know what design is um
because you can have that on every slide
and people know that a heading is a
heading and body textes that so you can
really sort of just work that out over
time um this one's good because it only
shows you Google fonts so it should work
if you're using Google Slides or other
web based things but just decide on a
font pairing and go with it add that
into your style guide this should help
you to make you look like you know
design um without actually having to be
an expert in this
field um and for colors so accessibility
is good because it helps you to make
sure that everyone can actually get the
information that you're trying to give
them which is the point of speaking at
the end of the day um but accessibility
on slides is really important as well if
you're ever speaking in real life
because lots of projectors are just
garbage so if you have accessible color
combination so for this contrast Checker
that I use this is a web aim one there's
so many out there but if it's passing
the wcag guidelines on the contrast
check so that's the difference in
contrast between the front and back
layers essentially of color that means
that you'll still be able to see it even
if the projector is terrible and the
window curtains are open on the windows
and it's just bad but you'll still be
able to see it because there's good
contrast so it's good practice to do for
accessibility but it will really give
you a lot of safeguards to avoid having
to tune a projector to a certain range
you'll always be able to see it um and
the same thing for color blindness if
you pick your initial color palette when
you're making your style guide with
these two things in mind it will be
accessible by Design because you can
already work out what color combinations
can I use can uh people with different
Vision see the differences between the
color um this David Mass logic site I
use all the time because it shows you
through different types of vision how
different colors are perceived so it's
really helpful for making the style
guide at the start um but in St I even
come into when I'm using user experience
design tools and things like that I
always come back to these so good
because it's accessible but even better
if you're just not sure what sort of
projector you're going to come into um
and on this note as well when you are
designing slides try them on lots of
different screen types so put it on your
phone with the brightness down and go
and stand in the sun somewhere and see
what it looks like or if you've got a
really dodgy projector in the office try
them on that or on an old screen a TV
screen that you can put them on see what
it looks like really large because if
you've never worked with a large
projector before you don't really have a
good sense of what text is too big so
you can run tests yourself to see like
at what point font can you see things or
is it too big or is it too small being
able to test those out over time is
really helpful and if you can then add
that into your sty guide um it just
makes everything so much more
reproducible no one ever talks about
this in practice but just do it think
about it a lot at the start and then you
can reuse the same thing every time same
thing goes with data visz um if you're
someone that does a lot of data
visualization in your speaking slides
and things like that work out what a
style guide is for your charting and
then just make that consistent because
then if you're reusing chart elements
cross presentations great you can just
keep going and it'll be so much easier
to skip between them or go back or other
things like that you'll just be able to
keep it really consistent over time even
if you're saying all of my charts will
always be in squares or something that
way if you swap a chart out for a
different one there's a square Gap in
the slide that you can then fill in so
all of this just comes back to making it
easy on yourself which is why I said
work smarter not harder I know it seems
like a lot of work to organize but
honestly anything you can do to really
reduce the amount you have to think
about things when you're getting ready
for a talk will just take so much
pressure off you um especially if you're
already really nervous about speaking
it's just one less thing to worry about
and one thing that you know will go
smoothly because you've already worked
it out so just think about little things
like this you can do to prepare um as
well if you're someone that's showing
code Snippets in your slides work out
what you're actually going to do to use
that and do it the same way every time
um there's different ways you can do
that maybe you just want to do a
screenshot of whatever code editor
you're using
I don't mind whatever you do end up
using just make sure you've got a plan
so that you can keep doing it every time
so that you're able to reproduce it so
that then if you have a last minute
change to one of the lines of code it's
a one-step process to update that not a
50 step got a screenshot this crop this
change the colors later just have it
streamlined so that there are last
minute changes you're being kind to
yourself in that
process um so now I'm going to step
through every single thing I did to get
this speaking spot at NDC Sydney um I
think yeah this is something that once
again no one ever talks about this
because they think that if they're going
to tell someone how to speak at a
conference there'll be more competition
for speaking at conferences which there
is but I also think there's enough
speaking spats going around for everyone
um and I think as well this is what
keeps early career people from speaking
or this is what keeps maybe diverse
audiences from speaking just because no
one's really stepped through how to do
it so I'll step through now everything I
did to prepare for this um and so the
NDC I found the call for speakers so I
did NDC last year as well um you can
watch my video on YouTube where I
physically choke in the middle of it
it's fantastic um but you can go through
and there's like different call for
speaker pages but I knew there was one
for NDC because I'd speak spoken at it
last year so I went to the NDC website
to find that page I think it was also
advertised quite heavily on Twitter so
it's a really good place to keep track
of call for speakers um then it takes
you to a website called session eyes
session eyes is one of the
key speaker platforms I've seen the
other one is called paper call that I've
seen used as well other times it's just
a Google form or other times you just
email someone but session eyes is the
biggest sort of centralized platform
I've seen um so it's a call for speakers
page that will have a little bit of
information so over here it says the
regular talks with 60 Minutes lightning
talks 15 minutes workshops to two days
um and then they give you some
suggestions for topics so so this is
where it's really important because NDC
it's so broad it's not a really
pinpointed conference so being able to
think what can you actually present um
and a way that I get around this is so
my previous keynote talk that I would do
quite heavily was called the persuasion
equation so that was how to make your
voice heard when people don't want to
listen to you so being able to be really
persuasive with data visualization um
and I chose that as a topic initially
because it was a topic that I could
really skew for whatever type of
conference I was going for so I was
going to be doing that at a business
conference I could make it super
business focused but I could do the same
conference and I have done it at
artificial intelligence or really
heavily focused data science conferences
as well so it's got this core sort of
80% that's really core material and then
the other 20% I would fine-tune that for
whatever conference I was speaking at
which is really helpful if you can think
about how making it easy for yourself if
you can think of a topic that is really
helpful but Broad um then you can tailor
that so something that's not too broad
that it means nothing but something that
you can really tailor and apply to other
things so when you're drawing your vend
diagram with the circles think about
something that you could tailor to each
of those specific pillars of the ven
diagram as you're going through so same
with how to become a Tech conference
speaker I can pretty much do this talk
at any different Tech conference um and
it's just a matter of working out how I
can actually tie that
in with what's going on so they will
give you some suggestions sometimes
they're really specific about what they
want sometimes they're really broad just
think about how you can then tailor
everything you're going to show into
something that will actually make sense
for this um and then don't miss the
closing date is a solid tip um and then
always assume that it's the day before
or the hour before because you never
know with time zone differences what
will actually occur um and on this page
as well if you scroll down normally on
the thing they'll tell you if travel is
covered or if they'll pay you or all
that other logistics information is
normally on the sessiz page when you
apply and then when you get accepted uh
this what is what it looks like in the
back end of session l so this is the
information down here that I gave them
so I chose a 16-minute session which is
what you're in I said this was
intermediate um added some tags that
come into the dropdown I hadn't
presented this at a conference before
it's my first one for this round of talk
um and the target audience and then
there's also a link to previous speaking
e details so that's sort of most of the
information that you need to give and
then what I'll do now is break down how
I actually made the description and
things like that no one tells you how to
write a session
description um and so this is when
you're coming into if you're looking
more accurately about what sessions you
really actually wanted to see at a
conference you can start to sort of get
a bank of these together and work out
how they're structured what's covered in
them and then what actually made that
interesting to you so why you wanted to
see it and what you actually wanted to
get out of it so this is the description
that I submitted for this talk that
you're in now which I don't think it was
changed usually for session I that
information gets published directly to
the website pretty much for btim so
always keep that in mind as well um make
sure anything you put here is fine to be
online um every time I read this I
forget that I mentioned having panic
attacks at my first conferences but um
think about what you can actually do so
this is how I step through what needs to
go in my session description so the
first thing I have a zingy opener
something with a story or Journey that
shows that this is personal to me and my
expertise specifically because this
whole thing you're not trying to sell
the conference organizers or the
audiences on the
idea just of having this session it's
that no we need to have this session and
I need to be the one presenting the
session so sort of two prong number one
they need to be interested in it but it
has to be why you are the best person to
be delivering that as well so that's
sort of my open eye also talk if there's
some social proof in there so saying
that like I started having panic attack
before my first conference in 2019 not a
good memory through to now doing about
20 of them as well as University guest
lectures lots of things like that so
it's talking more about the Journey of
how I put this into practice the second
term is what the talk actually is so
when I'm talking about be who you needed
when you were younger this is the talk I
wish I could have had earli in my career
great uh we're consistent um and then
stepping through what's actually in the
talk so breaking the Catch 22 of
becoming a speaker when it's talking
about how you can film videos and things
like that ahead of time little things
you can do to improve your brand making
your voice heard in the industry so this
is what the meat of the talk actually is
um being able to show that this is a
target audience is really helpful for
conference organizers because if you
think about when they're making a
conference schedule they've got
different sort of personas in mind for
who might attend that conference so they
need to make sure that there's something
for everyone in terms of the different
personas that we'll have at the
conference so it needs to be find a way
to communicate that it's Broad and will
be helpful to anyone that attends but
think about specifically the people who
think about someone personally in your
life that you would like to come to your
talk or that would find Value in it and
then talk about why they would so this
is Broad because it's from different
software and Tech backgrounds but it's
specifically about how you can apply it
yourself but it's also really helpful
any of this can be applied for stuff you
manage um because lots of the time in
performance reviews people will say they
might as a goal for the next year ahead
they might want to become a Tech
conference speaker or they might want to
do more content based things and there's
not really any good tools to be able to
guide them through that process so it's
one of the other things I'm hoping
people are going to be able to get out
of today in terms of being able to
Mentor their staff and Coach their staff
through this process because is really
daunting so thinking about who should
come to the talk why would they come to
your talk what will they get out of it
specifically around the people is good
for that third chunk um and the last
chunk is being able to show some add
different additional benefits or being
able to look at the problem in a
different way so talking that it is
interactive so we'll have lots of
questions at the end um could learn from
mate just shows that I will be honest
about how things didn't go well um and
then the career benefits that come from
speaking are really good people think
that it's just that people want to
become a speaker because they want to
get paid for that specific talk but as I
was saying especially in Australia so
much of it just comes back to increased
salary or being ahead in someone you
could be exactly the same in terms of
qualifications as another person um for
a job interview there down to two people
maybe but if one of you's done speaking
even if you want the same money you've
got the same experience everything if
one of you done speaking it's just a
really good way to show different value
to the organization because you just
stand out in a little bit different ways
so it is really helpful um and this is
how I always write my session
descriptions
um I don't know what the actual formula
is because I don't know if there is one
but this is what I do and it's worked
over time when I was starting out I
would apply really heavily and I would
actually split test these descriptions
um I had sort of two realm two versions
that I would do and I would send
different versions in and then I would
see how it goes and if one was doing
really well then I would start honing
that one in so think about how you can
test things out or have a go um the
other side is that as they're alluding
to before the program started you don't
actually have to have written your talk
when you send in a session description
so being able to you can send in session
descriptions and just see if they get
picked up at a conference or not um you
have to know that you do actually have
to deliver on that if you get booked to
do the conference but thinking about
what you can actually do
to maybe you could try to write a
session description but you're not
really sure will work out or not but you
can just have a go and then if it does
end up getting picked up at a conference
fantastic you can write the talk to go
along with it but just thinking you
don't have to write the entire talk
before you start applying for
conferences and don't let that stop you
or be a friction point in terms of
learning to talk at conferences because
you can just start applying with session
descriptions and then when you get
booked for one then you'll actually have
to do it but um it's a really good way
if you're just sort of testing the
waters to see what will happen you can
start applying over
time so now my speaker bio as well no
one tells you how to write this either
um and it's really uncomfortable if you
don't want to write your speaker bio
find someone um either that you with or
you work for or find someone in the
comments of this who you can trade with
or a friend and just write each other's
speaker buyer it's so much easier to be
really polite and kind to a friend that
is to write nice things about yourself
it's deeply uncomfortable but just work
out someone that you can trade with
because then at the end of it you'll
both have speaker bios fantastic and
it's easy this is sort of how I
structure mine um this is also what I
use as my LinkedIn bio just so it's
consistent the first thing I have a
tagline this is actually how I explain
my job to my parents because I'm head of
enablement for AI machine learning and
data that sounds very fake but it's a
very real job and I'm very much in
between the really rigorous maths data
data engineering Tech side with um user
experience and talking to people so this
ties back in with that V diagram I was
talking about but then it means that if
the at a inperson conference if they
need a way to talk about me and
introduce me really quickly fantastic
they've got it if they need a tagline
when they're writing copy to do social
media post from the conference they've
got information so just giving people
the right information in this section
because this is what you fill out in
session IED and once again they can and
will publish it anywhere so if you give
good information to the organization
that's going to be running the
conference they'll have everything they
need to write about you in a way that
makes sense um then you won't get stuck
with weird descriptions that don't make
sense for you and that will usually only
happen if you haven't given them enough
information to work with so I always
start with a really quick tagline this
first paragraph is sort of my actual bio
so what I tell to conferences if I apply
to them not through session as if I'm
just emailing them I always say if you
need a short bio just use this first
paragraph if you would like a long bio
use both and that's because often
especially on printed information maybe
they're only got a small space um or if
they want a really long section to fill
out a page that's why I give them both
so think about how you can structure
your bio to give them stuff to work with
um and that will once again just help
their marketing team to do a better job
of talking about you in a way that makes
sense so this is sort of my actual bio
it talks about my job where I work what
my degrees are in what I actually do
what I like at my job so overall they
specialize in researching and developing
technically robust solutions that help
non-data people harness the power of AI
That's what I do I talk to people who
don't understand data about how to get
the most out of it it's just a very long
way of saying that um and the second
part is get to know me so all of this
talks about all the other stuff that I
do outside of my actual job so all the
speaking lecturing things like that all
the work I do in Regional Queensland
with the queer Community this is good
because it shows that I'm a real person
um and it makes it a little bit more
personal but it also really filters out
if a conference sees this and they don't
want anything to do with me uh this will
surely filter them out straight away and
I wouldn't want to speak that either so
it's helpful on two fronts not only
getting to know me a little bit more but
absolutely filters out people that you
wouldn't want to be around anyway so
this is how my speaker bio um obviously
if you copy paste this for yourself it's
not going to work out so think about
more about what you actually do and how
you can best communicate that um because
your speak is Will audiences to see you
on the website but it's also this stuff
that will help you to get notice by
conference organizers if they're going
to be looking through bios to work out
if they're tossing up between two people
it gives you an opportunity to tell them
more about yourself um when you can't
introduce yourself in real life so
that's how I break this down once again
there's no guide book to to this this is
just what I've worked out over
time um so I also did some social media
posts um this is what my tweet looked
like I made this graphic myself I went
on the NDC website and found the color
schemes and thought I've made the
graphics myself if you don't this is why
you need to know how to do a little bit
of graphic design um the thing with
social media posts is almost always the
image size is just 12200 by 628 so if
you set a PowerPoint slide of that pixel
Dimension um you can just make the
graphic in PowerPoint and then export it
as an image and you don't need to have
canva figma or photoshop or any actual
design tools you can just crank that up
which is why it's really helpful if you
have either a sty guide for yourself or
something like that um just because you
can make it easier over time especially
if it's a photo of you you can work that
in um so I always just put I always make
sure I do these ahead of time this is
good for my LinkedIn because it helps
you to book other conferences but it
also keeps that conference happy knowing
that you've promoted them and I always
make my company logo really large on
this just to show that
I am I know especially if you need time
of work to be able to speak at
conferences or things like that um
always very thankful to especially
blackbook of being so supportive of me
so I'm always trying to make sure that
it's not just me touting myself as
Brooke but it's
specifically improving the brand of
blackbook AI my employer as well so it's
just keeping everyone happy and I always
link to where to get more info or
tickets or things like that this one I
actually made a Tik Tok which I don't
know if this video will
work but it's me and a cat that I was
babysitting talking about Tik Tok I
don't know find out whatever actually
works for you um and keep going with
that over time and just work out
different ways that you can talk about
what you're doing because then that will
help more people to find you and it will
really just help you to book more things
in future which is what you're trying to
do at the end of the
day um and then so how to get experience
when you have no experience so on that
sessionization list the recent speaking
stuff that I've done and also media if
you've never spoken at a conference and
you would like to talk at a conference
the easiest thing you can do is just to
make LinkedIn videos where you're
talking about a topic that you like so
just you can be talking to camera um or
you can film something on loom or on
Zoom or on Cisco WebEx where you're
sharing slides and talking to them being
able to do those Little Snips of video
content is really easy content to crank
out but it's also showing that you can
talk to camera um even if no one's
booked you to do that so you can take
control of that and really just get
ahead of that um it's sort of like when
you buy scissors and they're in a
plastic container and you need scissors
to cut the scissors out of the container
so you can get in and it's just this
whole Loop ordeal but getting ahead of
this and just thinking about what can I
actually do ahead of this some of the
media that I put down those are written
articles that I've submitted to
Publications or interviews that I've
done for different events and things so
it's all about just showing that hello
I'm the real person I have communic
iation skills finding different ways to
do that will help you so much especially
if it does get down to two or three of
you that the conference organizers are
trying to work out who will be a safe
bet because at the end of the day if
they're selling tickets they want to put
on a great event so just being able to
show that you can deliver on what you're
saying to deliver get creative and find
different ways to talk about this um
even if that's written articles or just
getting in your habit of doing some
video content somewhere that you can
link to show that you are a real person
and you can do this we'll go and
absolutely long way even if you've never
been booked to speak somewhere
before um if this is relevant to you so
I went to the global diversity cfp day
it's a worldwide event but there's
normally some in Capital Cities there's
definitely one in Brisbane that I went
to um it was in either January or
February and they fully showed us how to
write speaker Biers descriptions even
things like stagecraft there's also
really good resources on their website
um if you or anyone you manage is a
member of a diverse Community really get
them to apply to this and go along it
was honestly one of the most positive
things I did in terms of giving myself
confidence to speak so it's a great
initiative to get involved with um
additionally if you are from a large
employer and you would like to sponsor
them I'm not affiliated with them I just
went to their event it was fantastic
definitely sponsor it put money behind
it if you're ever someone that's
complained that you couldn't get a
diverse range of speakers through your
event this is a great way to help the
pipeline of speakers and to give people
confidence that are from diverse
backgrounds so it was really fantastic
um the other side is I also became an
AWS Community Builder um so this is sort
of a there's a QR code to join the wait
list I believe for the next round this
is my LinkedIn post I did about it it's
a community they help you to write more
to learn how to write content to learn
how to create video content um I've
already booked two speaking things
through this because they've helped me
to find the cfps to send into um this is
just the one that I'm I'm sure there's
the Microsoft MVP program is probably
the most similar one from Microsoft I'm
I'm sure there's one from Google I'm
sure there's one for whatever platform
it is that you're really interested in
get in touch with someone from their
Community team or from their marketing
team something find them on LinkedIn and
work out how you can actually get
involved because all of these vendors
want community members to be able to
speak at their events they want people
to be able to put out content that's
relevant to what they're doing from a
company side so just work with them um
and work out how you can use that as a
spring board so I'm in the machine
learning program of the a community
build ERS and we get all sorts of
benefits and things like that that
really helped out over time um I wish I
had known about this earlier I would
have joined earlier I think it's quite a
new program but definitely apply if this
is something that's relevant to you or
apply to whatever it is that's relevant
to the stack that you work with so when
you've made your vend diagram of things
you're actually working with work out
how to hone in on that and then make use
of the resources that are available to
you because I promise you there is
someone in marketing at each and every
Tech platform who would be absolutely
delighted to receive an email saying
hello how do I get involved so just make
the most of those resources that are
actually available to you um this is my
closing second last closing slide so
first of all when I was saying earlier
about how your employer really likes it
if you do speaking because it can help
them the really big reason for that is
because it helps to recruit people um if
anyone would like a job at blackbook uh
there's a QR code to get to our work
with us page otherwise just contact me
on LinkedIn and I'll put you in touch
through to our general manager for HR
and things like that um this is how to
get in contact with me so my LinkedIn my
Twitter my dev2 is where I write lots of
uh my more technical articles if I put
the QR code here is my motivation to
keep actually putting content there and
the same thing with my Tik Tok that I
made less than a week ago um if I put
the link here I'll be forced to keep
looking so that's my final closing slide
and now I'm excited to get into any
questions if there are
any hey Brooke yes oh that was an
inspirational talk
uh there's so many takeaways here I've
got I got three pages of notes already
um uh yeah I definitely need to learn a
lot of your your tricks there your
formulas sound fantastic um cool so
there are questions in in the chat so
just call out uh from top to bottom here
the first one was um from l so his
question is how do you get over that
first anxiety of being on
stage um it's really
hard it's really really hard um I think
thinking about all the ways that it can
go wrong as an anxious person I would
already do that so I could hedge against
them so I already knew that it could go
bad and then I could just work out
different ways to actually push through
I think that's really important as well
um or just working out how you can get
past it the other side is that there's
really good text to speech and speech to
text things now so um before you had to
practice your talk by talking to people
which I have no interest in so um you
can record it on your voice notes
especially if you're walking your dog or
something you can just record it and
then transcribe that using AWS as your
whatever um and then look at what it
actually looks like because then you can
see what you're saying without having to
listen to your voice which no one should
be tortured with um and that will really
help you to be more confident in what
you're saying without having to tort
yourself as much and then so when you do
actually do it you'll be so much more
rehearsed um and one of those things
that will make it more natural for you
because you'll see about how you
actually speak and you're different yeah
that that's actually that sounds really
good I wish I did that I remember my
first public talk very little
preparation it was just I went in cold
and it hurt a fair bit was super nervous
and uh your voice changes and yeah yeah
and only outgoing people give you tips
so they're useless they're like oh just
think confidently before listen to a
pppe song it's not helping just do it
that's right oh wow look uh there's
another question from from Tien um
what's your number one mistake you see
firsttime speakers making all the time I
think when they try to be someone
they've seen on YouTube or Netflix or
Twitter or something they're trying to
be them pretending to be Tony Robbins or
something instead of just being them as
themselves one of the like the Tech
conference talks that I like going to
the most are when it's someone technical
just absolutely living their truth being
themselves and just getting really nerdy
on a subject that they're it's a special
interest topic or something I love going
to talks like that I think lots of
people do because they're super engaging
because you can just tell the person is
having the best time and yeah yeah
absolutely just getting into that
mindset of how you can that's why I was
talking about being genuine because it's
how can you do it for you rather than
what's your best Tony Robbins
impersonation or something yeah that I
now you mentioned it for sure like you
can see it uh younger speakers who doing
it or first time speakers I should say
um yeah they would have role models and
try and be like them but I guess you
know it's a lesson to learn that you
should be yourself it's much easier
being yourself uh rather than just
forcing yourself down a way of behavior
that you're not really comfortable with
but good advice yeah I noticed it a lot
because lots of the speaker role models
were all men so as a young woman I just
didn't I couldn't see myself doing any
of that so that's why I thought I
couldn't be a speaker because all of the
tips just were completely not relevant
to something I could see myself doing so
it's helpful so much for that mindset as
well I think I'm not sure what it's like
in Brisbane but in Melbourne at least
there's a lot of uh female meetup groups
a lot of tech female
speakers when we actually did a cfp for
another conference as well that the
number of women outweighed the number of
men so yes it's it's it's it's changing
it's uh all that the tools and all the
the resources everyone needs is out
there so uh it's it's definitely good to
see that change as well um cool now
let's see if there any other questions
um people have said that they've gone to
the uh the global cfp days I'm myself
included I went a couple of years ago uh
very useful like you say and they teach
you how to write your bios and um you
know be friendly you know don't use
things like
guys um use other terms everyone you
know be respectful um but I I'll go back
to one of my notes Here is uh about the
speaker bio right do you do you think
the length of your bio matters and
exactly what you put in there or is it
more just again like being yourself
being more important I think putting the
information in that you would be mad if
they didn't know about you when you're
applying for a conference is really good
and then that's why I sort of make mine
in two chunks so if they want a really
quick one it is there in a couple
sentences or they can add the longer
part and I think being able to move
between both of those is really helpful
because then you can just put the most
important things at the start and then
whatever they cut out at the bottom you
can live with or without but it will
make sure that you're being represented
in the way that you want to be
represented in that very cool also the
other trip is to look through loads of
people on LinkedIn um and see how they
summarize their work and how they talk
about it there's so many people globally
that you can sort of just pick and
choose and see what you like and don't
like so it's one of those things that
when you're being really observant aside
from the uh looking at the agenda of
conferences look how speakers talk about
themselves and see what you can see
working for you or not
working that that's definitely a good
tip um you looking around at what other
people do and again but yeah don't just
copy it right you know get some
inspiration for yourself um and you
don't want to write a story about
yourself sounding like someone else so
um another thing I I sort of noted down
is that your actual formula that you
said for your bio um I I've looked
actually I couldn't find Formula but I
like your formula I think you definitely
need to publish that somewhere and make
it a bit more known be very useful um
yeah no one tells you how to do any of
this stuff it's like that's right this
hidden secret that apparently everyone
who does it knows how to do it but no
one will tell anyone else about it like
you're saying the extroverted people uh
when I started ask someone a question
and they said oh I just I just wrote it
down is just whatever came to mind and
I'm like I'm going to try this it didn't
work it took a long time to actually get
one out but uh another fantastic trip
tip is sort of just more of the techy
side of stuff about doing all this is to
use PowerPoint to make your Twitter
posts or your LinkedIn posts oh yeah uh
wow I was using Photoshop but that's a
good tip well because what you can do is
you can make the background in Photoshop
and then just put the text on in
PowerPoint um you can even do that if
you're doing like the sort of social
image that gets attached to blog posts
and stuff I just set it up if you need
to set a template for your whole website
you can do that in Powerpoint really
fast um and then if you set it up for
the any sort of social post is the same
size so you can just crank that through
especially if it's information that gets
repeated all the time like your name and
your job title you can just copy it from
the previous slide and then just export
it as an image it's not supposed to be
for that but it works really well so it
does I can see it happening I'm gonna
try it out as well so hey Brook do you
want to hang around for our uh next Quiz
yeah we got the Tech quiz but this
requires that I need to wear a fun hat I
don't have a funny hat but I got a very
colorful one just Chuck this
on I did not bring a hat everyone at
home even though you're not on camera I
assume that everyone is putting your hat
on as well and I also I've got a jacket
that goes with it so you one sent me
the that's all right I'm gonna get this
nice and colorful somehow they actually
matched very lucky all right here we
go now everyone can see me me asking the
questions okay so we have the slider up
there and uh just would love everyone
that's on the live stream and even on
the close the streams to join in if you
sign
up we're going to run the quiz and
you'll be able to win some really cool
prizes uh I think the the top five
winners or uh positions get to win uh an
NDC Sydney hoodie and for the very
number one slot is a uh an NDC Sydney
ticket for next year I believe I think
that's the case hopefully someone will
correct me but
uh should join for that alone I have one
from all the
time oh they they're so good yeah it's
getting a bit hot now so it's not really
hoodie weather all right yeah I'm ready
to go uh so this is a a a techie
quiz
um and we have already got eight
people see some of the names from the
last session jumping in people really
want that
uh want that NDC
ticket all right who we got there Tim
comport JT Matt yes some familiar names
bman he's there
cool llama number one that has to be l
is that
Li I can't see the chat if that's
Li all right cool so let's just give it
another 30 seconds or
so and then we'll start the
quiz
um L says he's got his hat on yes that's
good
Li uh I think we actually got the same
colored hat this
time
all right okay uh well people are still
coming in now just be mindful that on
the live stream there's uh there a bit
of a delay what I'm seeing here and
what's actually going out on YouTube
there between a 10 and 20 second delay
so grab your phone or just go to the
actual slido link itself uh and play
there so um yeah definitely try and be
on the on the trigger ready to go get
your answers in okay cool I think it's
slowed down a bit now looking at people
joining so we've got 23 that's going to
be good for competition all right so I'm
going to click so actually Brooke can
you see the questions that pop out so we
can alternate I ask a question you ask a
question yes go first there all right
I'll go okay clicking start here we
go asp.net applications can be written
in any of the following except J Visual
Basic python or
JavaScript o
uh there's some Clear Choices already uh
but it's starting to mix up a little
bit uh and interesting here we go so the
the results are
in and the correct answer should be has
it to
guess python you can't write aspet
applications with python I'm not sure
how that would work if you even tried
but if it even would be possible but all
right so who won who's on the
leaderboard who came first Matt 88 all
right he was on the trigger there
cool uh K Magda Lambda number one and
Anon okay so I think we'll see who who
stays at the top there all right you
ready for the next question yes here we
go what does la and Q stand for or
link they're all very
similar and what does it stand for in
words not in its values
important yes yes don't I want to spoil
the answer we give it away oh it's even
oo there's uh interesting interesting
choices here La language interface
natural query versus language integrated
query oo interesting what's the answer
whoa so that was a surprise I think uh
yeah language integrated query we as it
for net developers use it fair fairly
often but uh there you go let's see who
who's on top Matt 888 and then Jimmy
Matt G all right here we go hitting up
the
competition next
one who is known as the father of the
worldwide web was it Bill Gates Steve
Jobs Bren Ike or Tim burners
Lee do you
know think I
know well we'll see here let's see what
people think so the answers are in the
correct answer is Sir Tim berners Lee so
he's been kned and yeah very very
influential man that guy uh changed our
worlds
completely uh who got the top answer
there Matt 8 oh this guy's on fire
didn't Matt win the last round I think
he did they might have yeah oh Maddie oh
what are you doing let's see what
happens you can only have one NDC ticket
so you have to share it right
uh all right Brook next
question cool um what does MPEG file
extension stand
for do people say
EG yes it's one of those words I never
say out loud I just
read
yeah I'm sure this one should be fairly
uh
straightforward uh oh Matt Matt Wick
said if he wins he'll share the ticket H
very nice Matt thank you all right what
did people guess ah it's almost even
split let's see what the answer was
Motion Picture expert group there we go
that's what it stands for I didn't
actually know that one so learn
something today cool and on top is it
Maddie it oh my goodness Matt G all
right so we got two Matts in the running
uh and Jimmy is on their tail all right
let's see what's next uh what HTML tag
can you use to apply CSS rules to a
document okay someone already answered
that one straight away
I've got a special screen here I can see
who's answering what uh not actually who
but how many people are answering for a
particular option so see who's in the
race
yeah all right the answers are in let's
see what have we got who got it right
who got it wrong correct answer is the
style
tag yes very important if you're a front
end developer you need to know that one
all right leaderboard we
have yeah no change at all and we got
Patrick and Chris new contenders let's
see if they can overtake we're at the
halfway mark now next question Brooke
who is considered as the world's first
computer
programmer
wow Margaret Hamilton and Adele
Goldberg I've heard a few of those
names oh come
on everybody hopefully everybody knows
this
one what have we got what's the
results o cool small mixture there but
let's see what's the answer aah love La
yes there we go she was the first
computer programmer a very very famous
lady and who's in the running here oh so
I think Chris got knocked off at the
bottom there so JT's back all right next
question we've got how many players are
there in the touring test that's
interesting I don't actually know the
answer to this one so here we
go lucky the answers are pre-programmed
I don't have to choose it
myself what do we got what we
[Music]
got I can I can certainly see people are
thinking hard about this one look at
that so uh is it is it two players I
think
so no it's three players okay cool
whatever that means I have to look that
up now but uh what do you do with three
players in the touring test okay we'll
have to figure it out all right who's on
top Maddie Maddy Patrick Jimmy and
JT all right Brook next
question which language came first
Fortran cobal lisp or
PL I also would like to know if there's
a prize for whoever gets all of them
wrong on each
test that is something I would take out
if there was one that
just I wonder if we could do something
like that a special
hoodie all right people are thinking
Fortran was the the the first or the
oldest language I guess let's see if
that's
correct yes it is wow very nice L says
there is a the spoon award uh for for
getting everything wrong but I think we
follow L's tip
car that would be funny um all right
who's on
top we have Matt 88 so we're on uh eight
out of 10 questions already so
nearly there nearly there next question
is which of the following JavaScript
evaluates to True oh wow false is equal
to null false is equal to false false is
undefined and false is zero okay yeah
there must be a lot of JavaScript
developers out here
um so people after that wooden spoon
cool all right let's see who what is
true all these falsehoods being true how
does that work uh leaderboard so false
equals zero yeah zero is false sounds
good that's just probably a weird way of
how JavaScript works but hey people seem
to know the answer and who got it on
most I
think you're right that's right
surprising it definitely stri up the
leaderboard a bit La Lama one's back and
um I forget who someone dropped off
there but oh good m still on top genius
far
next
question what did NDC originally stand
for was a bunch of options
there hope everyone actually know so
that's
unfortunate well that would be
interesting yeah there is a company
called n actually do a lot of angular
front end stuff
yeah what was the answer everyone thinks
it's the Norwegian developers conference
and I think they are
correct there we go it's definitely all
started all in Oslo uh you know many
years ago maybe Jacob can give us a full
history again one day but uh let's see
who who's on top no surprises Matt G is
second uh and the Llamas on their tail
all right so I think now we're gonna
have the last question
Brooke uh let's see finish quiz oh no no
that was one we that was them oh so Matt
G was actually at the top sorry I
thought it was one more Matt G you're on
the top no was it mat Wick I can't see
the quiz now what
happened let's see if I can get back to
the results quickly view results uh in
the
end no I can't see the results I can see
the leaderboard one second let me get
everything back on track all right with
nine out of 10 points yes it was Matt
Wicks on top second plays with Matt G
and JT llama one Jimmy and Patrick so
Matt uh wix is the kind enough to say
that he will donate his NDC ticket to uh
someone else uh I think ol leave up to
Matt wck to decide who that is I don't
want to choose for him uh then we got
Matt G JT llama one and Jimmy who all
get a nice limited edition NDC Sydney
hoodie
yay thanks for joining Brooke it was a
lot of fun having you here than for
having me yeah no worries so what have
we got up next I have to actually look
at the the run sheet now um you actually
well yes it's time to thank our sponsors
you know without them this event 100%
would not be possible so thank you very
much and here's some
videos and finally the top spot on our
list of medium best workplace winners
for 2021 one rocketing up from number
nine in 2020 to the top place this year
congratulations to our number one best
workplace in the medium category mantle
group mantle group is a business that
truly lives its principles customers
rate its Service delivery as excellent
Executives embody the best
characteristics of the company employees
and management are in it together as one
employee put it the co crisis was tough
for many businesses
and watching a team of over 250 people
reach consensus to get through the
darkness together will be one of the
highlights of my working life to be
satisfied with great place to work here
for us as an organization is extremely
important it helps us translate feedback
input from our team and from the
organization to make us a better place
to be on Australia's 2021 best place to
work list is a great milestone it's
we're super proud to be amongst some
really great organizations uh in this
list we really put focus on on the team
U during Co times tough times we really
centered our business to focus on a few
things that really matter to keep our
team employed to keep people safe but
also to keep productive throughout the
last 12 months the message I'd like to
give to our team is a massive thank you
there's so much gratitude as a
collective group of people that make up
manal group and I'm super proud of
everyone's efforts to contribute to
making it a great place to work it's
never one person in mandle group it's
always a a team that collectively
delivers on our promise as as an
organization I love running this company
I love running it because uh of the
people I deal with there such a great
team of people from a career perspective
it's the best move I ever did being a
great consultant which we are atw is
half half between technical skills and
communication it's given me the
opportunity to work with lots of
different types of technology and
explore some stuff that I maybe only
dabbled in at University or before ssw
is a company that makes enterprise
software Solutions uh and that's what we
do we build software for clients uh on
demand we build bespoke Solutions using
the latest technology and the lat best
practices I've been involved in the
development of some mining software been
involved in the development of software
for a legal firm and everything in
between there even in just under 2 years
I've been working across so many
different
projects it's just a really great place
to come into and I always look forward
to coming to
work are you an engineer looking to
impact millions of Australians we're
looking for big thinkers problem solvers
and challenge Seekers to help us
engineer the future of banking combank
engineering do you have what it takes
search engineering at
combank all all right welcome back
everybody thank you will for the Amazing
Quiz I uh I love quizzes just pity that
I as host couldn't see the answers so I
didn't bother partaking uh we have now
our last talk for the day uh which which
is great don't go away after the end of
the talk though because of course
afterwards we have the prize draw so I
have to mention expo. NDC sydney.com if
you haven't ented yet um but let's bring
on our next speaker who uh again
familiar face hello L
hello and you're gonna talk to me about
ml correct yeah yeah in a way um yeah
it's it's it's a bit of a fun talk
because we're at the end of the day here
so um we'll have a bit of bit of fun
apologies for the open door but it's
it's getting really warm in here
now I've been sitting in my own um Steam
for a whole day so my my kids just got
home and it took them about four seconds
before they started screaming at each
other so I'm going to mute myself and
over to
you no worries at all oh yeah welcome
everybody see again I'm changing from
being host to being a speaker now but
that's okay um I have got it's a little
bit of a fun talk we'll see how long it
takes um it's something that I've been
dabbling with it's it's part of a
project that I'm doing Ad work really uh
which is a training project for for a
CLA Guru and I thought I'll share with
you and it's yeah it's it's about spam
uh I think spam is misunderstood um but
you know we can uh um share my screen
that' be great we can show the screen
share I think and we'll put that up and
we can we can get into it um
so no no no no not sh oh I'll just keep
talking then um so we have um oh there
we go just be a bit of um yeah so it's
it's it's a talk about spam there's a
bit of a humorous twist to it but
there's also a bit of machine learning
to it um there's a bit of coding to it
there's a bit of everything right so so
stick with me and again please ask
questions on on YouTube you know just
put them in the comment and we'll get to
them either throughout because I can see
them right here next to me or at the end
we'll see how we go um so I have created
a talk it's called do spam have an
opinion um and using machine learning to
understand spam and it's interesting
because I just realized um a bit ashamed
to admit that there was a talk on track
four room four um earlier even this
session before that was also about
sentiment analysis machine loading or a
bit step step further so I should
probably go first anyway now we go you
can always go back and watch it as well
so let me just see here here we go is it
going to change there we go so that's me
um I am supposed to say hey I work for a
cloud Guru which is a you know cloud
training company I do a lot of azure
stuff I do a lot of stuff on camera on
YouTube on our own platform um and it's
fun because I get to talk to people that
are really excited about learning new
stuff and I get to learn stuff to teach
it so that you can learn hey um I'm also
a Microsoft MVP which means you get a
lot of stickers for Microsoft um humor
aside it does open a lot of doors and it
means that they award you something for
all the community work that you do so
it's not a you're not employed by
Microsoft or anything like that um but
yeah it's um it's also what I have on
you know behind me all my MVP awards
because that's quite a proud moment and
you should take pride in your
achievements um if I take something from
um all the talks we heard today Melissa
and brookens in particular so I'm G to
keep going um actually it says my title
title is training architect um and then
the the HR System marked up I don't know
what happened but suddenly I became a
train architect and I'm just stuck with
it so from now on I'm a train architect
it has sounds so much cooler um and I
like trains so I'm a train architect so
there exactly all right so I am just
gonna get my notes hang on a second so
you if you watched the stream
earlier you might have seen the llamas
because those are llamas in the
background but what you also might see
is that there's a satellite dish right
so I used to be on
this not ancient but
somewhat rural internet connection um
it's called Sky Master which is the
Australian government's way of providing
internet connection to people that live
in the middle of nowhere like I do you
can see there's no neighbors around me
and and that's great uh the problem is
that especially because it was a
geosynchronous satellite it was really
far away really really far away like
45,000 kilometers which means that your
ping goes up now the benefit is that
there's only one satellite and it stays
exactly the same spot so it's very easy
easy easy I say that in quotation March
because nothing about satellite launches
are easy but it's an easy technology
compared to you know satellites that
move around and that also means that it
was always a problem um come on change
slide there we go there we go it was
always a problem streaming llamas right
so I talked about this in the break
before that I have llama Cam and it is
running and it is via satellite
connection um but it was never quite
amazing
so usually what would happen I've
actually created talks about this is
that the internet experience here would
be like banjo coding in the outback this
is an actual slide from a talk I gave a
few years ago because it's such a weird
thing to get used actually this is what
normally happens to be honest usually
that you get this the lag right and it
cuts out and you don't see anyone um but
what happened is that I I got starlink
right and I wanted to put this in
because it's such a huge change in how I
work with technology not just in what
we're going to talk about with Spam um
but it is in fact complete space nectar
so this system and this is just me
nerding out right now we at the end of
the day we need to have something that's
interesting right there's currently
about 1700 satellites rather than one
but they are instead of 45,000 km up
they're about 400 km 45500 km up which
means they're much closer to the Earth
which means that the Ping time is really
slow um um low right it's very fast
connection well the latency is low um
but they move because they are
constantly falling because of Earth's
gravity but they fall around the earth
essentially right so they circle the
Earth and that's why there's so many of
them in like a Super
Constellation and then that means that
the dish that I have on my roof now
moves to capture all the satellites and
it's very complex I'm amazed that they
made it work and now apparently there's
also satellite that talk to each other
so not only can we get it with a dish
that moves and catches is the satellite
that is here right now you can also get
it in the middle of the ocean or where
there is no because you need a ground
station so I my satellite goes up to
sorry my dish goes up to a satellite
that goes down to a ground station
that's how I get internet connection um
I'm just blown away so if you hear about
styling it's an absolutely fantastic um
invention just
marvelous um anyway that's enough about
starlink I think so the connection is
pretty good now I'm actually not um I
have better connection than most
Australians funny enough so it is a bit
of a um contentious issue with people
sometimes because they can't get
Starling if they're in the city usually
anyway we're gonna talk about spam um
right so we yeah we're not just talking
about spam but we're actually talking
about spam that for my you know my
purpose goes at s and a half kilometers
a second that's how fast the satellites
move and we all have let's say a
restrained relationship with Spam right
um it does help that we can kind of put
it in space I think that's pretty cool
that we have space spam now with
satellite
connections but anyway um spam is
something that we get every day right
some have spam filters that work more or
less some have not
um there we go I'm just looking at
comments as well please put them in the
in in YouTube actually I can move my
computer bit over here so I can see it
better um so please do put them in the
comments so I can see it all um and but
what is Spam like what what is spam in
fact what is it that we use um for
spam so the official definition and this
is from Oxford dictionary I think it
says what is Spam it's irrelevant or
unsit unsolicited messages sent over the
Internet typically to a large number of
users yes for the purposes of
advertising fishing spreading malware
Etc that Etc means there's a whole lot
of things that spam tries to do now when
I first read this when I was trying to
figure out how what how what I could do
with all the spam emails what really
caught my eye
was the word irrelevant how do we know
someone obviously took a lot of time
writing these spam messages out because
you know they send them to a lot of
people and they're hoping for a result
whether that's good for you or not but
are they irrelevant are they irrelevant
messages I thought well that make me
think H maybe we can do something with
this right now okay I'm gonna need you
all to go in the YouTube chat and give
me your answer to
this how much of the email that gets
sent how many how large a percentage I
should say uh of the emails that that
that get sent are spam what do you think
and I want you if you can that would be
fantastic now I have a couple of
suggestions here might be
12% um maybe it's
20% is it that high maybe it's 35% 40%
like how high is it it is it 50% what do
you reckon come on there's 42 people
here watching I'm sure you can uh give
me some numbers just blow it out 35% J
thank you JT keep going we got 20%
Michelle now I'm not saying you should
pick one of these numbers these are just
like suggestions to get your mind going
like give me what you actually think
right someone's saying
99.99% that's true in some cases I think
um feels like
that
yeah say because according to a survey
um in June of this year so not
that
84% the spam because they apparently are
irrelevant and
unsolicited right so in numbers 362
billion
for that's an over lot of data say yep
no
it's an
awful some people have taken to
analyzing spam in other ways which I
think is quite of hilarious so this is
something I found on Reddit um someone
got 182 spam emails in a week and they
analyzed where what categories that was
down to quite a lot of detail um I mean
there's the obvious like Viagra and UNS
six things sure but then there's also
gutter protection
sure what or business insurance in
French so I'm like is that really spam
how how would you anyway yeah business
insurance but anyway I found these quite
humorous because there's just always
stuff that comes out of it that I didn't
realize or didn't expect to be honest so
um what about this one spam sources
there we go um this is what who actually
sends the spam or allegedly um most of
it is finance and that's I don't think
that's completely
um unsurprising I think that's kind of
as you'd expect um but then I thought
something like online games would be
much higher but it's only about a
percent one a half percent um it vendors
I don't know why they do spamming stuff
anyway um but obviously not a lot of
global internet
portals um this comes from the old
school way of thinking about SEO that if
you have a link to your website more
places then it goes higher in Google I
don't think it works like that anymore
but that would be some of those internet
portals I suspect um but yeah this
interesting split of it there's a whole
lot of it right and then if you look at
something like fishing in in particular
so fishing is the action of trying to
get you to do a thing by sending you an
email right so it could be clicking on a
link or hey your if your um iCloud
account is closed or your your PayPal
balance is in the negative click here to
sort it out kind of thing those are
fishing uh emails and a lot of that
comes with fake invoices
and um I don't know if anyone remembers
the I love you virus in like
1998 or 99 but that was like a an Excel
spreadsheet that came with it's a bit
like a fake invoice that someone clicked
and there was a a VB script I think it
was that ran and it send it to everybody
else and just clocked up everything um
yeah what we
got the Viagra spam is insane that's
right Michelle um yeah it's um and that
wasn't my email account just Mak that
sure that clear um so a lot of fishing
scam tactics as well um but what do we
do with it like the destiny of all this
spam is Just Junk right we just get rid
of it and it just piles up like where
does spam go when it
dies all the data that is used on it
just sort of disappears and it just
becomes junk um we just disregard it
right we just click that delete button
and just get rid of it and I think we
can do more with it I think we can do
more with it so uh let's just have a
look I'll make sure I listen for any
notifications here so
um we um
often well come on it's going a bit slow
here
sorry there we go often it's a spam
filter um that takes care of it it could
be a junk folder uh we all have junk
folders um I'll show you mine in just a
second well screenshot of it um and then
we have the vicious delete button right
we all know this delete button we just
keep pressing it all the time um so wow
that is really jerky that gift isn't it
anyway we'll go away from the gifts
because that's but I think there's a way
that we can maybe coexist with Spam
right we need to understand it we need
to understand what is what is the
sentiment what is inside of this spam
and if we can do that maybe we can learn
to live together hey maybe I don't know
but we'll look at it
so um that is part of that was my
thinking for it I thought there was a
terrible waste at 84% of spam gets
discarded well most of it does at least
um and we just don't do anything with it
it's just junk right hence the junk junk
mail um but maybe there's a way that
spam can be here somewhere maybe there's
a a way that emails and pie charts can
live together
right so why not use robots or some sort
of robots let's use digital robots
um there's
a I think there's for us to maybe
investigate how this might work and we I
mean I'd love to use Wally but I don't
think Wally might be the right choice
but that was the best picture I could
find I think instead we need to use
something like machine learning because
I think machine learning can uh outpace
spam so machine learning in very brief
description right it's a lot more than
this is the study of computer algorithms
that can improve automat atically
through experience and using data and I
think machine learning as a tool now if
you haven't done any machine learning
before don't worry this is going to be
really simple um this is the whole point
of this is that you can use tools as a
technical developer type person you can
absolutely do this too um I'm sort of at
the very beginner stage of machine
learning I'm just dipping my toes in now
because I like to understand it more I
think machine learning is one of those
tools a bit like blockchain I don't
think anyone cares about blockchain of
in terms of consumers right I think it's
a bit the same with machine learning but
I think those two machine learning
blockchain as examples will be part of
many many many tools um over the years
or in in the future such as for example
as your SQL right now is using
blockchain for or you can use blockchain
for um log um what's the right word I
forgot the word not authentication but
Integrity like so you know that your
logs are correct and no one's fiddled
with anything in inside of of aure SQL I
think things like that is where it can
really improve the same with machine
learning and this is part of part of the
story right so um okay we still have
don't forget oops sorry move Mic don't
forget to um ask questions please do ask
questions so let's learn about the inner
workings of spam let's understand why
maybe what's the center behind it I
think that's a really interesting way um
so we're going to be using mys
spam right so here is my
inbox um this is of as of oh what was
this about a month ago I think or
something I started collecting spam
and this is a typical I I would say a
typical inbox for spam right so I have
something about sheds I have this one
which is the smoothie diet for some
reason I got this a lot so someone
thinks I should be on the smoothie diet
um
something about toenail fungus hey
fantastic um and then I've got some
creative stuff I've got cointry which I
think is crypto something Bitcoin
something like that more sheds and
something about diabetes as an example
here right so I took all of this junk
and I and I I saved it over a period of
time um and I extracted it so I I took
messages like this
one boost your horse tail and Main
growth effortlessly I've never thought I
needed this but there you go promote
Main and tail growth I didn't even know
that was a thing see I'm being educated
ecoin hair nourishment so I bet you that
most of you wouldn't know that this was
a thing either have you ever thought
about the equin hair nourishment
industry I thought so uh horse safe
natural ingredient etc etc right and
there's a link there of course God knows
why that goes I didn't click on the
links um but this could be a legit thing
I just I don't I don't think I signed up
for horse hair care I think um but there
we go so that's one of them another one
with a lot more uh effort I think that
was put into it was this one it's almost
like a poem you know has it ever felt
like fat is just stuck to your bones I'm
like I don't know not really that's how
it was with Jenny oh it's about Jenny
I'm not Jenny right and then it tells
about Jenny it tells the story about
Jenny um and how that she eventually had
this breakfast um trick apparently and
fat peel away I'm not sure if that peels
away but okay um and then it has the the
call to action right so click here to
see five second breakfast trick and I'm
not sure again I didn't click on it but
there's a whole story someone took a lot
of effort writing this I think um so I
thought let's take all of this spam and
let's do something with it like all of
it
so what were the tools that I used well
I am a Microsoft MVP in the azure award
category so yes I used Azure uh the cool
thing about Cloud technology is that you
can use very very compute heavy things
with a click of a button you don't need
to buy all the hardware and everything
right and this particular thing I in
this particular instance I used
cognitive Services which is a fantastic
tool um it's I'll show you all in live
in just a minute it's really really
simple to use it's super easy um all you
have to know is just this like a bit of
logistic regression new networks and
partial derivatives and you're set
that's all you need to know no you don't
um all you need to know is just how to
log into Azure portal um obviously all
of that is behind it for machine
learning but again I like mathematics
but that's another
level um and if I want to do a thing of
machine learning I don't need to know
what the mathematics are underneath it
at first I need to know how that affects
my project right so there are a bunch of
different cognitive services on Azure uh
we have some here here that are um well
this is not the full list but there's
some of them here um I'm going to use
what's called text analytics so that's
the one you can see in know second row
third um Square there detect sentiment
key phrases and named entities so
there's a bunch of things you can do
with text analytics not just what we're
going to do but there's a whole bunch of
them um and if you are interested in
this in in machine learning in in the
the sort of modeling of data to automate
it these cognitive are fantastic like
there's so many different things you can
do with this computer vision um that's
another one that I'm actually thinking
of using for my llama cam um I've
started using it so the that's the
bottom uh bottom row first Square there
says computer vision I thought I was
going to use I'm thinking of using that
for llama cam in the sense that when I
get um a notification and there's a
movement I can take that still image
pass it through computer vision and then
there's a model I can tell whether it's
a llama Or Not right and I've trained
the model I have the model going that's
not what we're talking about today but
as an example and I did all that in like
two hours or something I had just a
bunch of images of llamas a bunch of
images that aren't llamas like zeas and
giraffes and horses and dogs and
whatever and then a trains it so knows
what llamas are now I need to do the
next step but my point is it's really
really approachable even though it's
called machine learning and sounds scary
so we're going to use text analytics for
this um so I've created a text analy I
service I'm going to call it spam
cognition because we're looking for uh
you know cognitive Services we're using
that for spam sentiment analysis um and
it just it looks like any other Azure
service there if you're familiar with
Azure this is very stock standard if
you're not familiar with a it Azure um
if you create a storage account or a VM
or right it's all the
same time and then they almost become
sick nature
um so still no questions oh we got no
llama hair nourishment required Matt
says well I don't know um they do like
they they do look a bit raggedy so maybe
but
um yeah why
not again someone can tell me that like
aquan ban the llamas or something it's
same as goats I think anyway um
this uh text analytics service cogntive
service in Asia you get an endpoint so
it's publicly available obviously it's
authentic so um oh and you get some keys
and endpoints this is we're g I got to
show you where that is and how that
works right um and then we get an actual
interface we're going to use this at
first before we go into some of the code
um but there's a text an I'm actually
going to use version 3.1 because that
just came out just to uh you know mess
up my demo and see if we can break it um
but I am going to do a demo
so demo time right
so not used to standing up yeah I'm a
nerd I sit down um so I'm just going to
share this so no I'm not going to share
that let's jump over to bear with me
here we go so we have oh come on slow
slow slow
there we go there's the spam cognition
and I'm just going to get my cognitive
Services as well come on Chrome there
you can do it there we go so um let me
just make that a bit
bigger it's really struggling a bit here
I hope you can see that there we go it's
coming up yep
um yeah okay yep we got it all right let
me just make that a bit bigger as well
okay so let's start here so first of all
here's the service here's the spam
cognition service um there's not much to
it because everything is done for you
right it's already done the model for
you and everything um so you just got to
set up the service and then there's an
API of how you use it which I'll show
you just in a sec um so here let me just
show you the keys and endpoint because
this is all the bit you need right
um come on there we go so we have an
endpoint we have a location so the
location is important uh because you can
only access it in one location um the
way you created it for for the um uh for
the servers for the cognitive servers
test I'm GNA do in a minute and then
there's two keys right and they don't
show you so we want to we want to use
those keys to authenticate with it's
like a token right uh okay so let's go
over here to the text analytics API so
this is you can see on the left here
just within text analytics there's all
these different apis right so we're
going to use the sentiment
API and uh the name of that is here so
yep a e this is for my test and then
there's a few parameters that you can
add now I'm just going to go through a
couple of them there's more parameters
but we don't have enough time to go
through that um so show stats yes we
want to show the output of what actually
is the stats that's what we're
interested in this is we we're going to
analyze the sentiment of something uh in
this case our spam email right um and
then there's opinion mining I'll get
back to that in a second then there's
just a string index just tells you what
the format is uh and then in here this
key here the ocp apim subscription key
is the key from there so this in this
case it's key one right and obviously
there's two keys because you're supposed
to rotate them regularly so that key1
key2 becomes key1 Etc uh and you put a
new one new key in um so that's that's
how you authenticate with it then I have
a a body here of Jason very very simple
in this case um it needs an ID and again
this is purely for demonstration
purposes this is just to show you how
the IPA respon API responds right um
give language and then the text so this
one is a oh there's a bit of
a yeah you got to format it right so
I've taken all these uh um emails and
I've removed all the carriage returns
and everything and I've put that in so
it's all just one long string right that
goes in here that's the text and that's
what I'm going to do a sentiment
analysis on and then it also here it
gives you the actual request so this is
a post
request um this is what actually gets
sent to Australia East API cogn this
endpoint here with these parameters show
stats true opinion mining false and so
on um and of course there's a there's an
authentication key in there as well
doesn't show you that and then if I
click on send in
this that just sends come on here we go
107 millisecond response pretty good and
then I get a whole bunch of data to back
um so the top bit here is not as
interesting so here are my statistics so
I sent a reasonably long string from
directly taken from a spam email there
was no no cheating it was exactly from
it and um Amanda had tried everything to
lose weight but after having a second
son the weight wasn't coming off that's
the first sentence so the sentiment
analysis texted sentence by sentence by
sentence by sentence and it figures out
what is the sentiment in this sentence
right so in this case they saying that's
negative whoops sorry um this sentence
so there's a you can see it's just
standard Jason format there's a
sentences collection here and the
sentiment for the first sentence is
negative it's 100% sure that's negative
right we can see okay yeah well the
weight wasn't coming off could be that's
a negative then the next sentence it
says she tried all the popular plan like
Weight Watchers Jenny Craig even some
crazy fed diets from Dr Oz I think and
there's another weird character but
nothing worked and in this case it's 95%
sure that that's a negative and then we
get down to we've all been there right
and it's pretty sure that's a positive
etc etc so it's analyzing each sentence
for sentiment positive negative or
neutral
overall wow this is laggy there we go
this is the overall document sentiment
was mixed so it can't determine if it
was just positive or negative it's
mainly positive you can see the numbers
here it says it's 69% positive but it's
also 29% negative so that's where you
get a mixed back a mixed result right
okay
so oh come on I have a whole bunch of
them here let me just hang on a second
so I have a whole list of them so let me
just try another one just because we can
and then I'll get into some of the
coding stuff um okay so we have one
about Einstein and Tesla here oh come
on it's I think my computer's struggling
a bit so we'll see how we
go go all right so I'm just going to
paste that in so this one is what do
Einstein Tesla and even nostras have in
common they all knew something yada yada
yada so that's again I'll just copied in
I'm doing the same thing just so you can
see a different text here oh response so
I probably got something in there it
doesn't like
these Let's see we can oh no it's not
actually not the it's the double
quotation that it doesn't like because
yeah so this is a form meting thing you
could do that in code very easily just
remove or or change them right so let's
just try it again send that one there we
go response okay so in this case it says
it's negative whoops and it's 100% sure
that that document is negative right so
that's interesting and I thought okay we
can do this with lots of spam messages
we can put this through a whole bunch of
stuff but can we automate it well we can
now I haven't quite got to the point of
automating it but I'll give you a a
sample of what it could look like so we
are in Visual Studio good old 2019
because I don't live on the edge or
something um and all you do here is that
you um does a whole API obviously for it
so you create you to create you use the
new package hang let me just go into new
good if it will let me right click Come
on talk about
yourselves
wow it's uh it's not happy come
on nope oh there we
go uh no of course not because I clicked
on the file to get it to open come
on there we go manage n get packages so
I'll show you the N get package that you
need to do and that's the only thing and
it's an official Microsoft n get package
um
wow come
on yeah live demos good isn't it so oh
hang on click
installed I have just the Azure AI text
analytics uh new get package that's it
that's all you need right
and then we can go in and obviously you
can see here is my token that's the one
that was hidden before you got to put
that in somewhere don't put it in code
people all right never put these things
in code this is a demo it's a sample
don't do this um and then we have the
endpoint URL where we're going to talk
to and all you have them to do is then
create a text analytics client and then
I'm going to pass that client so that's
with the endpoint credentials that gives
you the the object the client object and
then I pass it through this
um uh function here which by the way I
got most of this from a Microsoft
example it's that simple there's no
point in writing it again um and that
client all you need to do is create an
analyze sentiment batch and you just
give it that document right that's all
you need to do now in this case for this
particular one I also get the um opinion
mining seg segment of it now opinion
mining is a way of um trying to figure
out where which part of or so which keyw
keyword you are
analyzing the sentiment about now I
couldn't get this to work 100% on all
the spam but I think it's worth um
trying or I can show you for a very
simple example it says the food and
service were unacceptable but the coners
were
nice was were um and that is a a way
that you can show uh something negative
and something positive right but we want
to find out what was negative and what
was positive what are they talking about
so in this case all I do here is just a
hug huge for each thing that I just
print out stuff right I just print out
all the the results so if I run this
it's just a console app Remember
um and wait because it has to fire up
come on build it um that does exactly
the same as I just this before on the
website right it's it's really that
simple now my point is that oh and it
goes on the other screen thank you very
much come
on so that now runs connects to Azure
using that token that we saw and here's
the score so that's similar to what you
came out before but format a bit nicely
um so what it says here is that we have
the aspect so the aspect is what are we
talking about like what's the target of
this sentiment in this case it's the
food it's negative which is what it says
the food and service were unacceptable
but we also have an aspect called
service which was also negative right
you say it's 100% sure that that was
negative and then we have the con
which was positive now this is very cool
because you could use something like
this to analyze your Google reviews like
if you run a restaurant if you run a
business you can in this case said
restaurant because they talk about food
um but if you have a business are you
and and feedback as we know I don't know
how many here get surveys out after
every single interaction with a company
yeah exactly everybody wants to know
what you think so that they can stand
out and be better I think
um and this could be really cool for
that if you automate this and you plug
this into um let's say a logic app on
aure which is also very simple to do um
you could have all the Google reviews
plugged into the logic app that then
runs a cognitive um service sentiment
analysis on it and then spits it out and
then you could know what is it that
people like and what is it that they
don't like and I think this is very very
cool it's it's very simple and all this
came about because I was looking at spam
I know um so oh we go is there a logic
app connector for the text analytics
client and Matt's already owned it yes
there is um and if there wasn't you can
just plug in an API by the way an API
endpoint you can do that with logic gaps
as well um logic app is one of those
things that a lot of developers sort of
look down their nose at to be honest
because it's not real coding because
logic gaps are one of those Services
where you just plug things in but the
they're so powerful and they're so fast
to use that it's like the point is moot
like it is development because you're
plugging things together it's just that
there's no actual code in it you can
write JavaScript to do little things and
whatnot but you don't have to and
there's plenty of other areas where you
do need coding so logic apps are very
cool very cool you know it's one of
those things where I would have that
table that says Logics are cools change
my mind um I just I don't see any
argument for why they're not cool and
they keep being developed and the
serverless which is also very cool I
heard
um all right so yep that was it for that
thanks for answering that Matt by the
way Matt yeah
no oh yeah you were about the Llama
that's right okay so let me just go out
of this um so this code example is very
simple come on close there we go there's
not much to it because it's really is
that simple but you could imagine if you
plug that into um know that documents
object there if you plug that into
something that you know feeds stuff into
it or or L but you can build your own as
well um so yeah
so where does this all lead us to then
so we've seen now how we um what we
create on Azure a cognitive service
entim text analytics client we know use
sentiment analysis through an API we can
get opinion mining even now I tried this
on larger examples and it didn't quite
work it usually had the object that
Target is just um null so I'm guessing
there's some work to be done on that
part but it's very cool when it works
um and it's always very accurate when it
does work so that's cool um and we've
now seen it in code as well very
rudimentary basic thing but we don't
have that much time and and I didn't
create a large experiment maybe I'll do
that actually this is part of a a
project like I was saying earlier that
I'm doing for ACG so this will be in a
much more polished and edited way soon
um on YouTube and our platform there's a
plug plug so I'll close this again I'll
bring up my slides again there we go
let's see
if yeah of course it shows why does it
always do that why does PowerPoint not
remember where you were uh which screen
was what anyway so enough of you Gordon
goodbye so this is all it is right it's
just Jason that you come that that comes
back and it's if you haven't worked with
Jason notation before it's almost human
readable almost it's that simple but
there are so many libraries that take
Jason natively and just works with it
and makes this all into objects um for
in your code that you can use so it's
super easy to use and it's it's very in
this case it's very simple Jason there's
not not a lot of um um fin angle or
tricks to
it so all right we need some results
because I did this on 20 spam messages
that I found that I picked out and this
is was my spam count in percentage
because who doesn't like a good pie
chart right I'm talking to you Mr
manager mam manager um so a lot of this
was about health because I think what
they're trying to do with Spam is
obviously the sentiment of it is that
they want you to you know something that
relates and health is something that we
most of us think about unless you're 21
and think you're Invincible but other
than that you know reasonable uh part of
us would would consider Health being a
part of what we you know strive to keep
on top of then there's shopping
obviously buy my thing there's business
stuff which is like business proposal
you know come and invest in this or buy
these shares or the crypto mining thing
um there's a lot about weight loss in
particular you could say that's Health
but it was it was you know there was
specific ones that were just about
weight loss so I put those in as that
and then there's one about the mind you
know so mental health kind of on the
about the mind so that was my split
right so what was the overall sentiment
like what was the actual result of all
of this an analytics and all of this
fangling going around with code and
Azure and everything where do we end up
so turn out that shopping overall is
very neutral um no it never seems to be
positive or negative you can see that is
overwhelmingly neutral it was just BYO
thing um Health was very negative and
it's probably to call an action right it
was all about hey you you know your
toenail fungus is really bad or you di
might get diabetes or whatever it is um
business was all positive hey buy my
thing it's
awesome right and weight weight loss was
sort of in between
um negative and positive and it was all
I added all this up it was a lot of fun
to put in um so that was uh um the
conclusion right it's it's you know
there if you got to form a bond with
Spam you you go for business
opportunities that's where that's the
positive thing right and as we talked
about with Melissa this morning that she
was talking about try and get into that
positive mood right negative Fosters
negativity so um yeah spam can make you
positive Maybe
that was something um right now just
before we end and we go into Q&A if
there is anything um oh yeah price draw
ENT the price draw um I just wanted to
pull out a few quotes from some of these
messages because I thought they were
amazing um so there's one from sheds
because I got I don't know why but I get
spam about building sheds maybe because
I live on a farm I don't know um but it
says here that I their plan so complete
they build themselves I'm I'm I'm amazed
that's quite the U quite the claim so
I'd like to get a that builds
itself I'm uh I'm currently building a
shed that's about a meter by half a
meter for like garden tools and that's
taking me six months already I don't
know what I'm doing so building
themselves that' be great um another one
President Putin has been using this
Russian method for years and is one of
the reasons he is in such incredible
shape it's almost like he wrote it
himself um yeah
yeah I don't know if he is but anyway
yep I'm G to leave that one there and
then about this one I'm I'm still
confused why do we punish a finger that
has done nothing to deserve it I I don't
there was no context why why are we
punishing fingers it's painful and this
is again what's the sentiment for some
it's nauseating to punish a finger plus
seeing your own blood in the morning
ruins your appetite for your frosted
flakes I don't know but yeah so don't
just discount spam
right because it it bring you humor and
stuff anyway my point with all this is
of course we don't like spam right but
what you can do is that you can use
asure cognitive Services um with little
effort if you even if you got a free
account I think you can still spin up a
cognitive service and you get like 5,000
um API queries a month for free which is
a lot if you're just doing you know
something like this a personal project
um it is kind of fun to work with
because you don't have to be a machine
learning Guru you can get access to all
of these different tools that do all
these different things like the one I
did with the Llama cam trainer model
like trying to trainer modeler says is
this a whatever or not or I can
recognize things right it's very cool um
so yeah I
think I ended up oh that's 45 minutes
not bad I think we're gonna go to Q&A um
so I would G to do that and I'll just
see if I can bring back
Dave I need to go back to there it is
hey hello Dave oh look at that you're un
mute
Dave I me I was here there's
Wally oh very good A bit of fun here at
the end of the day um so what do we get
a nice dessert at talk well I think you
covered all the questions while you
doing it you're you're a little Matt
answer it for me well that's true too um
I I mean I I'm curious other than llama
cam which you've talked about um I'm
kind of curious how this fits in like
whether you have ideas for what's next I
know you're begin home assistant that
sort of thing um what's the next thing
that you'd like to tackle with it you
know well I think to be honest so we so
we run a um like an Airbnb thing as well
and I wasn't completely kidding when I
said that it matters what people think
is good and bad like how else can you
fix it right if someone says oh the fly
screen's broken uh but the TV was great
like you need to kind of pick that out
now as a as a business with with like
one room it's not hard to do it as
people post it right it's it's not you
don't need to build a whole machine
learning you know operation to do that
um but something like that it's and I I
yeah as you said I do a lot with home
automation um and I'm trying to figure
out because it's so I use you know a
product called unify and there's a bunch
of cameras that I have and they all
bring in motion events I'm think I can
do something with those motion events um
and then tricker stuff but I don't know
exactly how that might fit in with
cognitive services and there are so many
of them anyway so there's yeah it's it's
I'm not 100% sure I'll just go a look
hang yeah that idea that makes sense to
me I have I have a couple cameras as
well and the motion events there's one
pointing out the front and you know you
can try to to tell it where to look but
then at night the headlights flash up
the lights on the fence and so it think
something moved so if refining that or
something would be yeah um I saw I saw
someone that had done it with with that
and and had a because the the cam a lot
of the cameras nowadays have an rtsp
feed like a real time streaming protocol
feed so with that's a local protocol
this is how you can see the camera on
your local network right and um if you
can somehow get that feed into something
that you know you don't want to send you
know all of it up to the cloud because
it's gigabytes of data right so you got
to segment the data and you can then use
those images to say hey is this a car or
dude that's in the carport right if it's
a dude or a person I want to know right
because it's not supposed to be a person
there those kind of things yeah it's
cool um
yeah well we can am I a host now or am I
still presenting I don't know this is as
I said before this is the weird
transition
before yeah I don't know um but no we
can talk about hang on let me just find
this bear with me with a minute here I
mean we pretty much have nothing to do
officially until the uh the prize drawer
yeah people should go and join the prize
draw right if they haven't already
absolutely submit I haven't I don't know
if I'm allowed but let's assume I'm not
yeah I figured I wasn't allowed either I
thought that would be weird um I did do
that once actually I was um what was
that I think it was my Jeep
Club yeah I know I'm a member of a Jeep
Club it's okay um and uh and we had this
Christmas thing or whatever it was and I
drew my own hat my own name out of the
hat for winning something I looked at
him I just back I'm like that's so weird
no exactly so yeah how many of those did
you bring so any I'm just looking up the
cognitive services on on the Azure side
of it so it's called cognitive Services
because it's for speech Vision language
and decision that's the last one
decision and there's a whole bunch of
services within that so it's like an
umbrella of a bunch of models so that's
what it's called a machine learning
world is a model that Microsoft has made
for you to use without knowing about
machine learning just knowing about apis
and code um and there are okay let me
just read out some of there speech to
text could be useful if you're doing
something text to speech again you can
get someone to talk for you speech
translation now this is one of the ones
that I think they used on Skype I
believe there is still on Skype um so
skyp still exist oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
um that's so rude now if you if you do
if you do use Scott right I use it with
my parents who are in their 70s I'm not
gonna make them do something else yeah
it's path of lose resistance but on
Skype if you speak speak English into
the thing the camera whatever it can in
real time translate it to German and
Spanish I believe and the other way
around so it does speech to text text
translation text to speech maybe no it's
just speech translation so it's a real
yeah yeah yeah yeah so it's like the old
remember that Martian thing from
cartoons where you're talking to one and
all the other language come out the
other it'sit like thatw um speaker
recognition I haven't try this one
identify and verify the People speaking
based on audio that would be that would
be interesting I don't know if your
cameras pick up audio but that would be
interesting to see if you you know if it
sees a person but it hears your voice oh
ignore that one but if it hears someone
else huh um but there's there's
languages so sentiment analysis that we
that I went through um you can do the
the usual bot stuff you know support
sort of like question answer things
those i' been boring um conversational
language understanding so enable the
apps to interact with users throughout
natural language yeah it's a bit sort of
still the bot thing is whoops um or you
translate stuff which is useful for
certain things uh computer vision that's
the one I like computer vision and
custom Vision um they're the ones that
actually use images to to visual to
analyze and to come up with stuff um
there's a face API that I know um my
good friend Hank Bullman who's also of
the DC alumni he did a lot of stuff with
that um about how you detect whether
people are happy or sad or what the mood
is that sort stuff
right he's also a total AI nerd and
decision uh I just GNA Say Brook uh
Brook actually in the chat has uh
recommended the Azure AI fundamentals uh
sirt people want to learn more to get
ideas so that's cool I can only
encourage that thank you Brooke that's
fantastic um yeah that's right there's
there's aert for that um I have not set
that exam nor nor looked at it so I'll
take Brook's works for it she's sort of
the AI expert in this in this uh
audience um oh Matt do you want to bring
that that question up there we go can
you integrate this all into a teams app
so it listens to your speech and lets
you know how casual formal you are
speaking I would say yes you can um I
believe PowerPoint has that inbuilt and
so I suspect that you behind the scenes
he's probably using those same Azure
services so wait what
yeah PowerPoint has a mode where when
you're doing a practice presentation
it'll give you feedback on you know
you're saying I'm too much or I haven't
actually tried it but I didn't know that
yeah
ible I say um all the time and I do this
speaker tools there you go thank you bro
ah see Power speaker tools this is so
awesome hey Brook do you want to do this
talking I think it' be more
useful um yeah that's awesome yeah I
didn't know that existed I've never used
it I'm G to use that next time that's
absolutely um yeah and speaking of Matt
uh Matt W who won the uh NDC Sydney
ticket uh yes NDC ticket for next year
uh he would like to give his ticket away
to a deserving student so if you are a
deserving student uh reach out to
someone at NDC uh I'm sure someone can
make up an email address what does what
does that mean to
serving uh well that's I don't know he
he didn't specify but 25 words or less
uh yes you'll find a coupon if you got
in the cupboard there's a rice bubbles
box and just cut out the CP does that
work for Lego too I wish
yeah and of course the the next question
when are the prizes being announced
well not long we are just waffling a bit
along here because we need to compile
the list and do the thing
so that I can draw the the people out
that's basically what we're doing so it
won't be long we're just waiting on the
Queue that's why we filling in the time
now with a bit of a and um if we did it
now there'd be there'd be three names in
that and it would be last David y I win
again
um cool okay
so um I don't know how we do this ticket
anyway I'm going to let NDC figure that
one out that's nice handball isn't it h
um because I I don't know what that
constitutes so I'm not a student well
that's not true I study all the
time but are we talking about student of
a institution or student of life or we
don't know well I don't know is that up
to end Ser is that after to Matt maybe
we'll let Matt work it out he tried to
handle let's handle it back yeah sorry
I'm just looking at the chat as well
um there's something about the open AI
ah They just added open yeah to teams
that's right um I think it's the teams
there was some announcement about
teams um okay Matt saying maybe Junior
de all right um good
idea yeah P get cop that's right so that
that's another one yeah that's the one
there's the question um that's cool they
being
Microsoft add open ey I think that's two
teams in Spec
specifically yeah there was there was a
bunch of teams announcements at ignite
that uh I haven't quite up yet so
possibly that one all
right uh I'm just looking sorry I'm just
paying attention to whether we are no
we're still not there not really
yet no not quite yet um yeah so uh I
think that answered the question about
what to use it for but I I am going to
do more machine learning stuff in the
next year I think I am not going to be
that complete in the depths of machine
learning kind of person I usually take a
practical approach to it so like hey
what can I use this service for um yeah
more than and I think it was like the
question and and answer from Matt about
uh power apps being able to access them
obviously makes that a lot easier as
well you know for sure perhaps yep start
start with an idea and then yeah you can
always add add code later rather than
having to work it out I actually uh I
kind of talked to occasionally there's a
there's a ml model builder built into
Visual shudio and I talk to that team
occasionally about some stuff and
that it's a similar idea where they're
trying to uh they will like it has a
mode where they will detect what the
best type of machine learning is so you
don't have to know necessarily the
differences until you know later when it
might become an issue so yeah it's cool
um there's a lot of new new things
coming in 2022 I haven't looked at most
of it um which which bit of it do you
work on 2022 don't you yeah yeah which
bit of it did
you
well in the biggest the biggest bit I
worked on it helped with is hot reload
um oh right oh nice the theet 62022
thing if we ignore all the drama
um I wasn't gonna go there it's you got
you gotta say it otherwise everyone does
it is exactly it's all good there um but
yeah I I don't know I do a few things I
uh I I work on razor tooling as well so
uh hopefully yeah there's a new editor
for Razer files so yeah I do stuff I do
stuff I do stuff too my my proudest
achievement so far is is in net 6 uh
every single pdb that is produced by the
compiler is teeny tiny bit bigger thanks
to
me I just put my name in everyone yeah
just Dave was here that's right
increment count plus one y exactly
that's right look we've make a mark a do
it
exactly oh man H all right well I think
that we are going to go to uh show a few
ads for our sponsors because we cannot
do this without sponsors we seriously
cannot um and then when we come back we
should be good to do some
prizes
good
and finally the top spot on our list of
medium best workplace winners for 2021
rocketing up from number nine in 2020 to
the top place this year congratulations
to our number one best workplace in the
medium category mantle
group mantle group is a business that
truly lives its principles customers
rate its Service delivery as excellent
Executives embody the best
characteristics of the company employees
and management are in it together as one
employee put it the co crisis was tough
for many businesses and watching a team
of over 250 people reach consensus to
get through the darkness together will
be one of the highlights of my working
life to be satified with great place to
work here for us as an organization is
extremely important it helps us
translate feedback input from our team
and from the organization to make us a
better place to be on Australia's 2021
best place to work list is a great
milestone it's we're super proud to be
amongst some really great organizations
uh in this list we really put focus on
on the team um during covid times tough
times we really centered our business to
focus on a few things that really matter
to keep our team employed to keep people
safe but also to keep productive
throughout the last 12 months
the message I'd like to give to our team
is a massive thank you there's so much
gratitude as a collective group of
people that make up mandle group and I'm
super proud of everyone's efforts to
contribute to making it a great place to
work it's never one person in mandle
group it's always a a team that
collectively delivers on our promise as
as an
organization
are you an engineer looking to impact
millions of Australians we're looking
for big thinkers problem solvers and
challenge Seekers to help us engineer
the future of banking combank
engineering do you have what it takes
search engineering at
[Music]
combank
I love running this company I love
running it because uh of the people I
deal with there such a great team of
people from a career perspective it's
best move I ever did being a great
consultant which we are at thisw is half
half between technical skills and
communication it's given me the
opportunity to work with lots of
different types of technology and
explore some stuff that I maybe only
dabbled in at University or before sssw
is a company that makes enterprise
software Solutions uh and that's what we
do we build software for clients uh on
demand we build bespoke Solutions using
the latest technology and the latest
best practice
I've been involved in the development of
some mining software been involved in
the development of software for a legal
firm and everything in between there
even in just under 2 years I've been
working across so many different
projects it's just a really great place
to come into and I always look forward
to coming to
[Applause]
work when you're talking Sovereign ICT
capability it's more than a safe Pair of
Hands it's people with very specialized
capabilities it's why we created telra
purple but talking is one thing being
able to walk the walk is
another we've supported all levels of
government across Australia with
customized Technology
Solutions we hope government agencies
cope with a huge increase in demand for
support in times of need all while
shifting to remote working themselves
and our long-term collaboration with
ambulance Victoria resulted in a digital
platform that came to the rescue in a
national emergency
a perfect example of how adaptable
purpose-driven technology can be We
Believe purposeful technology inspired
and delivered by people can make the
difference we believe we're uniquely
poised to help write Australia's next
chapter with
you all
right okay hang on a second here people
I got my head on but we're just getting
there okay all right so we're here for
the price draw that's very exciting um
we should be able to see the wheels
spinning I think if we can there we go
look at that we are ready now let's just
remind ourselves what we're actually
playing for here so if you've entered at
the expo. NDC sydney.com price draw you
can win one of three Amazon gift cards
from launch darkle uh a smartwatch and
10 zi fitness trackers from
ssw there is two Uber Eats vouchers at
$125 and apple airpods from combank Asen
giving away $250 gift pay vouchers uh
table giving away a Nintendo switch OED
model that must be the good one I think
um and we got a free ticket well we got
some free tickets for NDC conferences
I'm not sure how many can we get someone
to tell me that that would be great um
so that's what we're playing for right
now so let me just
here do this there we
go all right cool so I am ready for the
what are we doing here no don't do that
okay now I'm ready
hey okay well we can all we can all be
in the priz draw come on put us in it's
all right we just we can we can have
more we can have more people come on
William wants to go in come on William
you can be in the priz draw all right
and yeah we got three tickets for next
year three NDC Sydney tickets for next
year there we go hello William hello I
got my hat on oh good good I've got a
special head on this one has got so many
sparkles on it I can't touch it because
it get sparkles everywhere anyway um so
you just sprinkle that on the ticket
make it nice and glowy yeah that's right
so this is all based on your entries on
the Expo site uh to enter for the price
draws and I don't know who's in it and
I'm just going to click click and we'll
see with the first one is so we're going
to give away from top to bottom three
Amazon $100 gift cards so I'm going to
click to spin and we see if there's
audio on it I don't know trying to share
the audio um I canar oh you can hear
it and come on estan veano
hooray and we got to make sure that we
uh keep track of all these as well so
we're going to remove you estan because
you can only win
once and then click again and we're
going to go for another Amazon gift
card and I'm going to get William to
read this one out oh so
tiny it gets bigger oh wait for it Derek
Lee there we go hey well done
dere all right apparently there is more
than one Jason Taylor in the list a red
and a yellow one uh
oh well you can only win
once all right so the next winner is who
is it
Dave Nicholas ho
congratulations well done so that's his
three $100 Amazon gift cards nice and
don't worry we're keeping track of who's
winning and it's also being recorded
anyway so ssw has got now we're not
going to go the 10 zomi fitness trackers
we're going to do those after the fact
because it takes too long to be honest
uh but you they will be drawn and you
will be notified if you win don't worry
about that uh we are going to draw for
the Smartwatch though because it's you
can choose Apple or Samsung so when you
get in touch with ssw
just let them know if you prefer an
Apple or Samsung
Smartwatch um and here we go I prefer a
Rolex personally yeah smart watch or not
smart and we got Brad Brad Gman well
done you are the lucky Smartwatch well
done remove Brad as well all right next
one we have two Uber Eats vouchers $125
each from combank so that's going to be
you see who that is
William
[Music]
oh and people sitting there going no it
was so
close uh Stratton V there you go
Stratton yeah you got Uber
ech yeah you got that name to say um and
then we got another
$125 Uber Eats voucher from
combank all right let's
see who we got who we
got actually I'm going
to congratulations Kenneth anerson see
if you can dinner tonight that's a very
Danish surname well done
Kenneth okay and then finally we got the
Apple airpods also from combank We Gonna
Roll It
Away definitely do with a pair of
them come on who's winning
who Eddie lamb well then Eddie all right
that's awesome all right then um so I
don't know how to say it you're gonna
have to say it William aenx aenx how do
you say it a zenix yes fun fact it's the
combination of azure and Microsoft's
first operating system called
zenx you're right
no the first $150 gift pay voucher is
won by who is this
William uh Shane
rud I know Shane he's from net wealth
hello
Shane well done Shane all right and the
second
one from
aenx
aenx I thought it wasting system
xenix Zen yeah is JC hon on JC all right
and this is one of the big ones I think
I could imagine for all the gamers out
there one of the uh the Nintendo switch
console oh LED model does either you two
know what that means
is yeah new
screen new screen play anyway in the sun
in the dark
obviously super
cool hey and sunar if I mispronounced
your name uh well done you want a switch
congratulations all right and then we
have three tickets for NDC Sydney 202
and you do the you do the first one Dave
who is the first winner of the
NDC oh this is a good one who's going to
NDC hopefully we'll all see you there
just wow liong
congratulations that's fantastic well
done
Li all right and who is the second one
William all right let's see let's see
can I get yes no that won't
work yeah I'll just move the screen a
bit to bump to the next one oh your
screen's Frozen L give me a sec uh Sean
strandon well done Sean congratulations
Sean con and we have the last one the
very last ticket for NC Sydney
2022 here we go gold ticket but with the
same as the other non gold tickets yeah
do the same thing
though oh James D well done James ho yay
James that's awesome so as I said
there's still the 10 zomi um fitness
trackers as well we'll do those after we
end the stream and you will be notified
by ssw um with with how you claim your
prize for those and all the others you
you'll hear from them as well so um
that's all going to happen that's all
the boring ab and stuff so um I I can
just say thank you to my co-hosts this
has been a fantastic day um we had
everything H
we oh yeah a lot of great talks a lot of
bits in the middle there just chitchat
it was great I had a lot of fun today um
but now it's it's the end of the day
unfortunately oh can't wait for next
one I know it's a bit um anyway I yeah I
enjoyed myself to be honest it's I to
wear lots of hats there were llamas it
was
Fant
um hey look at that
Bunnings
hey L actually I just want to say thanks
to absolutely everyone in the background
Jacob Lon Tian uh Steiner everyone
involved with NDC Sydney today uh we we
get to do the fun bit they they do some
of the really difficult stuff in the
background Mak sure this all runs nice
and smoothly so big thanks to everybody
on on the background absolutely so with
that I hope to see you all at NDC cityne
2022 in person fingers crossed I'm going
to be there um and um thanks again for
joining us all through the day and until
next time
bye-bye bye
bye
I